NUMBER FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND GENERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH. AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THESE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
TESTIMONY BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY
WITH THE USE OF THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SYSTEM. FOR THE
WHO ARE PURCHASED REMOTELY
TODAY PLEASE MOVE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS ARE IT
PERSONNEL WILL MUTE AND UNMUTE
THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH
TO SPEAK THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR QUESTION
HE USED THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM ONCE
RECOGNIZE SPEAK PLEASE YOUR
NAME AT THE AGENDA ITEM TO
WHICH YOU ARE REFERRING. ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING. SIX THE BUSHEL THIS
REQUIRE ME BLAUT AND WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE ZERO SIX ZERO.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THE MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST USE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE NON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS ISN'T EASY. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
ADJUSTING TO THE USE. OR NEW
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. AND
PATIENT WELL INTERESTED PLEASE.
THE LINE. WE HAVE APPROX TWENTY
FOR DISCUSSION ON TODAY'S
AGENDA THIS INCLUDES PARTS A B.
AND C. IN ADDITION THERE IS A
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR ASSOCIATED
WITH EACH PART OF THE AGENDA. I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL OF THE ITEMS ON ALL
THREE PARTS OF THE AGENDA A B.
AND C. PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND VOTING. ONCE
WE HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS WE WILL HAVE
ONE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
ANY OF THE DISCUSSION OR VOTE
ONLY ITEMS FROM TODAY'S
HEARING. SUBSEQUENT TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WE WILL
VOTE ON THE AGENDA ITEMS. WE
WILL EITHER TAKE ONE VOTE FOR
EACH PART OF THE AGENDA TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS.
LISTED ON THE AGENDA OR A
SEPARATE VOTE IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WISH TO PULL ITEMS
FOR A SEPARATE VOTE. BEGIN I'D
BEFORE WE BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
LARGE PORTION OF TODAY'S
AUDIENCE FOR REQUESTING
FUNDING. FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY. THE PROPOSAL IN
QUESTION IS NOT ON TODAY'S
AGENDA HOWEVER I WANTED TO
INSURE INSURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THIS TOPIC BRIEFLY. A STUDY
PUBLISHED JUST THIS WEEK BY UC
MERCED IN MY DISTRICT SHOW THE
TRULY DEVASTATING LOSS THAT IS
BEING FELT AMONG OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
pGIVEN THE LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS HOLDING HOSPITALITY
AG IN SERVICE SECTOR JOBS. THE
STUDY SHOWED THAT BETWEEN
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH APRIL
EIGHTEENTH ONE IN FOR NON
CITIZEN WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
LOST THEIR JOBS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AN ESTIMATED SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND WORKERS AND IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT 42% OF THOSE ARE
ARE UNDOCUMENTED. BUT I KILLS
GET DESCRIPTION GET THE MODEM
AND THE BUT I GET A LIST TO A
BOIL US YET IF THE COSTA. YEAH
NORTH. IN THE ODD THAT THE
DENTIST OF MEN MOMENTO SICK
SEIZE AUGUST THERE MONO THAT
WAY IN WITH THE ACTION THE LIST
HE LOOKED UNA DOSIS GREW JACQUI
IMMOBILE SEE RELATE BOUGHT
pCOMPANY THAT MARKET ALTHOUGH
SOME OF CALIFORNIA KNOWS HE SAW
THAT ALMOST I SIAD THE PHONE
BILLS I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. SO BEFORE WE
GET INTO THE AGENDA ITEMS I'D
LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
VOTERS CAREER INTERNET NIELSEN
BUT I'D RATHER HEAR. WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. SO I'D LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE WHEN WE'LL BE HEARING
THESE LATER ITEMS THAT HAVE
BEEN REQUESTED BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO BE PULLED
PULLED FROM THE BOAT ONLY TO
DISCUSSION SESSION SECTION- AS
I SAID WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
THESE LATER- HERE ARE THE ITEMS
THEY ARE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES AND
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS EMPLOYEES
AND INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS THE VICTIMS OF WAGE
THEFT IN ISSUE THIRTY ONE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
LOANED TO THE GENERAL FUND. WE
WILL BE HEARING THEM- ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN TOGETHER IN
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE AND
THIRTY ONE TOGETHER. IN
ADDITION TO PULLING THESE ITEMS
FOR DISCUSSION THERE WILL BE
SOME CHANGES TO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. AND THESE ITEMS ARE
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER BILL ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. THE ET DE AB FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION NATION NUMBER
FIFTEEN THE D. I. R. A. B. FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS APPROVED AS
PROPOSED IN THE MODIFIED
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THESE
ITEMS OPEN. SIR. I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WHO ARE ALL
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. UP FOR
IT WE'RE GOING TO- START WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE A PART A OF
THE AGENDA. AND IF THE
DEPARTMENT OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
THE ITEMS IT'S- THE FIRST ITEM
IT IS ISSUE NUMBER FORTY TWO
FROM THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. HI EVERYONE. I'M IN
A FINANCE. WELL WE CAN HEAR YOU
THANK YOU. THIS PROPOSAL IS ONE
OF SEVERAL INTERESTING YOU
TYPICALLY MAKES TERRITORY
OCTOBER IN NAY BAKER PROGRAM
STOPPING IN BUDGET AUTHORITY TO
FROM WHAT ON ECONOMIC
PRODUCTION AND- BUT- REPORTER
FROM YOU MUST BE THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE CAN BUT- REFLECT. IT'LL
RESOURCES BUT IT YOU WILL HAVE
A OFF TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS. PAUL
IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD AND HAVE A
QUESTION IN OF THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION AND THE BUDGET YOUR FOR
YOUR WIFE PAYMENTS AS WELL AS A
INCREASE OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN POSITIONS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. PUT IT IN ON WE ARE
IN. YOUR FORTY BY ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND 50% ON DESPITE IN
YOUR WIFE AND UNEMPLOYMENT
HOLES. OF THIS TRAGEDY CREEK I
DON'T WANT YOU A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR NOW- ONE OF. SENATE SUMMER
YOU INDICATES. THAT OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ABOUT ONE
BILLION FOR THE STATE TO COVER
YOUR- BUT THE STATE HAS PAID
OFFICE BACKS I'M WITH FEDERAL
TAX RECEIPTS. I'M A RECENT
WEEKS. THERE YOU ARE TRUST FUND
YES ALL RIGHT. SO THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A FOUR HUNDRED. YEAH
DOLLAR BALANCE. IS THAT
CONCLUDE YOUR PRESENTATION.
VERY GOOD- THE- MOVING ON TO
THE LA. ANY COMMENTS. I YES IF
YOU COULD. IF YOU COULD ON MUTE.
YEAH AND IF THEY'RE RETURNING
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WELCOME. THANK YOU I'M
TELLING OVER THE LA- I SIMPLY
WANTED TO PROVIDE A BIT OF
CONTEXT AROUND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ON COMMENTS
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL- AS OF
MAY NINTH GIVEN THE- PRESIDENT
RISING UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
SENDS ABOUT MID MARCH THE STATE
HAS PAID OUT ABOUT TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN BENEFITS TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION UNEMPLOYED WORKERS AND
AS A MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
BERMAN FINANCE CHANGE THE THIS
TAKES YOU ARE TRUST FUND WHICH
PAYS BENEFITS BRIEFLY WHEN IT
IS ALL THAT SEVERAL WEEKS AGO.
WHEN THIS OCCURS AT IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT TIME DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EXTENDS. YOUR TERM
IS TO THE STATE'S ARE TO
CONTINUE BETTER. SINCE THAT
TIME YOU AYE PAYROLL TAXES WERE
RECEIVED BY THE STATE AND THE
STATE WAS ABLE TO PAY BACK
THOSE SHORT TERM LOANS. ON
THESE FEDERAL LOANS BECOME
LONGER TERM LOANS WITH INTEREST
IF THE STATE IS UNABLE TO
REPEAT OUT IN THE CALENDAR YEAR
IN WHICH THEY ARE RECEIVED I'M
SO WE'LL BE FOLLOWING THAT
GOING FORWARD. IN REGARDS TO
STATE RESOURCES AT EDT GIVEN
THIS ON PRESIDENT RISING
WORKLOAD. ON THE SECOND FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL
PROVIDING TWO ROUNDS OF GRANTS
TO THE STATE'S OBJECTS RECEIVE
THIS FIRST ROUND GRANT FUNDING
OF FIFTY NINE MILLION EXPECTS
TO RECEIVE. THE SECOND ROUND
THAT BECOMES AVAILABLE ON THE
CITY'S USE THESE FUNDS- FOR TO
COVER SOME INCREASE CALL CENTER
COSTS OUT OF VENDOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SETTING UP A
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAM. SOME STAFF
OVER TIME AS WELL AS REDIRECTED
STAFF SALARIES ON. SENSIBLE
MARCH TWO ADDRESSES ON
PRESIDENT AND RISING WORKLOAD
EDT HAS REDIRECTED ABOUT
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STAFF FROM
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
STATE ENTITIES TO ASSIST IN YOU
AYE CLAIMS PROCESSING. AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE BARMAN
FINANCE MENTIONED AUTOMATE
REVISION PROPOSES TO HIRE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY YOU ARE A CLAIM STAFF
UNDER THEIR TRADITIONAL
WORKLOAD BUDGET- UPDATE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION TYPICALLY
PRODUCES AND BACK. ON DESPITE
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THERE CONTINUES TO BE SOME
CONCERN- EDG IS. ABLE TO
PROMPTLY ISSUE BENEFITS- AND
ABLE TO PROMPTLY RESPOND TO ALL
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS INCREASED
THROUGH THEIR CALL LINES AND
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MAY WISH TO
DIRECT QUESTIONS IN THIS REGARD
TO THE APARTMENT DIRECTLY TO
THE KNOCKED IT OUT THOSE
ISSUES. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF COURSE I
YES. MISS UP AT. SENATOR
NIELSEN. WELL THE LATTER POINT.
THIS IS A CERTAINLY A NATION.
WELCOME ALL RIGHT. BUT THAT
SAID WHAT I WOULD EXPECT OF MY
COLLEAGUES OFFICE PEOPLE AS
THEY LOSE HIS LIFE. LANCE ABOUT
PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
THROUGH. IN ANY MANNER AND WAY.
OUR NOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STAFF AND THEN
THE ADDITIONAL- I THINK IT WAS
SEVENTY OF THE ANALYST HAS
MENTIONED THAT- I DON'T KNOW TO
WHAT DEGREE THOSE ARE DEPLOYED
YEAH WE ARE STILL GETTING
COMPLAINTS. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE BEFORE WE MOVE ANY
HAD ANYWHERE ON THIS ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE IN A VERY OUT OF MY
EYES TO. DISCUSSION OR REPORT
FROM DDD AS TO WHAT IS THEIR
PROPOSAL TO BECOME MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE CITIZENS AND
TO THE AFFECTED PARTIES. IF THE
EDT COULD RESPOND. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SHERIN HOW YOUR AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR AT. ME YES AS FAR
AS OUR CALL CENTER IT GOES
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
OVER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE AS
WE SPEAK WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS. AND SIX HUNDRED OF THOSE
WILL BE- PHONE AGENTS- AS SOON
AS WE FINISH THAT FIRE WE'RE
GONNA TURN AROUND AND HIRE.
ANOTHER LARGE NUMBERS OF STAFF.
AND CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE
CALL CENTER CAPACITY WE TO
AGREE WITH YOU WE ARE YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO MORE OF THE CALLS. I WOULD
REALLY TAKEN A HOLISTIC
APPROACH SO- TO TRY TO
ALLEVIATE CALLS COMING TO US IN
THE FIRST PLACE BY REALLY
RAMPING UP ALL OF OUR
COMMUNICATION. RULES US IS OUR
WEBSITE MORE WE A LOT AS EACH
USE ON OUR WEBSITE WE ADDED A
NEW BENEFITS GUIDE. WE'RE
UTILIZING SOCIAL MEDIA EVERY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION WE JUST
LAUNCHED A NEW PILOT LAST WEEK-
I TEXTING PILOT. HELLO PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND I UNDERSTAND
WHERE THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS
FOR EXAMPLE YOU WILL GET A TAX
NOW- SAYING- YOUR CLAIMS IN
PROCESS OR YOUR FIRST PAYMENT
SPEND MAY- THIS IS A PILOT AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS TO GET
INTO EVEN. FURTHER DETAILED
PLAN INFORMATION SO I THINK
THAT WILL HELP GREATLY AS WELL-
WE ALSO DEPLOY AT HOT ON A WHIM
SO WHICH IS OUR IT'S IN. TO
HELP. ANSWERING QUESTIONS THAT
CLAIMANTS MY HAVE. WE'RE ALSO
USING THE CHECK BY INTERNALLY
WITH OUR CALL CENTER A- AND
DOWN ALL OVER ME AND PROCEDURES
TO ASSIST AGENCY BETTER PROVIDE
IT RESPONSES TO CUSTOMERS- WE
KNOW WE'VE HEARD SOME ISSUES
AROUND THE CONSISTENCY OF THE
RESPONSES AND- WERE VERY
EXCITED TO GET THIS ROLLED OUT
TO BECAUSE IT WILL REALLY HELP
PROVIDE CONSISTENT RESPONSES
AND INFORMATION FOR OUR NEW
AGENTS PARTICULARLY AS WE ROLL
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE. THE NUMBER OF. WE GET AS
ALWAYS ARE GONNA HOW. HE'S OUR
ABILITY TO. YEAH BUT THERE IS
SO MUCH MORE THAT WE CAN DO AND
CONTINUE TO DO. AND IT'S YEAH I
AGREE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WERE
RESPONDING TO ALL THE NEEDS OF
OUR CLAIMANTS I WILL SAY
DESPITE THOSE ISSUES WE ARE
STILL PAYING THE VAST MAJORITY
OF CLAIMS ARE GOING THROUGH
CLEANLY AND BEING PAID TIMELY-
BUT- THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS
SUCH AS- ONE PARTICULAR.
EXCEPTION HOUSE TO DO IT
IDENTITY VERIFICATION AND THAT
IS AN AREA THAT WE ARE ALL
DOING ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH RIGHT NOW TO LIQUIDATE
THAT LONG. WE STARTED WITH
ABOUT THIRTEEN PEOPLE IN THAT
UNIT PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. WE
NOW HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN PEOPLE DEDICATED TO IT
AND WE'RE GOING ANOTHER
HUNDRED- STARTING ON TUESDAY.
AND OUR BEST SO WE'RE DOING ALL
HANDS MAKING SURE. WE GET THOSE
CAUGHT OUT- SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CUSTOMER LEFT ANSWER. SO
THEY CAN. IS SOME THE THINGS
WE'RE DOING BUT REALLY TRY TO
DRAW THE PROBLEMS. FROM EVERY
DIFFERENT DIRECTION BUT- AS YOU
AS FOR ALL OF US IN FEBRUARY
WHEN WE HAD A THREE POINT 9%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. WE HAD A
STAFFING LEVEL THAT MATT SAT SO
TO GO FROM THAT TO- AND
PROCESSING TWO TO FIVE THOUSAND
CLAIMS TO AT OUR HIGH ONE DAY I
THINK WE GOT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND CLAIMS IN ONE
DAY- IT YOU KNOW IT'S TAKE IT
IS A LITTLE BIT TO RAMP UP AND-
REALLY HAVE. THE MAN POWER
BEHIND IT AS I MENTIONED WE
REDIRECTED. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE. IN ET DE AS WELL AS
OTHER STATE AGENCIES GRACIOUSLY
HAVE COME TO OUR SYSTEMS. WELL
WE DO A MASS HIGHER. THE FIRST
ROUND AMOUNTS HIGHER IT'S LIKE
I SAID EARLIER WORK GET READY
TO HIRE ROUTE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE AND WE PLAN TO HIRE EVEN
MORE SHOULD WE EXPECT WHERE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR THAT WE WILL
SEE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS.
OF GIVEN THE PANDEMIC SO- WERE
MAKING SURE THAT WERE STAFFING
UP APPROPRIATELY. VERY GOOD-
FOR FOLLOW UP AND MAKE SURE
THAT THANK YOU DIRECTOR FOR THE
RESPONSE AND- I WILL BE NEEDED
ACTION MIKE. FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THAT THE U. R. REDEPLOYING FROM
OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL. I WOULD
ONLY ASK IN THAT THIS IS SO A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IF YOU
KEEP US APPRISED OF THE- STEPS
THAT YOU'RE TAKING. AND THE
SUCCESS THAT YOU FOR YOUR
ACHIEVING AS WE MOVE AHEAD
BECAUSE WE DO NOT WANT TO CLOSE
THIS BUDGET UP WITHOUT HAVING
ADDRESS THIS TO THE HI.
POSSIBLY THAT ENSURE THOSE
NEEDED. ARE A- SO OF PRE SHEET
THAT KIND OF COMMUNICATION
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
SENATOR DRAWS A YES- THANK YOU
SENATOR OF NIELSEN AND MADAM
CHAIR- I THINK THAT YOU HAVE
ADDRESSED AND RESPONDED TO THE
KEY ISSUES. I THINK AT THE
BEGINNING WE WERE- OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND WITHOUT A
DOUBT THIS IS THE MOST POPULAR
CALL. HANDS DOWN CALLS THAT WE
GET BUT IT WAS- AT THE
BEGINNING IS LIKE OKAY WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THROUGH WERE
TRYING TO GET THROUGH- BUT WE
WERE ABLE TO CAP
TROUBLESHOOTERS THAT RESPONDED
TO US AND GAVE US SOME FORM OF
A- OF AN EXPLANATION. THAT I
GOT TO THE POINT WHERE WE COULD
DO ANYTHING COULDN'T. TELL IT
COULDN'T GET ARE THE
APPLICATIONS AND COULDN'T GET
THE- NEXT UP WHERE IT WAS TOTAL
AWESOME COMMUNICATIONS. BOB I
GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY IF THERE
IS ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU NEED.
IN ORDER TO DO YOUR JOBS OF A
EVEN BETTER BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE- ALL WORKING REALLY
REALLY HARD AND- YOU'VE HAD A
LOT OF STAFF. BUT I WOULD URGE
YOU TO NOT HOLD BACK ON WHAT
YOU THINK YOU NEED TO BE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO FOR SUCH OF. A
MASSIVE RISE IN IN CLAIMS.
YOU'RE PRETTY MUCH THE ONLY WAY
THAT PEOPLE CAN. PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE OR- NOT FEEL THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET- EVICTED
OR OTHER VERY TRAGIC THING SO.
I JUST URGE YOU AGAIN COUNT. ON
JUST KNOW THAT YOU HAVE THE
SUPPORT TO DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED. ON MY WHEN A BOMB
SECOND THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WE ALL HAVE STORIES I
THINK THE REAL IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR ME RIGHT NOW IS THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT MADE AN
APPLICATION A LONG TIME AGO AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE SOME OF THEM MAY
BE IN THIS. IN THIS OP CATEGORY
THAT YOU HAVE IDENTIFIED WHICH
IS THE A DENTIST A DENTAL
VERIFICATION AND- THE SOONER
THAT THAT BACKLOG CAN GET TAKEN
CARE OF I THINK WE'LL SEE THE
NUMBER CALLS GO DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY BECAUSE- THE
LONGER IT TAKES AND PEOPLE GET
MORE AND MORE DESPERATE AND-
THAT'S WHEN THEY START
REACHING. REWIND SO APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT WE- POINT. WHEN
THIS PANDEMIC STARTED IN THAT
YOU STAFF FOR THAT THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE DO AND- AND I
THINK YOU'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS
JOB OF PULLING IN AS MANY
RESOURCES AS POSSIBLE AND SO
DID OR ONE ON LETTING US KNOW
IF THERE'S OTHER ANY OTHER
THING THAT YOU NEED TO HELP
YOUR GET YOUR JOB DONE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THIS IS
REALLY PROBABLY. STE OTHER THAN
THE PART IN A MOTOR VEHICLES IS
DOES THE DEPARTMENT THAT PEOPLE
SEE THE MOST IN A DOWNTURN
ECONOMY AND SO. A REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR HARD WORK
AND I KNOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN WORKING SEVEN DAYS A WEEK-
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT- THIS ITEM IS- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS ADOPTED MAY
REVISIONS PROPOSAL AND SO WILL
TAKE THOSE VOTES LATER. BONTA
THE NEXT ITEM. AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE NEXT ITEM IS.
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY THREE
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION REDUCTION
AND SUSPENSION- TURN IT OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU. THIS MERRY ALL RIGHT
FINANCE IF YOU. ARE GOING ON IN
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY NINETEEN
SAVINGS AND PLAY CONVERSATION
ON THE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND THEN REGISTRATION AT ALL
TIMES. BARNEY THE REDUCTIONS
ARE WE TRYING OFF IF THE
FEDERAL PROVIDES MONEY SAVINGS
ON AT U. CATEGORIES FIRST
CATEGORY STATING THE TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. OR
REALLY GENERAL FINDS I NEED TO
BE SHE- ACTION APPROXIMATELY
TEN PER OR JUNE TWENTY TWENTY.
SPECIFIC DETAILS ON HOW THIS
REDUCTION WILL BE ACHIEVED
RIGHT IT IS BEING NEGOTIATED
EACH. WE ARE NOT TAKING A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO THESE
REDUCTION AND WE ARE WORKING
COOPERATIVELY WHERE THE SIX
TWENTY ONE MARTINEZ. IN A WAY
THAT MAKES FIVE. EIGHT AND ITS
EMPLOYEES. WE ARE UNABLE IF WE
ARE UNABLE SAID SHE- BARGAINING
ARE YOU JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY YOUR RECORD FINANCIAL
REVIEWS. AS GLORIA SAVINGS OF
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
HIGHLAND GRANTED I REMIND
GENERAL LINE IS REFLECTED IN I
IN MY KNEE HIGH DRUG PRICES I
NEED A MAJORITY A COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED SALARY INCREASES THAT
WERE TO BE ACTED AND TWENTY
TWENTY. I NEED I NEED A HUNDRED
IS HUNDRED AND WERE NOT. ONE
MILLION FUND. THIS IS FOR A
STATE WHERE. IF YOU ORDER
SIXTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH
PAYMENTS TEMPERATE
AFFORDABILITY ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE RETIREE HEALTH CARE FREE
FINDING NATURAL CHANGES AND
ROLLING I'M HEALTH AND DENTAL
PLANS. GET EMPLOYMENT
INFORMATION. I'M ED IS A LIKE
OUT LA- HAVE ANY QUICK HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YEAH THIS IS NICK
SCHROEDER FROM THE LA WELCOME.
THANK YOU WE AGREE WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN AND THAT'S IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THE DETAILS
OF- HOW THE SAVINGS WILL BE
ACHIEVED REALLY WILL BE
CONTAINED IN THE AGREEMENTS
THAT ARE. FORTH COMING ALONG
THAT LINES WE ALSO AGREE WITH
THE MINISTRATIONS- APPROACH
THAT THE SAVINGS SHOULD BE BUT
SHE THROUGH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING- IF ALL POSSIBLE.
DONNELLY BECAUSE IT'LL HELP
MAINTAIN EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE.
RELATIONS AND ALSO REDUCE THE
RISK- THAT ANY SAVINGS WE MIGHT
SCORE IN THE BUDGET IN THIS
AREA. WOULD BE REVERSED THROUGH
FUTURE LITIGATION ACTION- ONE
THING THAT WE TO DO COMMENT ON
IS THAT THE SAVINGS ON A
REVISION. IS BASED ON A TWO DAY
PER MONTH FURLOUGH FOR TWELVE
MONTHS- AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ADVISE
THE- ADMINISTRATION AND
BARGAINING UNITS TO SEEK
ALTERNATIVES TO FOR LOW'S FIRST
BEFORE. AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO
FOR LOANS- AND THAT'S REALLY
BECAUSE FURLOUGHS CAN CREATE
LONG TERM LIABILITIES FOR THE
STATE FOR RESULTING FROM.
INCREASED LEAVE BALANCES AND
ALSO BECAUSE OF DESTRUCTION
LOW'S CAN CAUSE. IS A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR. RATIONS THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH BUT QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. FIVE I DO WANT
TO- THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
RECOMMENDATION AYE I THINK
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE THE. ON
ALL ALTERNATIVES TO FURLOUGHS
MAKES SENSE- OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
NOT AT THE BARGAINING TABLE IN
THESE KINDS OF DISCUSSIONS
HAPPEN- BUT THE MORE THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES CONTINUE TO
BE PROVIDED AND THAT WE TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THAT WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF FACILITIES
OPERATE TWENTY FOUR HOURS AT
THAT IS IMPORTANT THIS IS A
HOLD ON ITEM. MOST WILL BE
VISITING. THAT AGAIN TOM MOVING
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PENSION
PAYMENT ADJUSTMENT- IT TURNED
IT OVER TO- THE DIP DEPARTMENT
OR TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I SAID THIS IS ALL IN SEIZE.
FINANCE I'M THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM IS ACTUALLY COMPOSED OF
YOU ARE. HE SAYS TO IT I'M THE
FIRST ONE ALL THIS SIZE-
HOSTAGE YOU EAT CALPERS ANNUAL
PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE
ARE. SO SB NINETY AUTHORIZED
EIGHT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION TOWARDS CALPERS STATE
PLANS UNFUNDED LIABILITIES WITH
THE GOAL OF MAXIMIZING THE
STATE'S SAVING OVER THE NEXT
THREE DAYS. OF THE THREE
BILLION TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
WAS THE CHECKOUT PERSON TWENTY
NINETEEN. AT CALPERS SUPPLIED
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED MILLION
OF THE TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
TO PREVIEW SAVINGS AND ME
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. EACH
THAT MAYBE VISION PROPOSES TO
REDIRECT REMAINING TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION OVER THE NEXT WO
YEARS TO PAY THE STATE'S
OBLIGATIONS THAT WILL PRODUCE
MORE IMMEDIATE SAVINGS TO THE
STATE AND RESULTS IN A
REDUCTION IN THE STATE'S. THE
SECOND PIECE OF THIS OUT
PROPOSAL- HAS TO DO WITH THE
REMAINING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
I GENERAL FUND. NINETY THREE
THE MAYBE MEASURE PROPOSES
CENTURY CHANGES TO LIMóN EIGHT.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL. PENSION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT PROPOSED ACCELERATE
THE PAYMENT. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY. PAYMENTS TO THAT FUNDS
CAN BE DIRECTED TOWARDS SETTING
GENERAL FUND COSTUMES. PROGRAM.
PEACE OUT ABOUT IS- TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENT FOR C. H. P.
AND AS I MENTIONED AND THEY-
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
PAYMENT THAT WAS ALSO
AUTHORIZED UNDER ASKING NINETY-
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE OF
THAT WAS SLATED TO BE PAID TO
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
RETIREMENT PLAN TO BE DOWN
THERE UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE'RE BOOKING.
ARE WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
REDIRECT THE REMAINING TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILLION
THAT WAS SLATED FOR C. H. B.
HEY ARE OUT OF OPPOSITION TO.
THIS IS THE THREE PIECES THAT
ARE PART OF OUR- MAYBE PROPOSAL
FOR THIS ITEM. QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT. WE HAVE COLLEAGUES
FROM CALPERS ON THE LINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE MISTER
SCHROEDER. YEAH HI IT'S AN
EXTRA AGAIN- WE AGREE AGAIN
WITH THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN- AND
OVERALL OUR OUR COMMENTS ARE
THE IN THE SHORT TERM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS RELATED
TO- CHANGING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO A SUPPLANTING
PAYMENT DOES REDUCE THE STATE'S
COSTS- BUT IT AS THE AGENDA
INDICATES. DOES SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE SAVINGS OF THE STATE
OTHERWISE WOULD RECEIVE OVER
THE NEXT FEW DECADES THANK YOU.
GOOD COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS. VERY GOOD
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT INFORMATION
THIS IS THE HOLDOVERS. OPEN
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
SUPPLANTING PAYMENT AND RATE
AUTHORITY WILL TURN THIS OVER
TO. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OR CALPERS CAL STIRS. THIS IS
EVELYN SEES AGAIN. FINANCE AND
I'LL BE PRESENTING ON THIS I
DON'T. AND THAT IT SIMILAR TO
THE PREVIOUS ITEM THIS. HAS
THREE PARTS TO IT- SAID THE
FIRST ONE ALL DISCUSSES THE
SUSPENSION OF THE HOUSE STIRS
ANNUAL RATE INCREASES- GIVEN
THE CALL THE NINETEEN RECESSION
REVISION PROPOSED TO SATURATE
CHANGES THAT WILL SUSPEND THE
ANNUAL RATE INCREASES. THE REST
BY TEACHERS RETIREMENT BOARD-
AFTER TWENTY NINETEEN LEVEL
UNTIL. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. IN ONCE A CAN YOU
TO MAKE THESE PAYMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION TO REQUIRED PAYMENTS
THIS PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION GENERAL
FUND SAVINGS OVER A MULTI YEAR
THE STATE'S ANNUAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HEALTH
SERVICES. FIND THAT PROGRAM.
THE OTHER PIECE HAS TO DO WITH
THE WHOLE EMPLOYERS- EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO BOTH CALPERS
AND CAL STARS. AT TWENTY
NINETEEN BY JACK INCLUDED EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION TO
BITE DOWN LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION
RATES FOR BOTH CAL STARS AND
HELPERS. IN BOTH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- AS WELL AS A TWO
POINT THREE BILLION- HE MEANT
TOWARDS THE EMPLOYER LONG TERM.
LIABILITY TO PROVIDE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES RATE
INCREASE THIS CALL BELIEVE THE
MAJOR REVISION PROPOSES
REDIRECTING. THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OUSTER AND HELP HER'S
TOWARDS LONG TERM UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES TO FURTHER REDUCE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTION RATE IN
BOTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THIS WE
ALLOCATION WILL REDUCE THE
HOUSE SERVICE EMPLOYER RATE
FROM EIGHTEEN POINT 41% AT
LEAST SIXTEEN POINT 15% AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FROM
EIGHTEEN POINT 2% TO SIXTEEN
POINT 002% IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY CHILL. THE CALPERS
SCHOOL WHERE CONTRIBUTION RATES
WILL ALSO BE REDUCED FROM
TWENTY TWO POINT 67% TO TWENTY
POINT 7% IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND FROM 25% TO TWENTY TWO
POINT 84% TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO KNOW THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM CULTURES ARE ON
THE LINE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD- MOVING ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
MISTER SCHROEDER. THIS IS
ANGELA SHORT FROM THE ALEJO
I'LL ACTUALLY MAKING COMMENTS
ON THIS ISSUE WE AGREE WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO THIS
ISSUE OPEN- AND WE HAVE JUST A
FEW COMMENTS ON THESE
PROPOSALS. FIRST IN OUR INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION WE RAISE THAT WHILE
THE PROPOSALS TO REPURPOSE
CASTERS AND CALPERS
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS FOR
EMPLOYERS DO IT SHE AND BUDGET
YEAR. YEAH AND THAT SAVINGS
SAVINGS AND TWENTY ONE YOU TO.
THE ACTIONS WOULD MEAN FOR GOAL
AND LONGER TERM SAVINGS THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED OVER
THE NEXT FEW AND YOU READY
DOUBLE. NAME WHICH- THIS TRADE
OFF. IN ADDITION REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SUSPEND SHALL STIRS ALREADY TO
INCREASE THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION RATE WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRECEDENT
THAT THIS WOULD SET AND ABOUT
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THE ACTION
IMPACTS OUSTER IS ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE OR FINDING FOR THE
TEACHERS TO FIND OUT OF THE.
WHAT SIX AND THIS IS OF COURSE
THE GOAL OF THE FOURTEEN HOUSE
RESPONDING PLAN PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE FINALLY WE KNOW
THAT WE RECEIVED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR THESE
ISSUES YESTERDAY. AND WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT
LANGUAGE AND WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND
THE FULL DETAILS OF HOW THESE
PROPOSALS WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT AGAIN IS HOLD
OPEN ITEM. JT THE TESTIMONY
TODAY AND- THAT THAT- INCLUDES
OUR DISCUSSION ITEMS ON PARTY
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PART BE. WHICHIS THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESS SECTION. DEATH
SENATOR ON THE THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF. ISSUES AREN'T THERE
SOME ITEMS THAT WERE PULLING
FROM THE IN IN THE VOTE ONLY
YES AND SO WILL BE TAKING THOSE
UP AT THE END WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT- FULLER VOTE. OKAY SO.
ANYTHING THAT WAS THE OLD SPEAK
ON YES WE AT THE VERY END WILL
DO IT AT THE VERY END YES. OKAY
YEAH FOR. OKAY SO MOVING ON TO
PART BE THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESS. IN. THEY WERE JUST
GOING TO TAKE A MINUTE HERE
WELL WE- MAKE SURE THAT THE
AREAS ARE CLEANED. WE HAVE A
CHANGE OF STAFF. FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT ARE ARE WATCHING OUR
VIDEO. IN OREGON. BUT NO RIGHT
OF THE. REALLY. WELCOME THE NEW
STAFF MEMBERS THAT ARE. FOR
CALLING US IN THIS SECTION.
THANK. OKAY.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE
READY TO START ON AYE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL AND WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
SIDE OF. OKAY SO THE FIRST
PROPOSAL THEY SEE ON THE AGENDA
HERE YES OR THE- POST- ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES- SYRUP
MONEY STATE PROPOSED PROVIDES
CITIES AND COUNTIES- THE AGENDA
DOES A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
LAYING OUT HOW THAT MONEY
WOULD. FLOW OUT. THE ONE POINT
SEVEN ONE POINT THREE BILLION
OF THAT WILL GO TO COUNTIES-
50% OF THAT WILL GO TO COUNT
THE FORTY TWO COUNTIES OF
POPULATIONS BELOW FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. TOWARDS A COUNTIES IT
DID NOT RECEIVE ANY FEDERAL
ZERO WEEKS MONEY FROM HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY EIGHT. AND
ANOTHER- ANOTHER 50% OF THAT
MONEY WILL GO TO COUNTY
OPERATIONS OR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DID RECEIVE CHARM
FEDERAL- SIERRA FOR WEEKS
MONEY. AND ALL THAT 50% 55% OF
THAT AMOUNT WOULD GO TO. I'M
SORRY 45% AMOUNT WILL GO TO
THOSE BY COUNTIES THAT DID THAT
DID RECEIVE CORRECT ALLOCATIONS
AND SIERRA MONIES FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BUT WHICH
IN FACT HAD THEIR ALLOCATIONS
REDUCED BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CITIES AND THEIR JURISDICTIONS
ALSO QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
RELIEF. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT.
THOSE COUNTIES DIDN'T GET QUITE
AS MUCH AS THEY WOULD OTHERWISE
AS AN ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
FORMULAS BECAUSE THE FACT THAT
THEY HAD CITIES IN A
JURISDICTION IT ALSO
INDEPENDENTLY QUALIFY FOR
SIERRA. MONEY NUMBER POLICY
PROVIDED FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M STATES EUROPE
MONIES TO CITIES- THIS DOES
EXCLUDE THOSE FIVE CITIES THAT
DID RECEIVE DIRECT ALLOCATIONS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND OF THE- FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. 50% WOULD GO
TO THOSE SEVEN CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS BETWEEN
300-100-0500 THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THE MONEY WILL FLOW
DIRECTLY TO THE CITIES. AND
THEN THE OTHER 50% WILL GO TO
THE CITY'S POPULATIONS UNDER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND. AND
BEHIND GIVING- 50% TO SEVEN
CITIES WITH POPULATIONS BETWEEN
300-100-0500 THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BECAUSE YOU MINISTRATION
BELIEVES THEY HAVE. SOMEWHAT
UNIQUE- SERVICE NEEDS SOME
RELATION TO PARTICULARLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. BECAUSE
THEY DO HAVE A LARGE NUMBER
ALMOST PEOPLE IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND- UNDER
PREVIOUS MODELS SUCH AS THAT HE
GOT LOCATIONS APPLICATIONS.
OVER THE PAST YOU BUDGET YEARS.
THOSE CITIES DID RECEIVE SOME
ADDITIONAL ALLOTMENTS AN
ACCOUNT. THERE NEEDS TO THE
MONIES ARE BEING. ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THEY CAN
BE YOU OR- ACCORDING TO FEDERAL
STATUTE AND ACCORDING TO OUR
GUIDANCE THE STATE'S. RATIONS
THEY CAN BE USED FOR ANY ALLOW
PURPOSE UNDER THE FEDERAL
STATUTES TO. AND FOR THE FACT
THAT UNDER THE FEDERAL LAWS
ALSO THIS MONEY HAS TO BE SPENT
BY DECEMBER THIRTIETH. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. AND SO THE
MONEY COULD NOT BE USED TO BACK
FILL. USED FOR COVERT SERVICE
RELATED PURPOSES AND SO WE
BELIEVE THERE'S ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY AND THEREFORE
CITIES FOR EXAMPLE TO BE ABLE
TO USE THAT MONEY FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR
SERVING HOMELESS- EXPERIENCING.
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF THE
FEDERAL RULES AND REGULATIONS
AND SIMILARLY WE BELIEVE THAT
COUNTIES HELP. WHAT'S ABILITY
TO USE THEIR ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR SHARE. BY KOBE
RELATED SERVICE PUBLIC HEALTH
PUBLIC SAFETY THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO THAT CONCLUDES THE UP
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR-
ALLOCATION FROM THE STATE- RUN
BY VIRTUALLY FUNDS TO THE
LOCALS. I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS MAY
HAVE NOTS WORK THERE ARE NONE
RIGHT NOW I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
ON TO THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT RUN KEEP PEACE.
AND SO I WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON PROJECT RICKY. THE SIX SO
MILLION AS PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION IS THAT CORRECT. A
YES THERE'S TWO ELEMENTS WERE
PROVIDING ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE ZERO
MONEY TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
CRIMINALS AND ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE. MONEY THAT IS BEING
PROVIDED TO FUND THE PROJECT
REACHING PROPOSAL. PROJECT ROOM
KEY ON AS A SERVER SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE SIERRA
MONIES AND THIS MONEY IS GONNA
BE YEARS CHIU AT TEMPLE
LEVERAGE ON THE SUCCESS OF THE
CHEAP SO OR THROUGH- OUR
EFFORTS TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. ARE SOCIAL SERVICES
IN TGS IN ORDER TO- SECURE
HOTELS AND MOTELS OR- THOSE.
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS POPULATION.
FOR MOST AT RISK OF KOBE. THE
CURRENT ASSIST ON HEALTHCARE.
IN KNOWS HER MORE. OR OLDER IN
YOUR FIRST AND SO FAR THAT
EFFORT HAS YIELDED. SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CONTRACTING ROOMS AND
SO WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO OF
COURSE THAT IS ONLY TEMPORARY
THIS IS TEMPORARY HOUSING AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO LEVERAGE OFF
THE SUCCESS GETTING PEOPLE
HOUSE TEMPORARILY AND TURN INTO
A MORE PERMANENT SOURCE OF
HOUSING THAT'S WHAT PROJECT
SHE- YOU AT THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. SO MILLION
DOLLARS WILL WILL. HOUSING YOU.
AND A FOREIGN. YEAH THE LABEL
SURPLUS IT- APPLICATIONS DOWN
PROPOSALS FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES WHICH PARTICIPATE. AND
THE MONEY WILL BE USED TO
PURCHASE ON A- PURCHASE HOTELS
MOTELS AND OTHER APPROPRIATE
PROPERTIES THE PROPERTIES ARE
PURCHASE DO NOT HAVE TO
CURRENTLY BE USED- ART PROJECT
BRING KICKING THE OTHER. USERS
WELL. BUT THE IDEA IS TO TRY
AND SECURE PERMANENT HOUSING
FOR. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MOST
RESTRAIN THIS TIME FROM CRISIS
TO. GET OFF THE STREET STAND
THROUGH PROVIDING THE CARE THEY
NEED. SERVICE THEY NEED HOW
IT'S GOING TO WORK THERE'S NOT
A SECOND. MODEL YOUR STYLE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN EACH
SEAT ONES APPLICATION AND
PROPOSALS FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES. AND AGAIN GO AHEAD
AND WEIGH THOSE- APPLICATIONS
COASTAL BASED ON FRIDAY OF
FACTORS TO INCLUDE ON. THE
ABILITY TO EXTEND THESE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDS BY THE DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FEDERAL TO DATE ARE
DISPATCHED THREE CUT OFF DATE.%
AND ALSO THEY'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER THE ABILITY OF ON THE
CITY'S COUNTY IS AT THE TOP
WEBER SEES MONIES TO SECURE
PERMANENT- HOUSING. ALL THE WAY
ABILITY OF THE CITY AND
COUNTIES TO SUPPORT AT HEALTHY
ON AN ONGOING BASIS BECAUSE
AGAIN THESE ARE ONE TIME MONIES
BUT- AFTER. THESE DISABILITIES
TO HELP ONGOING NEEDS YOU CAN'T
JUST STOP BOB YEAH BUT KEEP
SERVICE NEEDS IN A VARIETY OF
MAINTENANCE NEEDS SO THAT'S
GONNA BE ANOTHER PRACTICE WAYS
UTILITY TO. OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
TO MAINTAIN THESE ON ONGOING
BASIS STAND EIGHT CITIES GONNA
CAST IS THAT'S POSSIBLE EXCEPT
ON PROPOSALS FROM ALL LOCALS
WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE. AND.
ADAM BACKWOODS- WHAT I HAVE TO
SAY ON PROJECT RANKING AND BE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE EITHER BY
ELEMENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL. VERY
GOOD OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M THAT'S WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.HE IS A DEPARTURE FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS I'M AS
WELL AS WHAT THE STATE HAS DONE
IN RECENT YEARS OF THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS ALSO.
THINK ABOUT WHETHER LOCALS ARE
POSITIONED TO JIMMY. A LONG
TERM PROVIDE THE SERVICES
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AS WELL AS
WEATHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE REQUIRED TO HOLD ON TO THIS
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS. PRESIDENT
OF TIME. AND FINALLY WHETHER
THIS IS THE BEST APPROACH TO
ENSURE THE STATE CAN PRESERVE
THE GAINS ITS MEETINGS. IN
ADDITION IN ADDITION WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES
PROVIDE ADMINISTRATION
SIGNIFICANT. DESTRUCTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE WANT TO CONSIDER
WHAT OPTION IT HAS RIGHT
OVERSIGHT AND SURE SUCCESS. SHE
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER NIELSEN. I WAS
VERY INTERESTED IN FAVOR REDUCE
SUPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL IN JANUARY OF
BECAUSE IT. WHICH INCULCATING
SOME NEW PARAMETERS I GUESS I
WOULD CALL IT. AND THAT WAS
ENSURING THAT THOSE WHO WERE
BEING HOUSED AT HAD ACCESS TO
TREATMENT AND- THE NEEDS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE THAT WOULD BE
EXTRAORDINARY AND WOULD
INTERFERE WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
GET BACK INTO THE WORK FORCE TO
BECOME GAINFULLY PARTICIPATING
IN SOCIETY IT WAS GOING TO
FOCUS ON THAT. AND IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE SUCH PLACEMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO BE TRACKED AND
MONITORED IF YOU WILL TO SEE IF
WHAT WE'RE SPENDING THE MONEY
ON. WAS IN FACT WORKING. NOW IS
WE'RE PROCEEDING TO A BEEN A
BRAVE NEW WORLD WHICH GREATLY
CHANGED SINCE THAT TIME WHAT IS
THE STATUS OF THE CONSIDERATION.
OF TRACKING THE SUCCESSES IN
AFRICA CITIES OF THE DIFFERENT
TREATMENT- PLACEMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITIES- AT TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
POPULATION SO THAT THEY DON'T
REMAIN DEPENDENT BUT THEY KIND
OF. GET BACK INTO THE
MAINSTREAM. AND I'M BUILDING ON
THE MODEL THAT STARTED IN THE
EIGHTIES WITH THE GAME PROGRAM
GREATER AVENUES FOR
INDEPENDENCE THAT THEN MORPHED
INTO THE NINETIES I THINK IT
WAS CAL WORKS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
CALLING IT NOW. SO IT IS NOT A
PART OF THE- PROGRAM MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FINANCE AND LEDGE
ANALYST ON THIS ONE. ONE MIGHT
BE HAPPY TO TAKE THE FIRST-
FIRST A SHOT AT RESPONDING- YES
OUR OUR ACCESS TO HOUSING
SERVICES PROPOSAL THAT WASN'T
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THE STUDY SITE FOR THE
OP THAT DID INCLUDE ON
COMPONENTS OF- WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. AND ONE OF THE LIMIT
SO WE HAVE THIS FEDERAL CROWN
OF I WAS REALLY FUN MONEY OVER
PROVIDING FROM THE STATE TO THE
LOCALS. OUT FEDERAL STATUTES
REQUIRE THOSE MONIES BE
EXTENDED BY DECEMBER. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DOESN'T LEND
ITSELF TO BEING USED FOR THOSE
SORT OF WRAP AROUND SERVICES
AND- SUPPORT HOUSING TYPE
SERVICES. WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO LEVERAGE THOSE
MONIES TO PROCURE. THE ROOM
KEY. PROCURE PERMANENT SHELTER
FOR THOSE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
MOST AT RISK IN THIS TIME
CRISIS. AND ALSO TO. GIVE A TOM
TO THE MONEY THAT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE CITIES
AND ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS THE COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
THAT TO THEM SO THEY CAN USE.
FOR KOBE RELATED PURPOSES AS
WELL. THE ROLE OF THE ALLOWABLE
USES. I'M HAPPY SAID ABOUT. THE
PROJECT ROOM SHE ONE OF THE
THAT THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
WHAT WAY IS THE ABILITY OF THE
BUT THE FUND RECIPIENTS TO
SUPPORT THE HOUSING ON A
PERMANENT BASIS AND TO PROVIDE
SERVICES I'LL ALSO BE SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE A CONSIDERATION
SO- YES YOU ARE CORRECT IN THAT
WE GET HELP TO DEPART SOMEWHAT
FROM WHAT WAS OUR INITIAL
PROPOSAL IN THE FALL BUT WE
STILL THINK THAT THIS
MAINTAINS. A LOT OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS WITHIN THE PARAMETERS
OF THE OF THE- MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE. AND THEN. ONE MORE
QUESTION RIGHT NOW MEDICARE.
THE MAINTENANCE OF ACQUIRED OR
LEASED PROPERTIES- WHAT ARE
YOUR PROVISIONS FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF SAID PROPERTIES
WHETHER THE STATE IS REQUIRED
AT OR IS LEASING IT. YES THE
MAINTENANCE THIS IS A KNOWN
THAT'S UNKNOWN FACTOR THAT THE
MONEY TO PURCHASE OF SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LACKEY
MAINTAINS AND SO THAT'S WHY
EACH CD WORLD CONSIDERS CARTER
APPLICATION PROCESS THE ABILITY
OF THOSE. LOCALS TO RECEIVE
THAT MONEY TO PURCHASE COPIES
ON A PERMANENT BASIS. TO
MAINTAIN THOSE PROPERTIES AS
WELL. UNFORTUNATELY THE FEDERAL
MONEY ITSELF COULD NOT BE USED
FOR THOSE MAINTENANCE PURPOSES
BECAUSE IT SUCKS. IT'S THE
EXPENDITURE DEEP DEADLINE OF
DECEMBER. AND WELL MAYBE THIS
FOLLOW THIS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE REPORTED HOMELESS
POPULATION DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU
HAVE NOW SECURED HOUSING
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR. MOTEL
THROUGH HOTELS OR WHATEVER SURE
THROUGH THE- IN THE EFFORTS OF-
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES IN
TGS WORKING WITH THEM CITIES
AND COUNTIES- CROXLEY SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CONTRACTED ROOMS HAVE
BEEN SECURED- WE DO OF
KNOWLEDGE- APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
THOUSAND THOSE ARE STILL RIGHT
NOW SO THEY'RE NOT ALL BUILD
BUT- HAVING SAID THAT OUT. THE
EATING TGS NOVEL CARTER'S DONE
A VERY GOOD JOB AND WORKING IT
BECAUSE WE THIS ONLY CAME UP
TWO MONTHS AGO IN TWO MONTHS
WE'VE ONLY DONE A LOT TO- TO
SECURE ROOMS AND TO BEGIN
FLOWING- RESIDENTS IN THOSE
ROOMS SO THAT WE REALIZE IT'S
AN ONGOING PROCESS. YEAH JUST
KEEPING UP WITH THE BEST A
KIANA AND BROKEN HOLES FROM
STILL SOON. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- FIRST ON
THE- THE BROADER ISSUE- YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE FUNDING DOES
NOT- IS NOT LIMITED TO HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS SIDE I HAVE A
REAL CONCERN ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE- OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND I'VE ONLY BEEN TO MY
SECOND YEAR HERE BUT I KNOW
THAT HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
IS SUCH OF CRISIS. AT SUCH A
CRISIS LEVEL AND THERE'S SUCH
ENORMOUS NEED WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY VERY HARD IN THE
SENATE- UNDER THE PRO TEM'S
LEADERSHIP- TO CONTINUE ON AND
BUILD AND REALLY- IMPLEMENT
SOME SERIOUS FOCUSED STRATEGIC
POLICIES THAT GET US YOU KNOW
THAT HELP US TO MAKE PROGRESS
HERE WE HAVE THE OF A WHAT IS
IT A MILLION AND A HALF OF MORE
OR LESS UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THERE ARE NEEDED IN THE
STATE. I LIKE TO KNOW WHY WOULD
WE NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
FUNDING. TO ADD TO THE TOOLS OF
POLICIES ADD TO THAT FUNDING SO
THAT IT JUST DOESN'T GET
SCATTERED I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE ENORMOUS NEEDS RIGHT
NOW BUT- WHY NOT. WHY GIVE SO
MUCH FLEXIBILITY TO BE USED
OTHERWISE RATHER THAN LIMITING
THAT TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. YES SENATOR WE
HAVE THE- APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE IN
SIERRA MONEY STATES PROVIDING
TO LOCALS- SIX HUNDRED MILLION
WILL RIGHT OFF THE TOP BE USED
TO SERVE ON. HOMELESS PERSONS.
JEFF RANKING. AND THEN- BUT THE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S WILLING TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES- OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT CITIES.
WILL BE WORKING BUT THERE ARE
CONTINUOUS CARE NURSE COUNTIES
TO GO AHEAD AND- REX ANY MONIES
THAT ARE USED THE SERVER BUT
ALMOST COMMUNITIES ON A WAY
THAT COORDINATES WITH ONGOING
EFFORTS AND SERVICES. THAT OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THAT. SOME OF
THAT MONEY I CAN'T PUT A DOLLAR
AMOUNT ON IT BUT SOME OF THAT
MONEY WILL ALSO BE USED TO
SERVE THE HOMELESS-
INDIVIDUALS. AND AS FAR AS THE
COUNTY MONEY GOES THE ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS- THERE'S
NOT A STRICT REQUIREMENT THAT
MONEY BE USED TO ANSWER- THE
HOME ALMOST POPULATION BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT. WITH THE- THE
CURRENT CRISIS AND- THE MANY
REVENUE LOSSES THAT COUNTIES
AND CITIES AND- IN ADDITION A
LARGE SERVICE LOADS. BY YOU
SOME U. PEOPLE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT. FLEXIBILITY TO GO AHEAD
AND USE THAT MONEY FOR OTHER
PURPOSES AS WELL HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. WE RELATED
THINGS ON THE- FEDERAL LAW SO
WE'RE SOME FLEXIBILITY. WELL I
WOULD CONTINUE TO INSIST- AND
URGE YOU TO- CHANGE THAT AND
MAKE IT MORE OF A FOCUS WE IT
BEFORE THIS COURT PANDEMIC.
HOUSING WAS NOT GETTING BUILT.
ON AND THEN WE STARTED MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND IT'S
GOING TO BE ANOTHER REASON WHY
CITIES OR COUNTIES DON'T USE
THE FUNDING FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS SO I THINK UNLESS
WE HAVE A COORDINATED POLICY IN
FUNDING STRATEGY IT'S GONNA
IT'S GONNA SLIP AWAY AND IT'S
GOING TO GO BACKWARDS- I HAVE A
SPECIFIC ONE ABOUT THE ROOM KEY
UP IN LOS ANGELES I THINK RIGHT
NOW. IT SERVING ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED- INDIVIDUALS- AND
MAYBE SOME MORE SITES COMING
AND SO MY CONCERN IS. WHAT'S
THE TRANSITION PLAN. FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOW IN
THAT- IN THOSE ROOMS IN THAT
KIND OF HOUSING- OF. YOU KNOW
FOR LEAVING YOU KNOW AND THE
TRANSITION. IT WAS THIS JUST A
QUICK YOU KNOW LET'S GET THEM
OUT BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC GET
THEM OFF THE STREETS IF IT
DOESN'T HAVE YOU KNOW REAL
ACCESS TO JOB TRAINING
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES-
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OTHER
THINGS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT JUST
GONNA WRITE BACK QUICKLY GET ON
THE STREETS AND WE'RE WE'RE
BACK ROW. MAYBE EVEN WORSE OFF
THAN WHERE WE STARTED SO WHAT'S
THE TRANSITION PLAN. THE
TRANSITION PLAN IS THAT- WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
IS. SHORT TERM HOUSING RIGHT
NOW THE SECURE NAY SO TELLS IN
MOTELS. BUT THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLE BEHIND PROJECT ROOMS
IN THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ALL OVER EXISTS TO
ATTEMPT TO SECURE AS MANY OF
THOSE PROPERTIES. ALL FOUR
MINUTE BASIS SO THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS FOR BEING HOUSE AND
THERE ARE. TEMPORARILY RIGHT
NOW. SHOULD HAVE A PERMANENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR HOUSING IN
THOSE FACILITIES OR OTHER
SIMILARLY SITUATED FACILITIES.
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
THAT'S THE PRINCIPLE BEHIND
PROJECT ROOM KEY IN THIS PART
OF THE- COST US. WE'RE GONNA
BUT TEMPERATURES. WELL THE
PROJECT PROPERTY FUND WITH
MONIES THAT. THAT THEY HAVE A
VIABLE PLAN GOING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THIS
FACILITIES BECAUSE WE DO
RECOGNIZE THIS IS ONE PINE
MONEY IT'S EASY TO PURCHASE THE
PROPERTY. CHIEF OPERATIONS.
THING SO THAT'S GOING TO BE A
FACTOR AS WELL. AND THEN
FINALLY- MENTIONED. CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN NINETY. IN THIS
ON THE USE OF THAT WHAT IS.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THIS A
PROPOSAL THAT. THAT THAT WOULD
BE INCLUDED IN THERE OF YOU
KNOW PRETTY MUCH NO NOTICE- NO
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT WHAT IS
IT ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL THAT YOU
WOULD THINK THAT OF CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN NINETY IS NEEDED
THANK GETS NEEDED BECAUSE OF
THE IMMEDIACY OF CRISIS- WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
MONEY OUT TO- MORE LOCAL
CORPORATE. ORDERS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE STE. RIGHT SERVICES TO
THESE PEOPLE ARE MOST IN NEED
AND- THAT STEPS THE GUIDING
PRINCIPLE BEHIND BEING ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT AND YOU THINK THAT
NOT HAVING LEGISLATIVE.
OVERSIGHT OR HAVING LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT WOULD STOP YOU FROM
GETTING THOSE FUNDINGS ON. WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT WOULD
STOP US FROM GETTING THE MONEY
OUT BUT WE BELIEVE THAT WE WANT
TO FOR THE MANY OUT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND I AM NOT IN A
POSITION TO MAKE ANY
COMMITMENTS- ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I THINK
THAT. I DO THINK THAT WE WOULD
CERTAINLY. BUT AT LEAST.
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE WITH ON
THE LEGISLATURE HOW THE MONEY
IS BEING USED IN TWO OR SHARE
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW- HOW
THE MONEY'S GOING OUT AND IS
USING AT BUT SENATE SHE- AND
JUST AND MADAM CHAIR I THINK
THAT'S A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE AND
I FOR ONE. WOULD URGE THAT- BUT
WE HAVE TO HAVE OF NOT JUST A
NOT EVEN JUST A NOTICE WE NEED
MORE SERIOUS- INVOLVEMENT AN
ENGAGEMENT ANDS AND SUPPORT FOR
MAYBE NOT SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATION SO. THAT'S THAT'S
MY LAST COMMENT ON THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR DR SO I
I'LL START ON THAT ON THAT
PARTICULAR NOTE IN AND SAY I
APPRECIATE THE INTERESTING
GETTING THEM OUT MONEY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- BUT THE
AYE AYE AYE I SECOND THE
CONCERNED THAT SENATOR DRAWS-
HAS WHICH WHICH IS THAT THAT-
THE LEGISLATURE IT THERE IS A
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN IN
THIS DISCUSSION AND- WILL HAVE.
THIS ISSUE COME UP A NUMBER OF
OTHER ON A NUMBER OF OTHER
ITEMS AND I THINK WE CAN
PROBABLY SAY DITTO FOR THOSE AS
WELL- IT AT THE ELEVEN IDEA TO
BE USED VERY. VERY
STRATEGICALLY AND- AND- I'LL
TELL YOU ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
CONCERNED IS- IN MY DISTRICT I
HAVE FOR COMMUNITIES. FOR
CITIES THAT ARE OVER FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IT THEN THERE
FROM 400-002-0060 THOUSAND
PEOPLE SO THEY GOT NO DIRECT.
FUNDS FROM THE CARE ACT- IT
THAT THE CITY'S NEEDED TO BE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE
LARGER. AND SO MOST OF THE THIS
THE CITIES AND I'VE GOT TWENTY
EIGHT CITIES. ARE A LOT SMALLER
THERE FROM THIRTY THOUSAND TO-
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND THE
PROBLEM IS THAT- THERE. THOSE
ARE THE CITIES AND I'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE MAYORS THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE HAD THE IN AN IMPACT IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND THEY'RE
GETTING NO RELIEF AND NO NO
RESOURCES AND THEY'RE CONCERNED
AT THAT THERE ARE- MAJORITY
FARM WORKER COMMUNITIES WITH
THEM- BLUE COLLAR WORKERS AND
SO THEY THEY JUST DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF REVENUES AND YET THIRD
THEY'VE HAD TO MAKE SOME- SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AND SOME-
THEY'VE HAD TO EXPEND FUNDS
BECAUSE OF THIS VIRUS AND SO-
THE- THE IDEA OF HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE COUNTY HAS THEM
CONCERNED BECAUSE MOST OF THEM
FILL IT DON'T GET NO MONEY FROM
THE COUNTIES AND I HAVE SIX
COUNTIES. IN IN IN THE- THE
DISTRICT AND SO ALL OF THEM ARE
SAYING THE SAME THINGS WHICH IS
THAT- IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM TO GET MONEY DIRECTLY
FROM THE STATE THAT THAT'S THE
WAY THEY'D LIKE TO RECEIVE IT
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH THIS.
THROUGH THE COUNTY'S NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO IS MANY OF THEM
WILL NEED TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
KINDS OF THINGS THEY CAN USE
THEM FOR SO THAT THEY DON'T END
UP GETTING THEMSELVES IN
TROUBLE SO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WOULD BE- A GOOD THING AS WELL
EVEN IF IT'S JUST A LIST OF THE
KINDS OF THINGS. WE CAN USE IT
FOR- LIKE MASKS AND PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND- DEVICES THEY'VE
HAD TO INSTALL LIKE THESE KIND
OF PLEXIGLAS THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS- SO I RECOMMEND THAT WE
LOOK AT- NOT ALLOCATING THE
FUNDS THROUGH THE COUNTIES
THEY'RE LOCATED. ON THAT. CAN
BE DONE BY BY POPULATION WE DO
IT ALL THE TIME- SO THAT
THAT'S- IN THE ISSUE THAT CAN.
TURN THE PRICE ROOM KEY I'M I
THINK IT'S A BIT END OF A WAY
TO. BUY HOUSE HOMELESS BECAUSE
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT WE HAVE
HOUSING UNITS AND SO IF YOU CAN
USE THING THAT EXISTS THAT
GREAT A GREAT IDEA BUT IF YOU
CAN AT. HAVE AND THE GRANT THEM
SET UP THROUGH EIGHT I'LL BE
REAL FRANK WITH YOU PROBABLY
MOST OF THE COMMUNITIES. IN MY
IN MY DISTRICT WANT WON'T HAVE
THAT UP. TO APPLY FOR IT THERE.
THERE JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY'RE GONNA. COULD EXIST
OVER THE THROUGH THEIR OWN
BUDGET PROCESS- THEY'RE MAKING
SOME TOUGH DECISIONS AND SO- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDS THAT ARE DISTRIBUTED TO
PURCHASE HOTELS OR MOTELS. IS
EQUALLY SPENT ALL OVER THE
STATE AND THAT IT DOESN'T END
UP GOING TO ONE COMMUNITY WHO'S
BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BE ABLE TO. TO THE TWIST THE
ARMS OF HOTEL OWNERS TO BE ABLE
TO BUY BY THE HOTEL SO- THAT
HAVE BEEN HAVING HIS AND MY
GUESS IS IN ADDITION IS THAT
THE FACILITIES ARE GOING TO BE
THE ONES THAT ARE. STARTING TO
FALL FALL DOWN BECAUSE YOU'RE
MORE LIKELY TO SELL YOUR HOTEL
AND MOTEL AND I'M THINKING OR
MOTELS- IF IT'S FALLING APART
SO- LONG TERM STRATEGY FOR HOW
TO KEEP THAT FACILITY GOING
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT SO. THIS THIS IS ONE
CAN GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF
HEARTBURN I GET WE NEED TO
SPEND THE MONEY TO. BUY A THE
ENDOF THE YEAR- AND- BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO BE INVOLVED IN IN SOME
OF THESE DECISIONS SELF THIS IS
A HOLD WHY DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I. AT THIS POINT BUT
I THINK IT WAS A REALLY GOOD
DISCUSSION IN MY QUESTIONS GOT
ANSWERED AT CENTER NIELSEN. LET
ME JUST INTERJECT ONE MORE
SPECIFIC THAT CERTAINLY RELATES
TO THE AREAS OF INTEREST TO THE
CHAIR AND MYSELF AND THAT WOULD
BE FARM WORKER HOUSING AT ANY.
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON FARM WORKER
HOUSING. I'M NOT SERVICES THAT-
QUESTION- FARM WORKER HOUSING-
TAKE TO THE EXTENT THAT ALEX-
THEY WERE THERE ARE. HOTELS
MOTELS OTHER SIMILAR PROPERTIES
THAT CAN HELL'S. LARGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE IN THE ADEQUATE SAFE
ENVIRONMENT AND OUT TO BE
LOCATED IN A RURAL COMMUNITY
AND CERTAINLY THAT COULD BE ON
THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF PROPOSITION PROP-
PROJECT ROOM HE IS WELL. THAT'S
IMPORTANT POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION CENTER
NIELSEN. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS
THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT. AND WILL- TURN IT
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'M GONNA DROP OFF BUT
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES TAKE OVER
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER HILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DID YOU CRUZ DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS. THIS CALL AND THEN
THEY- ON THE CALL. EACH OTHER.
AND THE ONE MILLION SETTLEMENT
FUNDS TO AVOID AVAILABLE FOR
CLOSURES. JUST LOOK ON THIS
ALLOCATE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
BECOME HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY
ON HOUSING COUNSELING SERVICES
AND MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE. ASIAN
OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
QUALIFIED SCHOOLS YOU MORTGAGE
SERVICE PROVIDERS. I DON'T NAY
KELLY TO BEAT YOU- PARTNERS IN
THE PAST HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT.
PLANS FOR A SIMILAR SERVICE IN
RESPONSE THE GREAT RECESSION
ANY TENNIS PROVIDE OF THIS
NINETY NINE THE FIRST FIFTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION HOUSING
SERVICES INCREASED AWARENESS OF
THE BILL OF RESOURCES AND END
USER MEANING OR THE MORTGAGE.
THE REMAINING THIRTY ONE
MILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO. WRESTLE
PEOPLE SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS BUT I'M
HAPPY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OHIO. ONCE AGAIN NOTED AS WELL
AS WITH THE ALEJO- THE
ASSOCIATE GENERAL DOES WHAT
DETAILS ABOUT HELP SOMEONE
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO. ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT ACTIVITIES
WILL BE FUNDED AND WHO WILL BE
A BENEFICIARY OF THOSE SERVICES.%
AS WELL AS WHAT OVERSIGHT IS
NECESSARY I TO OVERSEE CALTRANS
WORK IN THE SPACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YES SENATOR OZ OF JUST
ONE A DIGITAL WITH THE- THE
COMMENTS BY THE LA THIS IS.
THIS IS REALLY URGENT PAINT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
FACING ENORMOUS PRESSURES AND I
REALLY THINK THAT- WELL I PLUG
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY GOING TO
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE AND- PAID
FOR ANDERSON AND HOMEOWNERS WE
NEED MORE- SPECIFIC INFORMATION
AND- I WOULD REALLY URGE ALSO-
PUTTING MORE INTO AID FOR
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS OFFERED
BLADE- THAN WHAT IS UP WITH
THEIR THEIR THE I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE FACING AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF. A POTENTIAL
EVICTIONS BOB VERY QUICKLY
AFTER THE TWO THREE MONTHS OF
THE EMERGENCY ARE OVER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. YES SENATOR
NIELSEN ANOTHER POINT OF
INQUIRY IT IS IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION. AND OF COURSE
THIS IS BEING HELD OPEN SO
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT. BUT AS FAR AS GETTING
THE MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE MONEY
OUT TO DISTRESSED HOMEOWNERS IT
HAS BEEN SUGGESTED TO ME THAT.
THE HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY
IS A BIT MORE NIMBLE OR QUICK
TO MOVE AGENCY AND HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS OF ANY
CONSIDERATION TO RE DIRECT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY A LITTLE BIT FOR
GETTING MONEY OUT MORE
EXPEDITIOUSLY. IT IT IS. THAT'S
A BIG JUMP QUESTION I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD TO ASK FINANCE THAT
QUESTION. IN. IT'S CAN SOMEBODY
FROM ABOVE FROM FINANCE I
BELIEVE THAT THE REPORT SAYS
THAT IT IS THAT KELLY CHIU
FADED THAT WOULD BE IN CHARGE
OF ALLOCATING THE RESOURCES AND
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THEY'VE
THEY'VE DEVELOPED A FIRST TIME
HOME BUYER BUYER PROGRAM IT AS
WELL AS A ROUTE AT AN ASSISTANT
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THAT. SO MY AT MY BIG CONCERN
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT TIMES IT'S
AND IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE-
THIS IS A- THIS IS MONEY THAT
WAS- WAS PAID. DURING THE LAST
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY BECAUSE
OF THE MORTGAGE MELTDOWN THAT
THAT OCCURRED BECAUSE OF FRAUD.
BY THE MORTGAGE- INDUSTRY AND
SO YOU KNOW AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR I WAS REALLY. FOCUSED
ON. BECAUSE SO MANY OF THE
HOMEOWNERS- WERE BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS THAT HAD BOUGHT THEIR
HOME FOR THE FIRST TIME-
IDENTIFYING A WAY TO GET. THIS
MONEY TO CAL HFA AND THEN TO
HAVE THEM- I CREATE A FIRST
FIRST TIME HOMEBUYERS PROGRAM
FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT LOST
THEIR HOUSES. SO THAT THEY
COULD ENTER THE THAT THE MARKET
AGAIN- AND- THE DIFFERENCE THAT.
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS MAKES IS
THAT DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE JUST NOT IN A POSITION TO
BE ABLE TO BUY A HOUSE GIVEN
THE DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY. SO
I'M REALLY CONCERNED WITH THIS
BEING IS USED AS WISELY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE I AGREE
WITH WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT- THE DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY IS GOING TO PUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE AT RISK. AND AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS WHY
THE YOU KNOW HAVING. HAVING
UNITS TO PUT PEOPLE INTO
BECOMES VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND
ALSO AT RISK OF LOSING THEIR
HOMES AND SO. ON WE'RE GONNA
NEED A- SOME SOME. IT KELLY
CHIPPY IS I THINK A REALLY GOOD
ENTITY. TO REALLY FOCUS ON
GETTING THE MORTGAGE MORTGAGE
LENDERS TOGETHER. AND COMING UP
WITH A WAY TO BE ABLE TO. HELP
PEOPLE OUT SO THAT THEY DON'T
LOSE OUR HOME SO. THIS IS THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN I THINK IT'S
WORTH MORE DISCUSSION AND I
APPRECIATE THE- THE INTERESTING
GETTING THE MONEY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND NOT
HAVING IT SIT IN THE TRUST FUND
ANYMORE. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY NINE WHICH
IS THE HOUSING REVERSION. AND
WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IRAN.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN ABOUT
INTERNET FOR NEW MEMBERS DAY
CRUISE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
GIVEN THE NEW AND UNFORESEEN
ECONOMIC VALUE. THE STATE
DISTRIBUTED SOLUTIONS SUPPORT
THE GENERAL FUND MIGHT WHILE
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING PROGRAM.
PROPOSES TO OUR VERSIONS
TOTALING MORE FIFTY NINE OF
PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED BUT
UNDERUSED FEINSTEIN GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENTS. INCLUDING
TWENTY MILLION. HOUSING AND SHE
NEEDED ALL MEN'S AND GO
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS PROGRAM
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
TWENTY. THE NINE COLLEGE BASED
MAKES ANGLE PROGRAM. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
ORGANS ARMORED IMPORTANT TO
KNOW TO LOOK TO OPERATE WITH
FUNDING FROM ONE AND ANNUAL
ASKING TO REVENUES RESPECTIVELY
CONTINUE ALL STRING. SECTION IN
THE STATE WHATEVER HAVE YOU
TAKE ANY. THE OHIO. THAT'S WHAT
I WAS THINKING WITH THE LA JOH
HOMELESSNESS IS AN AREA OF THE
BUDGET WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
GENERAL ON WHICH YOU SHOULD.
WEAR PORTIONS OF THE FUNDING
HAS NOT BEEN SPENT AND AS A
RESULT IS AVAILABLE. TO HELP
ADDRESS THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET
PROBLEMS YOU STACEY. EXPENSE OF
FULLY ACHIEVING THE OBJECTIVES
LEGISLATURE INTENDED WHEN
AUTHORIZED. THOSE AUGMENTATIONS
AND SO I CAN MANY OTHER AREAS
OF THE BUDGET THE LOGISTICS
WILL HAVE TO WAIT TO TREAT. OUR
SUPPORTING ADDITIONAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND ADDRESSING THE
STATE'S. DECISIONS TO MAKE.
MUCH MANY MEMBERS FENNER DRIVES
OF. YES HIS OUR OUR FAVORITE
SUBJECT MEMOREX EVERYDAY HAVING
WORKED WITH SENATOR QUALITY OF
IDEA TO ON THIS IN IN IN THE
SENATE. THIS IS THE FUNDING
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS ALREADY
AUTHORIZED AND YOU KNOW AS FAR
AS I SEE IT IN ON THE MOVE IS
THE FUNDING THAT WAS. GETTING
USED TO STARTING TO GET USED
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AS I FOR REPEAT EVERYTHING I
SAID EARLIER IT IS WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE THE COMBINATION OF THESE
POLICIES WITH FUNDING- IT IS
THE LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY IT IS
A CALIFORNIA PRIORITY OF
CALIFORNIA PRIORITY ALWAYS
COMES UP AS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE- OF A HOUSING OF COURSES
CONNECTED ESPECIALLY TO
HOMELESSNESS SO. I YOU KNOW THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH IS WERE WE
BUILDING FOR HOME OR WE
BUILDING WE KNOW WE NEED IT FOR
LITTLE AWE LOW INCOME VERY LOW
INCOME- I JUST DON'T SEE HOW WE
CAN. DE DETRACT FROM THAT
DEVIATE FROM THAT INSTEAD OF
MOVING FOR WE CAN'T LOSE THAT
PARTICULAR MOMENTUM SO.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOT TO BE OTHER
WAYS OF ALL PHILLY THE NEEDS OF
THE OF THEGENERAL FUND AND OUR
BUDGET BUT- I JUST THINK WE
SHOULD NOT GO BACKWARDS ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU MANAGING.
THIRTY NIELSEN ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNING THIS ITEM. SO I WON
A SECOND WHAT THE SENATOR DR SO
SAD OUR MOVE BEEN WORKING
REALLY HARD ON HOUSING PACKAGE
IN PART OF THAT PACKAGE- IS
LOOKING AT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
DO MORE. UP IN OUR OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IT TAKES MONEY
TAKES RESOURCES AND UP THE
PIECE THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
TROUBLING IS THE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE BECAUSE-
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMPLICATED TO
DO INFILL- IT'S BETTER. IT'S
BETTER FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
IT'S BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
BUT- SOMETIMES INFRASTRUCTURE
IS OLD IS OLD AND NEEDS NEEDS
REPAIRS AND TO HAVE ONE PROJECT
HAVE TO PICK THAT IT BECOMES
VERY COST. COST AT A
PROHIBITIVE AND SO- I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN AND I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN
NOW. MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS- AND
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY ONE THAT.
THAT HAS ME A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED AS AS AS A REVERSION-
IT MEANS WE DON'T GET THE MONEY
BACK SO IF THERE'S NO MORE
COMMENTS ON THIS ONE I'LL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM. GEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY ARE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY WHICH IS THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE CLEAN
UP. AND WILL I TURN IT OVER TO.
TO THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AN INMATE I'M SURE NUMBERS
DINNER CRUISE APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AS A LEGAL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE FARMER HOUSING
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
CREATED STREAMLINED MINISTER OF
YOUR PROCESS FOR AGRICULTURE
EMPLOYEE HOUSING. IT'S
SPECIFIED STATE HOUSING FROM
BEING UTILIZED FOR
CONSTRUCTION- OF HOUSING FOR
FEDERAL A STRAY WORKERS.
UNFORTUNATELY EXISTING LANGUAGE
CAN BE CONSTRUED BROADLY AN
ANCHOR SIGNIFICANT STATE COSTS
AND EXPOSE THE STATE
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL EXPOSURE
SPECIFIED THIS PROGRAM AT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. FIND THE
DEFINITION OF AGRICULTURE
EMPLOYED HOUSING. EASY TO
IMPLEMENT HELP YOU BUY LINES
AND FORCE YOUR ARMS AND THEN
YOU'RE STREAMLINING PROGRAM
MAKES CONFORMING CHANGES ARE
PROBLEMATIC. THIS MORNING I
GIVEN THAT THIS PRESSURES AND
STAYING SAYS THIS TRAILER BILL
IS NECESSARY TO SAVE THE STATE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT IS
NOT CURRENTLY IN THE BUDGET IN
NINE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONGOING. IN WHATEVER HAVE
YOU TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. PART OF
THE LA. THE OTHER COMMENTS TO
ADD ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS VERY GOOD
INDIA COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER DRIVES OF YES. AS SOME
FINANCE SAID THERE'S CURRENTLY
PROBATION ON STATE FUNDING FOR
H. TWO EIGHT OF WORKER HOUSING-
CONCERNED CONCERNED- JUST FAST
FORWARD CONCERNED THAT THE
CHANGES PROPOSED IN THE TRAILER
BILL TO ADD THE TERM UNITS
MIGHT ERODE THE INTENT OF
EXISTING LAW. THAT NO STATE
FUNDING CAN BE USED FOR HOUSING
THAT HOUSES H. TWO EIGHT
EMPLOYEES- AND THAT COULD
INCLUDE HOUSING THAT HAS SOME
AGE TO A HOUSING UNITS AND SOME
NON HA HOUSING UNITS. OR
BERWICK STYLE HOUSING OR MOBILE
HOME PARK HOUSING SO I'D URGE
WE- KEEP THIS OPEN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT. THIRTY NIELSEN.
JUST TO FOLLOW ON THAT
PARTICULAR POINT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE- ADMINISTRATION WAS
GOING TO DO SOME TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IT MAY BE FORTHCOMING
STREAMLINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS AND- THAT THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THE SHE H. CD'S
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES. A
LITTLE BIT AND PROCEDURES THE
DEPARTMENT SO WE CAN MAYBE MOVE
THINGS MORE QUICKLY IS THERE
MERIT TO THAT OBSERVATION THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING ON
STREAMLINING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ONE OF MINE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WELL IT THIS IS TO
REMAIN OPEN SPOT SO ANY
INFORMATION THAT YOU COULD GET
TO US ABOUT WHAT THE INTENTION
IS OUT WOULD BE. GREATLY
APPRECIATED. CONCERNED ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW THIS GETS
PROCESSED. SO THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- PART B. HOW ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PART OF THE
AGENDA. SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
PART C. WHICH IS OTHER STATE
ADMINISTRATION. AND IF WE'RE
GONNA DO A SWITCH. OKAY NO
SWITCH SO NO NEED BETWEEN WE
JUST NEED TO. GET TO THE PAPERS.
OKAY. THE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
FOR THEIR PATIENCE. OKAY. SIR
MY CORRECT THAT THE NEXT ITEM
IS ISSUE- OR NINETY SIX K. VERY
GOOD ITEM FOR DISCUSSION ISSUE
ONE NINETY SIX WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTION SEVENTEEN AND
THE AMERICORPS FUNDING STRATEGY
AND WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT- JOSH
FREDDIE THIS CHEAP SERVERS
OFFICER FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEER SHOULD BE
ON STANDBY LIKE TO TURN THIS
OVER HIM VERY UNLIKELY TO DO IS
IT'S JUST YOU. VERY GOOD.
WELCOME YOU SENATOR MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATORS FOR HAVING
US TODAY OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS THE E. S. F. SEVENTEEN
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN LED BY CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS HAVE CRITICAL
SUPPORT OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR OUR
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY OF OUR
FOOD BANKS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
THE FIRST SHELTER PLACE
ANNOUNCED BY GOVERNOR NEWS AND
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS AND I
WERE TASKED TO LEAD THE U. S.
SEVENTEEN FOR TASK FORCE TO
ENSURE THE OPERATIONAL
SUSTAINABILITY IN CONTINUITY OF
FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE STATE AND
WITH THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
THE FOOD BANK SAW IN MANY
PLACES DROP OF UP 270% OF THE
POINTS YEARS THEY RELY ON TO
OPERATE IN THIS DUE LARGELY.
THEIR FOR OLDER AND HIGHER RISK
FOR KOBE NINETEEN SO QUICKLY WE
DEPLOYED THE CALIFORNIA GUARD
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND AMERICA AS WELL AS
SEVERAL OTHER VOLUNTEER GROUPS
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SUPPORT SINCE
THEN WE HAVE SUPPORTED THIRTY
FIVE BANKS IN TWENTY SEVEN
COUNTIES AND THAT THESE FOOD
BANKS WE HAVE HELP PROVIDES
THIRTY TWO MILLION MEALS SINCE
KOBE NINETEEN BEGAN. TO DATE
THE CALIFORNIA GUARD CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AMERICORPS
AND THE CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL
SERVICE INITIATIVE HAS
SUPPORTED OUR FOOD BANKS WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND. SIXTY
THOUSAND PERSONNEL HOURS. SO
NOW IS THE CALIFORNIA GUARD
BEGINS TO DRIVE DOWN ON THIS
MISSION AT THE FOOD BANKS. WE
NEED TO TRANSITION TO A LONGER
TERM VOLUNTEER FORCE TO SUSTAIN
OPERATIONS. AND TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS WE WILL BE RELYINGON
CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL WHICH IS
RUN BY CALIFORNIA'S VOLUNTEERS.
AS WELL AS AMERICORPS SERVICE
MEMBERS AND TO GIVE A SENSE OF
SCALE WE ARE EXPECTING TO NEED
TO PROVIDE OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS. JUST SUPPORT FOOD
BANKS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
DON'T SEE THE DEMAND
DIMINISHING ANYTIME SOON. IN
FACT MANY FOOD BANKS HAVE SEEN
A 100% INCREASE IN DEMAND AND
THE PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT THESE
NUMBERS WILL CONTINUE AT LEAST.
THROUGH THE END OF THE YEAR.
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS THAT WE RUN
HAVE ALSO PLAYED A CRITICAL
ROLE IN RESPONSE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO. THIS STATE SUPPORTED
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS ARE
SUPPORTING CRITICAL COVERT
NINETEEN EFFORTS SUCH AS THE
FOOD BANKS WE JUST DISCUSSED.
AS WELL AS OTHER DISASTER
RECOVERY MISSIONS LIKE THE
CAMPFIRE RECOVERY IN PARADISE
WHERE WE ARE MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT TO
CREATE AND SUPPORT A LARGE
PROGRAM FOR CASE WORKERS FOR
CAMPFIRE VICTIMS. IN MOVING
FORWARD THE AMERICORPS MEMBERS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN MEETING
EMERGENCY COMMUNITY NEEDS AS
RECOVER AND REBUILD FROM CO THE
NINETEEN. THIS BUDGET ENSURES
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING FOOD BANKS AND OTHER
CRITICAL LOCAL NEEDS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
ARE ASKING US TO HELP THEM. AS
WELL AS BUILD AND MAINTAIN THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
RESPOND TO FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WITH
REGARD TO OUR WORK AROUND FOOD
BANKS OR ANYTHING ELSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
FINANCE ANY ADDITIONS YOU WANT
TO ADD. NUMBER RIGHT THE LA.
VERY GOOD I'M BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR DR SO THANK
YOU- YES MISTER FRIDAY HAVE A
GREAT- HIGH REGARD FOR
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS ON AND
THE WORK THAT'S DONE I'VE BEEN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE VOLUNTEERS
MYSELF. I JUST WANT TO ASK THE
QUESTION- I KNOW LAST YEAR. WE
DID APPROVE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS. AND DO
I UNDERSTAND RIGHT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL.
THIRTEEN MILLION. THIS COMING
YEAR AND TWENTY TWO MILLION THE
FOLLOWING YEAR FOR. NEW AMOUNT
OF THIRTY FIVE MILLION. THAT IS
CORRECT YEAH SO ANYWAY I THE-
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY. ECONOMIC
POSITION THAT WERE IN AYE- I
WOULD ASK TO. WE THINK THAT-
THERE ARE SO MANY- PROGRAMS
THAT ARE. ARE DIRECTLY DIRECTLY
IMPACTING WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE
HAVE FOOD ON THEIR ON THEIR
TABLE- TO BE ABLE TO USE THE
VOLUNTEERS SO- WHILE I FEEL
VERY MUCH IN A DILEMMA I THINK
ON THE WORK THAT YOU DO IS
TREMENDOUS BUT- I ALSO THINK
THAT THERE'S THE THINGS THAT
WERE BEING ASKED TO CUT. THAT
OFF OUR LIFE AND DEATH
SITUATIONS. THANK YOU WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
DO AND THE WORK THAT THE
VOLUNTEERS ARE DOING THEY'VE
BEEN AND IT INCREDIBLE ADDITION
TO THE FOOD. BANKS AND TO ALL
THE SERVICE AGENCIES AND THEY
BEEN PARTNERING WITH AND I
CONCUR WITH WHAT- CENTER DRAWS
RIGHTS HAS HAS TO SAY IT TO-
PROBABLY NEVER. A BETTER TIME
TO ADD. TO YOUR TO YOUR
SERVICES INTO YOUR CORE THEN
WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT WORKING
BECAUSE THIS GIVES THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AND THEN GO
TO SCHOOL BUT IT'S ALSO A
REALLY BAD TIME BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO MAKE CUTS EVERYWHERE AND SO-
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ITEMSIT
WILL REMAIN OPEN AND I THINK
YOU FOR. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY AND FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING- I THINK IT'S
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT BUT- FOR
MAKING SOME TOUGH TOUGH CHOICES
SO- AS I SAID THIS WILL WILL
REMAIN OPEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND MOVE ON. TO THE
NEXT ITEM. WITH WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN CONTROL
ELEVEN POINT NINETY. ITS THE
IT'S THE- CONTROL SECTION. WILL
TURN IT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ONE NINETY SIX VERY.
IT'S A NEW NUMBER. WHICH IS THE
NINETY SIX ONE NINETY SIX THIS
IS ONE NINETY SEVEN. YOU MAY
HAVE THE AGENDA FROM YESTERDAY.
OKAY. IS THERE SOMEBODY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
CAN ADDRESS THIS THAT SINCE
THIS- ASSUMES CONTROL BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I FIGURED
SOMEBODY WOULD WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT. IT'S THE HOT SEAT.
WELCOME A GREAT REST DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE YEAH THE CONTROL
SECTION ONE POINT NINE NO WILL
BE USED TO. OKAY FINDS PER YEAR
FINDING IT WAS A WRITE UP FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NINETY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. FOR A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS ARE SEATED
IN THE CONTROL SECTION. SO THAT
THE MONIES WILL BE EXPANDED
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
THERE'S A DEADLINE FOR THE END
OF DECEMBER. I AND SO THIS WILL
DEFINITELY. HE VERY WELL USED-
CONTROL SECTION AND WE- NEEDED
INSTEAD OF A CONTROL SECTION
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS HUGE HOLE
FEDERAL FUNDS. YOU SEE CONTROL
SECTION. THIS WILL WE NEED
AGNETHA FUNDS ARE VERY.
DISTINGUISHED FROM THE NORMAL
US SECTION TWENTY EIGHT PROCESS
THERE WE GO THIS CONTROL
SECTIONAL BE THE MOST USEFUL
PROCESS THANK YOU. OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WELCOME. WELL IF YOU GIVE US A
SECOND WORK WILL THAT WILL GET
YOU TURNED ON FOR YOU MAY NEED
TO TURN YOURSELF ON. CAN YOU
HEAR ME THIS IS HOW IN PERSON
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL THANK
YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT. AND SAID
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS THE
FIRST OF A FEW CONTROL SECTION
AND THAT COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERING RELATED TO COME IN
NINETEEN. SO I WILL PROVIDE
SOME SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON EACH
CONTROL SECTION BUT I'D POINT
OUT THAT THERE REALLY IS AN
OVERALL THEME TO ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS. WHICH IS THAT WHILE
SOME NEW LANGUAGE MAY BE
JUSTIFIED IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COMPANY IN RESPONSE. OVERALL WE
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED PROCESS THESE THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE SECTIONS GO TOO
FAR IN DELEGATING KEY
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY FOR
EXAMPLE RELATED TO A
CORPORATION. SO SPECIFICALLY
WITH REGARD TO CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE HELLO. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AN ADDITIONAL
PROCESS BEYOND THE EXISTING
CONTROL SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
MIGHT BE WARRANTED FOR
ALLOCATING THESE FEDERAL FUNDS
GIVEN. BUT THERE ARE
CONSTRAINTS ON THE CORONAVIRUS
REALLY FRIENDS AND THAT THERE'S
SOME URGENCY IN ALLOCATING
THESE FUNDS. HOWEVER WE THINK
IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
MODIFY THIS PROCESS TO INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT- AND
INVOLVEMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO
NOTIFICATION. OR FORMAL
LEGISLATIVE IN FRIGHT ON ANY
REALLOCATION OF THIS FUNDING SO
THERE'S- THE MINISTRATIONS
PROVIDED SORT OF ROCK FUNDING
PLAN. BUT IF THOSE CHANGE- THE
LEGISLATURE ISN'T ISN'T THERE'S
NO NO FORMAL PROCESS FOR
NOTIFYING LEGISLATURE SEEKING
LEGISLATURE'S. ONE ON FOR MY
LANGUAGE WOULD BE. THAT THE
MINUTES PROVIDE NOTIFICATIONS
ABOUT FUNDS THEIR REALLOCATED
THROUGH THIS CONTROL SECTION.
INCLUDING REQUIRING SPECIFIC
INFORMATION IN THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE GET THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION NEEDS. AND WE ALSO
THINK IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO
HAVE IN OUR REPORTING ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
UNSETTLING WOULD HAVE KIND OF A
CHECK IN AT THAT POINT- AND
ENVISIONED POTENTIALLY
RELOCATIONS AT THAT POINT. SO
THAT'S PROBABLY YEAH. LOGICAL
TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
SOME REVISED INFORMATION FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
WHETHER THERE'S BEEN FULL TAKE
UP OF THE- PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'RE EXPECTING TO FIND UNDER
THIS AND- WHAT THEIR PLAN IS
GOING FORWARD. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
INFORMATION- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER NIELSEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS WHOLE ISSUE IS
VERY BROAD. AND IF IT'S NOT NEW
THAT IS MEETING THE
LEGISLATURE'S SEATING MORE AND
MORE AUTHORITY TO THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND THE WHAT I CALL
ADMINISTRATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT THE FRONT. BUT IT'S
KIND OF COME TO A HEAD RIGHT
NOW. THE CHAIRS AND VICE CHAIRS
OF BOTH BUDGET COMMITTEES HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
TREND. OF LATE AT THIS
PARTICULAR TIME OF CRISIS MANY
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN VOICING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE IT. AND ONE
OF THE OLD STRATEGIES WAS TO
REQUIRE- BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE THE REQUIRED REPORTS.
THE LEGISLATURE. I'M TO THE
POINT WHERE I THINK THOSE ARE I
DON'T WANT HIM ANYMORE. REPORTS
MEAN NOTHING THEY GET FILED AND
FORGOTTEN. BUT WE NEED ACTUAL
AUTHORITY CITATIONS OF
AUTHORITY. AND RE DELEGATIONS
OF AUTHORITY TO THE LEGISLATURE
WE NEED TO REST SOME OF THAT
CONTROL BACK. THAT IS A BROADLY
APPLICABLE ISSUE BUT PROBABLY
MORE SO IN MY OPINION IT THIS
MOST DESPERATE TIME OF ALL. WE
JUST HAVE TO A PAUCITY OF NOT
MUCH OF WHAT'S GOING ON. AND WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE TO THE
CITIZENS. AND IT'S NOT US. LARA
TORTILLAS MEMBERS. AS MUCH AS A
CHIEF FORTY OF THE VOTERS OF
CITIZENS THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND NOT JUST THE
VOTERS THE CITIZENS. THEY NEED
TO KNOW AND I NEED TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S WATCHING THE
CHICKEN COOP. SO WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LEVEL LOTS OF
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS AS WE
PROCEED. AND AGAIN I SAY IT'S A
NO CRITICISM OF THIS PARTICULAR
ADMINISTRATION IT'S BEEN AROUND
A LONG TIME BUT NOW WE'RE AT A
MORE CRITICAL TIME- A KINDLE
WHEN WE WERE THAT MAYBE THE
PROP THIRTEEN YEARS WERE WORTH
A LITTLE SIMILAR. ABOUT TWENTY
TEN TO TWENTY ELEVEN BROWN
FORTY FIVE BILLION IN THE RED
THAT WAS ANOTHER SUCH TIME.
I'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME
AND I WATCH THIS HAPPEN. A DAY
BILL BY BILL DEAL WHEREBY DEAL
LANDED POPPING UP RACIAL
MANUALS. AND THAT AND EIGHT
PIECE A MINISTRY DIRECTIVES.
AND YOU KNOW THE MOST OF IT IS
NEVER BEEN CHALLENGED ILLEGALLY
BUT I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD PREVAIL WHERE
THEY AND LET'S HOPE WE DON'T
HAVE TO EVER GET TO THAT POINT.
ENTER DRAWS A SURE I'M I THINK
IT'S THE SAME I KNOW WE'RE
OR THREE AYE AGENDA ITEMS THAT
REFERRED BASICALLY THE SAME
THING IS TO WHAT DEGREE. TO PUT
DEGREES- IS AS YOU SAID- OUR
ROLE AS LEGISLATURE SEATED TO
THE TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH SO
I CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS FRANKLY I JUST ONE
TECHNICAL QUESTION IS THIS ONLY
USE FOR PURPOSES OF FUNDING. AS
FAR AS THIS KIND OF AUTHORITY
OR- YOU MEAN RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT COME IN AND THEN YOU
DON'T KNOW I MEAN THE
AUTHORITY. UNDER THESE- FOR
EXAMPLE LEAST THREE CONTROL
SECTIONS IS THAT ONLY FOR. IS
THAT A THIRTY ONLY ON ISSUES OF
FUNDING OR CAN IT. CAN IT BE
USED FOR OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
NON FINANCIAL NON FUNDING THAT
MAKES US A QUESTION. MAYBE THE
LA OWN. THAT MIGHT BE ABLE
INAPPROPRIATE QUESTION EITHER
FOR FINANCE ARE FOR THE LA
FINANCE DEALS WITH FUNDING SO
MAYBE MAYBE THE QUESTION SHOULD
GO TO THE LA. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS IS
THAT THESE- KEITH IS A CONTROL
SECTION BASICALLY ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING SO THAT. OF COURSE
THERE'S A THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY CONSEQUENCES TO THAT
BECAUSE IF YOU ALLOCATE FUNDING
TO A SPECIFIC KIND OF NEW
ACTIVITY THAT THAT CERTAINLY
HAS SOME- SOME SIGNIFICANT
QUALITY CONSEQUENCES BUT-
REALLY THESE CONTROLS ACTIONS
ARE- WHEN THEY WERE ANY
DISCUSSING ELEVEN POINT NINE
NOW ELEVEN POINT NINE FIVE AND
THEN SECTION THIRTY SIX RELATE
TO ALLOCATING. FEDERAL FUNDS
AND- LATER ON WE'LL DISCUSS
STATE AND I'M TO. ACTIVITIES
AND ALL RELATED TO COMMITTEE.
OKAY WELL JUST JUST ONE ONE
FIVE THAT I HAD WAS. UP BYOND
THE FUNDING- THAT WE OUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION. HOW DO WE-
MORE TO OF. THE OF JOB. IN THIS
IN THIS A IN THE TIME IN THIS
RECOVERY. HOW DO WE DO MORE FOR
IT FOR JOB CREATION IF WE COULD
USE THAT AUTHORITY. TO EXPAND
ON THAT ESPECIALLY WITH OUR-
AMID PROCESS IT AND I KNOW A
NUMBER OF ISSUES CAME UP OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS ABOUT
THE KINDS OF CONTRACTS THAT
WERE ENTERED INTO. AND HOW CAN
WE USE THE FUNDING IN SUCH A
WAY THAT REALLY BENEFITS JOB
CREATION ONE WORD MOST
DESPERATE AND MOST NEED OF IT
SO JUST A THOUGHT THANK YOU
MEASURE. THIRTY NEAR NIELSEN
DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER CHAL A
CONCERN WELL JUST A- PUT
NOTABLE NOT US NOT A FOOTNOTE
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE INTEGRAL PART.
I DIDN'T GET MY HAND UP QUICK
ENOUGH LEGEND WAS BEAT ME TO IT
BUT ANOTHER THING NOT ONLY
FISCAL POLICY BUT MAJOR. POLICY
PERIOD. HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
OVER THE YEARS. BEYOND THE
CONTROL THE LEGISLATURE WITHOUT
ANY STATUTORY AUTHORITY. AND
THAT'S A SENSITIVE ISSUE AS
WELL POLICY DOES COME IN AND I
CALLED GOVERNOR LAFAYETTE WHEN
THAT THE DOCTOR OUT DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONAL MENU MENU A
MEMORANDUM COMES OUT. THAT SETS
THE POLICY FOR THE AGENCY. AND
I AN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES
WE HAVE CHALLENGED AGENCY MY
STAFF AND I WHAT YOUR CITATION
OF AUTHORITY. AND A LOT BLANK
AT USE IT. AND ONE THAT REALLY
IS TELLING IT'S ALMOST HUMOROUS
BUT I WAS READING THAT TO A%
LEGAL DIMERA SEVERAL YEARS AGO
NOW ASK ME WHY I WAS WASTING MY
TIME READING THIS MAJOR LAWSUIT
THE QUESTION OF THE JUDGE. TO
CALTRANS. BUT THE JUDGE ASKED
FOR A CITATION OF AUTHORITY.
AND THE RESPONSE WAS BECAUSE WE
ARE CALTRANS. THAT WAS A
CITATION OF AUTHORITY. THAT WAS
NOT A FREUDIAN SLIP. WHY I
AGREE WITH YOU ON THE ON THE
POLICY ISSUE I THINK BUT THAT'S
PART OF THE CHALLENGE WITH THEM
WITH CEDING CONTROL AS IT WE
JUST WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A POLICY THAT WE
UNDERSTAND IN THAT WE'VE ABOUT
ACQUIESCENCE AND THAT THERE'S
A- THERE'S FAIRNESS INEQUITIES
GET YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT WE HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE ASKING US
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THIS AND- AND I THINK THE REAL-
THE REAL. WE KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO- THIS ONE IS A IS
A HOLD OPEN AND I THINK- THE
LIKE I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS. BOB THE LA- COMMENTS
IN REGARDS TO. THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE MIGHT ASK FOR
AND- I THINK THAT TO THE EXTENT
IT'S HOW HELD OPEN IT GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER. THE ADMINISTRATION. ON
THE SERVER WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM WHICH IS THE- ITEM
ONE NINETY EIGHT CONTROL ISSUE
ELEVEN POINT NINETY FIVE WHICH
AGAIN IS A- A CONTROL SET
SECTION ISSUE AND WILL I TURN
IT OVER TO THE PART IN A
FINANCE AGAIN. AND YOU CAN
PROPERTY DESPERATE PRETTY SURE
BECAUSE I THINK WE'LL MAKE OUR
COMMENTS PICTURED IN TERMS OF
THESE A CONTROL ISSUES BECAUSE
IT'S DID OR DID OR DID OF.
THANK YOU NEW KRISTIN SHOPS AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
THINK THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION ON WHO IS COVERING
THIS ISSUE AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE GREG PRESS. FOR I'M
JUST OUTLINING A LITTLE BIT
RELATIVE TO CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN NINETY AND THEN ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE. I'M JUST BROADLY
FOR THE TWO PIECE. AND WE ARE
WE THESE BOTH BOTH OF THESE
PIECES SUPPORT A STATE
ALLOCATION AND PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK TO BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE AND SPEND THESE
FEDERAL LANDS AND WE KNOW ABOUT
TODAY AND ONCE WE DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT SO JUST FOR THE BILL-DURATION PRIOR TO THAT ARE JUST
AFTER THE NAME REVISION WAS
RELEASED RECEIVE NOTIFICATION
FROM CITY SPEEDS THAT WE WERE
YET NEARLY HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS. OR CASTING AND KIND.
STATE THAT'S JUST A PIECE OF
THE OP PATIENT WOULD ROLL TO
THE STATE I'M WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE AND HEARD THE
CONCERNS OF THE LEGISLATURE
DURING THE BROADER OVERVIEW
HEARING ON MONDAY AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY DRAFTED LANGUAGE WE
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
STAFF THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR A
TEN DAY NOTIFICATION. TO THE
LEGSLATURE ABOUT BOTHTHE
ALLOCATION AND ANY POTENTIAL
REALLOCATION OF THE FINE AND
SHOULD WE FIND OUT OR DISCOVER
HONOR CHECK IN DATE SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THAT THE
FUNDS ARE NOT BEING SPENT OR
SOME OF OUR ASSUMPTIONS THAT.
JENNIFER IS. OUR OR SPEND THOSE
FINE TURN OUT TO NOT BE TRUE WE
MAY NOT HAVE EXPENDITURE LEVELS
OUT THE LEVELS ARE CASTING FOR
INSTANCE WE SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
DEVELOPING NOT NOTIFICATION
PROCESS AND WE STILL THINK.
UNIQUE SITUATION THE RAPIDLY
EVOLVING FRAMEWORK- IN TERMS OF
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THE
ABILITY TO AND ALL OF THE
CURRENT VIRUS RELIEF FINDS NO
LATER THAN DECEMBER THIRTIETH.
AND WE HAVE PRESS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE U. S.
TREASURY ON WHETHER THAT COULD
BE. OBLIGATED FOR SUSPENSION WE
HAVE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR NO
MATTER WHICH WAY WE BASS THE
QUESTIONER POSE THE QUESTION
AND THAT IS A PRETTY HARD DATE
FOR US IN TERMS OF SPENDING SO
IT DOES REQUIRE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT KINDS OF FLEXIBILITY.
THANK YOU AND HAVE THEM UNDER
PROVISIONS OF SECTION TWENTY
EIGHT. AND THE- OTHER
PROVISIONS BEFORE YOU RIGHT NOW
REALLY JUST DEALS WITH OUR
ABILITY TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FRIENDS AS THOSE WORDS
ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
STATE. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THEY ARE ALLOWABLE WE CAN
OFFSET GENERAL FUND COSTS OR
EXPENSES THAT WERE FRONTAGE
EVEN INTO IN THE CURRENT YEAR
TO DEAL WITH THE PANDEMIC IF WE
HAVE A DEDICATED. FEDERAL FUNDS
SOURCE THAT CERTAINLY MORE
OPTIMAL AND ULTIMATELY HELPS
THE BROAD GENERAL FUND
CONDITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M LA. HELLO AGAIN ACTED WITH
REGARD TO SEX CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE FIVE AND AS
YOU HEARD THIS CONTROL SECTION
ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION
WHAT'S ABILITY IN ALLOCATING
FEDERAL FUNDS IN THOSE ARE
BEYOND THOSE THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW ABOUT THEIR BEYOND THAT
THE FUNDS THAT ARE IN THE
CARRIAGE ACT- AND SO IT'S
REALLY COURSE THE COMING
NINETEEN RESPONSE INTO AN
OFFSET THOSE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS. AND WE KNOW
THAT CURRENTLY THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE DOES NOT HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU ACTED A BY
THE LEGISLATURE OR SEEK FORMAL
IMPRESS WE'RE PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT FINANCES OPENS YOU
AMENDING THE LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL I'M A WORSE
OVER SAY WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- AND SO IF I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT WE DO WANT
TO KNOW THAT UNLIKE CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN POINT NINE-
THERE'S NO EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR
THESE FUNDS IN THIS IS BECAUSE-
THE STATE DOESN'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT KINDS. WILL RECEIVE FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE DON'T
KNOW THE SIZE OF WHATEVER
ALLOCATION WE ALSO DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'LL BE RESTRICTIONS LIKE
THERE ARE I'M CURRENTLY THE
CURES ACT FUNDING SO I'M IT
MIGHT PERHAPS BE THAT YOU KNOW
THE AT FOR MY BROUGHT PURPOSE
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S WHY
POSSIBILITY. SO TIED TO IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD HAVE A FORMAL ROLE IN
WAITING IN ON HOW THESE FUTURE.
THEN AND HEALTHCARE A LARGE
BOWL GIVEN THE- CONSTITUTIONAL
ROLE RELATED TO. THERE RIGHT
ABOUT. ONE YOU COULD JUST
CREATED DIFFERENT. FOR LET. IN
SESSION NOT AND YOU COULD HAVE
SOMEONE FOR. YOU COULD ALSO
LIMIT THE USE OF FUNDS OR- THEY
AMOUNT OF FUNDS THAT COULD BE
AND IT COULD GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AGAIN THIS COULD BE.
THE SERVICE I KNOW WHAT FUTURE
FEDERAL FUNDS THE STATE WILL
RECEIVE AND SO- SO HE COULD GET
SOME GUARD RAILS TO KIND OF-
LIMIT THIS AUTHORITY IN OTHER
WAYS AS WELL. THERE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH-
WITH YOUR STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATION. AND TO THINK
ABOUT SOME DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
VERY GOOD- COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. IT SEEMS IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT. I MEAN I THERE'S NO
WAY THAT THIS LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO. TURN DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT HELP US TO DO THE
JOB WE NEED TO DO- IT JUST TO
THE EXTENT THAT. MY NOTE HERE
IS FUTURE FOR FUTURE FUNDS AND
TO THE EXTENT WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA WHAT THOSE
FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE. IN WHAT
CATEGORY THEY'RE GONNA BE AND I
JUST THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY HAS TO BE INVOLVED
IN THE DISCUSSION. ONCE WE
RECEIVE NOTICE THAT THOSE FUNDS
ARE GOING TO COME AND- WHETHER
WERE IN SESSION OR NOT WE ACT
VERY QUICKLY AND I WILL SAY
THAT I'VE SPENT MORE TIME ON
SOME PHONE CALLS AND I EVER
THOUGHT I'D EVER I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOWS HIM. WITH THE WORD OR
WITH THE THING- BUT BUT WE'VE
GOTTEN REALLY GOOD AND WE
DEVELOPED. IN THIS. THE VOTE
AND TO THINK SELECT. AT A
DISTANCE SO- IF THERE IS NO
OTHER COMMENTS WILL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM. YEAH SENATOR
DRAWS OF YEAH THIS IS I THINK
THIS IS PROBABLY THE STRONGEST.
OF ALL THE- THE AUTHORITIES
THAT ARE BEING- THIRTY THAT'S
BEEN ASKED FOR SO THERE'S LIKE.
PRETTY MUCH NO OVERSIGHT. NOW
WE'VE BEEN OFFERED SOME NOTICE.
I MEAN ALL OF THOSE THINGS
COMBINED. YEAH VERY GOOD- WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR THAT
TESTIMONY- ISSUE NUMBER ONE
NINETY NINE WHICH IS CONTROLLED
SECTION THIRTY SIX- WOULD TURN
IT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WELCOME WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF FINANCE. THIS
THIS CONTROLSECTION IS FOR
BECAUSE IN THE REVISION AND IS
A SATISFIED A KID AND AS I
CONTINUE TO PROFESSIONAL COVE
IN NINETEEN RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR THIS IS-
PROPOSED ESPECIALLY IN THE
EVENT THAT THERE IS A SURGE OF
NEW CASES IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE
AND AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THIS
IS MODELED AFTER THE CURRENT
GOAL SECTION THIRTY THAT WAS
PUT IN PLACE BY SP. TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD THE LA.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SET ASIDE TWO
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN A
FUND THAT THE GOVERNOR COULD
ACCESS FOR FUTURE KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED EXPENSES THAT HAVEN'T
YET BEEN IDENTIFIED AND SO AS
YOU HEARD THE ADMINISTRATION
IS. PROPOSING THE USE OF
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX TO
EXPAND THESE FUNDS FOR ANY
PURPOSE RELATED AND TO
BASICALLY COVER NINETEEN WITH
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
NOTIFICATION OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
SO THIS PROPOSED LANGUAGE IS
VERY SIMILAR TO THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE I SB
EIGHTY NINE TO GOVERN THE
BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT WAS-
APPROPRIATE BY THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT BEFORE LEGISLATURE IS
ABOUT TWO OUT OF SESSION- FOR
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING. I'M SO
THERE IS A STRONG REASON FOR
DOING AT THAT POINT GIVEN THE
BILL I JUST ENJOY THE COULD BE
IN SESSION HOWEVER WE WOULD
KNOW THAT THE SECTION THIRTY
SIX PROCESS HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT PERSPECTIVE- BUT THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME TO
REVIEW THOSE NOTICES. ANALYSIS
IN HIS IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO
GET- THE INFORMATION
LEGISLATURE HAS REQUESTED.
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO FLAG
THAT ARE IN YOUR STANDING IS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT WOULD BE EYOND THIS TO
CREATE NINE BILLION THAT WOULD
BE GOVERNED. BY THE CONTROL
SECTION. LEADS DIRECT KOBE
NINETEEN RELATED X. I'M AND
THAT WOULD BOTH CURRENT. AS
WELL AS THE- YOU'RE- I YET
RECEIVED INFORMATION ON HOW
THIS THESE FUNDS WOULD BE
SPENT- AND FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
DEPARTMENTS WOULD RECEIVE THEM
FOR WHAT PURPOSE- AND IT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO US THAT THE
SPENDING WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
ANY KIND OF CONTROL SECTION OR
OTHER PROCESS- OR- REQUIRE ANY
KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
NOTIFICATION. I'M AT LEAST AT
THIS POINT THAT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING- SO THIS IS ALSO
REALLY A PARTICULAR NO BECAUSE
IT'S EVEN LAST- LAST KIND OF
CONTROL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS OVER THIS FINDING. THAT
PENDING IS CURRENTLY ON
INCLUDED IN NINETEEN OH ONE.
BUDGET ITEM. SO WE STERN THINK
ALL OF THE FUNDING THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED SHOULD- BE SUBJECT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. ON
LEGISLATIVE CONTROL- AND SO
PART OF THAT CERTAINLY THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SHOULD GO
THROUGH A PROCESS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COMFORTABLE WITH
AND ALSO WE THINK THAT. I'M
EVEN THE DEAFENING THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED FOR BACK. CONTROL
SECTION THIRTY SIX THAT THAT
PROCESS COULD BE ENHANCED IN A
MORE ROBUST TO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. HAS AN APPROPRIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS. AND AGAIN
THEY'RE PROBABLY MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OPTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER- IT
COULD FOR EXAMPLE AGAIN SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE HAVE MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY SET DIFFERENT
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
DEPENDING. ON WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN SESSION IT
COULD REQUIRE LEGISLATION
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL PRIOR TO
YOU- FUNDS BEING MADE
AVAILABLE. IF YOU PUREE IT OR
REQUIRE CERTAIN THINGS BEING
MADE AVAILABLE WHEN THAT
NOTIFICATION. I'M IS MADE I'M
ALSO AND DIFFERENT THE COULD BE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE TYPES OF
USED TO FIND- OR THERE COULD BE
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING THOSE
AFTER THE FACT SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN KEEP TRACK OF
HOW. MANY HAS BEEN USED. VERY
GOOD. TWENTY CENTER NIELSEN.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT TO
OUR ATTENTION AS TO A CURRENT
AND LOOMING ISSUE BEFORE US.
AND KIND OF THE PROOF IN THE
PUDDING I THINK IS ONE EIGHTY
NINE WAS PASSED THE IT DID A
CORD A LOT OF AUTHORITY. AND
THEN A MAJOR- MAJOR
EXPENDITURES WERE THEN. FOR
MASKS. AND MANY OF US WERE
REQUESTING INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CONTRACTS. IN FACT I HAVE A
PENDING THE- REQUEST WILL JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE TO
AUDIT THE CONTRACT. NOW I'M
WAITING MY WAY THROUGH IT
MYSELF THE I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY-
BUT I'M ACTUALLY FAVORABLY
DISPOSED TO THE DIRECTION I'M
SEEING THAT IT WAS NEGOTIATED.
BUT BUT HERE'S THE POINT. THIS
IS IN THE BILLIONS THAT WE'RE
AUTHORIZED THE EXPENDITURE OF
IT BUT THAT WE THE LEGISLATORS
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER. AND
THAT'S GOING TO WAY TOO FAR SO
WITH A AND I HAVE NO. QUESTION
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION CANNOT
COME TO TERMS WITH OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT BEING INFORMED AND EVEN
APPROVING OF CERTAIN THINGS
THAT'S A GENERAL OBSERVATION
BUT I THINK THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT MOMENT. IN A
SEVERAL YEAR EVOLUTION. OF
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION AND
BUDGET EXPENDITURES AROUND HERE
AND I AM HAPPY TO SEE IT THE
TIME HAS COME. THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU SENATOR
AWESOME YET- I HAVE A QUESTION
IS. WHERE WITH THIS- STOPPING
IN THE FACT. I MEAN WHAT'S THE
TIME PERIOD IN WHICH- THIS
AUTHORITY WOULD EXIST HERE. AT
HE SAID ALRP FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS IS PROPOSED FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
BUDGET BILL SO THIS IS CONTROL
SECTION PROPOSED OR THAT THAT
BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY.
OKAY WELL I JUST WANNA. AGAIN
THIS IS LIKE THE OTHER ONES I
THINK ON TOO MUCH CONTROL
WITHOUT AND ENGAGING THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT'S INVOLVED- IF
YOU PUT IT ALL TOGETHER IS THAT
IS THAT CORRECT THAT IT WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY SIX OR SEVEN
BILLION. WHAT'S THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RIGHT WE'RE CONTINUING
TO DERIVE FIND AND REFINED THE
EXPENDITURES AS YOU KNOW AND
YOU ALL ARE VERY WELL AWARE-
THE EXPENDITURES WHEN
EXPENDITURES ARE NEEDED AND
RAN. AND CONTINUES TO BE
REFINED AND WE ARE ALSO AS PART
OF THAT REALLY TRYING TO TRACK
WHAT AND THAT'S GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS AREN'T WHEN WE'RE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT POTENTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT AS WELL AS THE
POTENTIAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WERE DISCUSSED EARLIER ITEMS
AGAIN CONTINUING TO DO THAT AND
CONTINUING TO. PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE GENERAL FUND AS WE MAKE
BUDGETARY DECISIONS I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IS THAT- WHILE
WE RECOGNIZE IT THAT- WE'RE
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT THE
GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW THE
pIMPORTANT EVEN IF WE GET
REIMBURSED I THINK WE NEED TO
KNOW WHAT WE'VE EXPANDED AND
THEN HOW MUCH OF THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN REIMBURSED AND- AND HOW
MUCH IS LEFT AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT ANY OF US HAVE A REALLY
GOOD GRASP ON ANY OF THAT. SO
ON THE MORE MORE DISCUSSION ON
THAT YEAH HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
IF I HAVE A- FOLLOW UP ON THAT
MATTER BECAUSE A- GIFT TO. THE
MUEZZIN MEMORY OF MY SHALL I
SAY.DURING THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED ALLOWING A GOVERNOR TO
DECLARE A DROUGHT EMERGENCY NOW
THAT WAS ALSO OF. AN EMERGENCY
OF GREAT MAGNITUDE. BUT MY
FIRST READING OF THE BILL
INDICATED TO ME THERE WAS NO.
SEC TIME THAT THIS EMERGENCY
WAS NOT IN EXISTENCE ANYMORE. I
DOUBT THAT THIS LAST
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY IS.
NOT STILL IN EFFECT RATHER THAN
IT IS BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
TERMINATION TIME. AND MY
READING OF EIGHTY NINE AND
WHERE WE'RE AT WITH THAT I
DON'T THINK THERE IS THERE
EITHER. SO I THINK MY POINT IS
WE HAVE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
CAREFUL ABOUT JUST SIGNING A
BLANK CHECK INS IN HERE. WE
NEED TO HAVE A HAND. IN SOME OF
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
REGARDING POLICY REGARDING THE
BUDGET. AND REGARDING
EXPENDITURES THERE FROM SELF.
THANK YOU. I DO AGREE- MY NOTES
A BLANK CHECK. SO IT'S A AM I
THINK WE AT THE CONCERN IS THAT
WE NEED TO KNOW- THINK WE NEED
A LITTLE BIT MORE ACCOUNTING
AND- THIS IS OBVIOUSLY AN AGO
SHE XIN ISSUES- SO THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOW TO HANDLE
ALL OF THESE AYE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THE CONTRACT THAT
WAS LET FOR THE FOR THE MASKS
WITH WITH CRITICAL- AND IT IT
IT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED. THE
BOTTOM LEVEL OF CONCERN THAT
THAT I HEARD IN MY COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE LACK OF PP AND THE
FACT THAT MEDICAL PERFECT
COULDN'T GET WHAT THEY NEEDED
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE AND THAT THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY UNTENABLE SO
WHATEVER HAVE HAVE HAPPENED TO
GET US TO GET THIS FIRST LINE
SO THAT WE WERE THERE AND WE
CAN GET THEM. THE ITEMS I'M I'M
ALL FOR IT. BUT WE IT'S DONE
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT. WHAT HAVE WHAT TRANSPIRED
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS DONE-
IN THE WAY THAT THE STATE.
WOULD WANT IT TO BE DONE WITH
AN ARMS ARM'S LENGTH CONTRACT
AND IT WAS IT WAS ABOVE BOARD
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU ARE
VIEWING THAT CONTRACT BECAUSE I
AM AN ATTORNEY AND I. THAT'S A
THAT'S A LOT OF WORK TO GO
THROUGH THAT STUFF. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR TAKING
TAKING THE LEAD IN AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAD WHAT WE NEEDED.
BUT BUT IT'S NOT LIKELY THAT
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND SO- I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE AT THE TABLE
FOR MONTHS MOST OF THIS SO. I
DO I DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THIS IS ONE OF
THE HOLD TO. OPEN ITEMS. AND I
EXPECT THAT THERE WILL BE. OF
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF. OF A
POSSIBILITY. THAT THAT THERE IS
THE POSSIBILITY OF DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF. OF CONTROL AND THAT
WERE WILLING TO GIVE WITH
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS. OF DOLLARS.
US SO THAT WE CAN. WE CAN LET
THE ADMINISTRATION MAKE SURE
THAT WERE. THAT WE GET WHAT WE
NEED IN IN AND HANDLING THIS
PANDEMIC WE HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC. TO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER. TWO HUNDRED.
WHICH IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT EXPANDING
BBO INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
AND- INNOVATION. AND WILL TURN
THIS OVER TO THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. UNLESS WE HAVE THE BE-
HERE. WELCOME A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR REALLY HARBISON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
COMMISSIONER AL RUNS FROM. MY
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT WILL BE
PRESENT. GREAT BEFORE IS YOURS.
WELCOME. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS MANNY
ALVAREZ THE COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. GOVERNOR CONTINUE TO
INCLUDE IN THIS MAY REVISE THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL CONCERNING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. IS
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD A
PROPOSAL THAT WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
PRACTICES. THAT WOULD EVEN THE
FINANCIAL TROUBLE WERE IN. THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS OBVIOUSLY
DEVASTATED SO MANY CALIFORNIANS
WE KNOW THAT FINANCIAL CRISES
MAGNIFY OVER ALL THESE
FINANCIAL PREDATION. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WOULD HELP COMBAT
THESE ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES FOR
SOME OF THE FOLLOWING. A NEW
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
DIVISION ACOSTA RESEARCH
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH. I
SUPERVISION AND REGISTRATION
FUNCTION TO REGISTRANTS
SUPERVISE NEW CLASSES OF
COVERED PERSONS OFFERING
FINANCIAL SERVICES CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS AN ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
RESOURCES TO BETTER PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PURSUE BAD
ACTORS. AND THE NEW COVERED
PERSONS POPULATION. A NEW
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
OFFICE TO ENCOURAGE INNOVATIVE
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
AND THE RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT
THERE OF. AND CREATING A NEW
OFFICE OF THE ARM BUT IT'S
PERSON TO ENSURE COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE NEW DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED A CONFIDENTIAL FULL AN
IMPARTIAL REVIEW. RESOLUTION
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING TO CONSOLIDATE ITS
STATE CORPORATIONS FUND AND THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FUND.
AND THEREBY CREATE A NEW
FINANCIAL PROTECTION FUND.
FINALLY TO CAPTURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT CURRENT AND FUTURE
ROLE ITS NAME WILL AGAIN BE
CHANGED COMPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION INNOVATION.
THE UPDATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CLARIFIES WHO WILL BE
COVERED BY THE NEW REGISTRATION
PROVISIONS. THE PROPOSAL DOES
NOT COVER OTHER AGENCY
LICENSEES ACTING WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THEIR LICENSE. AND
MOST OF THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
TOUCH EXISTING DEPARTMENTAL
LICENSEES. FURTHERMORE THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T CREATE NEW
LEGAL STANDARDS GOVERNING
BEHAVIOR OF EXISTING LICENSEES.
YOU UNFORTUNATE STRATEGIES YES
BUT THERE ARE NO UNDERLYING NEW
LEGAL STANDARDS. THE PROPOSAL
WOULD REQUIRE THE REGISTRATION
OF NEW COVERED PERSONS WHICH
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
OVERSIGHT INTO I'M LICENSED
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES WHILE
HELPING TO FURNISH NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE ON
REGULATED INDUSTRIES. YEAH WILL
HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND WILL HELP INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE WHICH
INDUSTRIES NEED ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS. SOME THOUGH THIS
PROPOSAL WAS IMPORTANT IN
JANUARY IT IS ALL THE MORE
CRITICAL TODAY. NEW PRODUCTS
NEW ACTORS NEW SCHEMES WILL POP
UP AS UNSCRUPULOUS ENTITIES
LOOK TO EXPLOIT. CONSUMERS
DESPERATION. IN FACT WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED SANTA AND WE'RE
NOT EVEN A FULL QUARTER INTO
THIS CRISIS. NO QUESTION IN MY
MIND D. B. O. WILL BE DEALING
WITH THE NEGATIVE ASPECTS OF
THIS ONGOING FINANCIAL CRISIS
FOR SOMETIME TO COME.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PROACTIVELY
REFINES THE TOOLS NEEDED TO BAN
THE FINANCIAL DISTRESS KERR. WE
DON'T ENACTED NOW I WORRY WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK BACK MONTHS FROM
NOW REGRETTING THAT WE DIDN'T
DO MORE SOONER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. YEAH YES I'M
SURE WE WOULD LIKE TO- ADDRESS
THE ELLIE IS ONLY OWES
RECOMMENDATION THAT THIS BE
MOVED TO A POLICY COMMITTEE WE
THINK IT BELONGS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT IS A
SUBSTANTIAL COMMITMENT OF
PERSONNEL AND DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROJECT AND ALSO- WITH ALL
STATE WOULD DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE ALL SICK
MANY COME BACK HERE WITH EASY
THING AND THEN HIRING STAFF AND
WRAPPING UP THE PROGRAM AND ITS
MISSION I JUST MENTIONED. TO
START. SUPER THE WORK. BOB
KELLY ON. THANK YOU CHAIR ASKED
WE RECOMMEND AS YOU HEARD FROM
FINANCE- THAT THIS PROPOSAL BE
HEARD THAT THE POLICY PROCESS
RECOMMENDED APPROACH BOTH
BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REALLY KEY POLICY QUESTIONS
THAT ARE INVOLVED THIS IS- THE
SIGNIFICANT KIND OF CHANGE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE THINK
THAT THERE'S NOT MUCH TIME IN
THIS PARTICULARLY- IN THERE'S
ALWAYS A COMPRESSED TIMEFRAME-
THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
PARTICULARLY THIS YEAR AS AS
YOU ALL KNOW THERE'S A VERY
COMPRESSED TIME. PROJECT HAND.
PROCESS I'M SO WE THINK AFTER
THOSE POLICY DECISIONS ARE MADE
IT WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
THEN TO PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF
FINDING THAT COMMENSURATE WITH
WHATEVER THOSE CHANGES ARE. SO
THAT MIGHT NEED ADJUSTING THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED CURRENTLY IF THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT OPTIONS BEING UP. AND
PROPOSE CURRENTLY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. SO WE THINK
THAT- REALLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET IT RIGHT I'M IN SO DOING IT
TO THAT PROCESS ONE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THAT'S THE CASE AND
HELP ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT
FUNDING LEVEL. IS ALSO PROVIDED
I'M AND OF COURSE THERE'S
ALWAYS- YOU KNOW OPTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR. IF
FUNDING IS TO BE EXPEDITED. THE
KIND OF THINGS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED A LEGISLATURE
INTERESTED IN DOING THAT. ALSO
WE JUST KNOW THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT FUNDING IS PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WE HAVE WE DO
RECOMMEND SOME TWEAKS. I'M ONE
OF THEM IS THAT WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD REJECT
FUNDING FOR POSITIONS THAT ARE
NOT NEEDED IN THE BUDGET YEAR
SO. THIS FAR AS FINDING A
PROPOSAL NOT ONLY REQUIRED
REQUEST FUNDING FOR POSITIONS
THAT ARE NEEDED STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUT
ALSO SOME POSITIONS THAT DON'T-
DON'T START INTEL FUTURE YEARS
SO MAYBE THEY'RE NOT NEEDED
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND SO WE THINK THAT
POINT. THE LEGISLATURE CAN
EVALUATE WHAT NEEDS ARE OF THE
PROGRAM THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY GIVEN THAT ITS NEW
PROGRAM SO. JUST JUST FINDING
THE ONES THAT WOULD BE NEEDED-
AND THAT AND EIGHT YEAR IF YOU
WERE TO TAKE THAT APPROACH. AND
ALSO THAT SOME TYPES OF
ACTIVITY SHOULD BE FUNDED. ON A
LIMITED TERM PILOT BASIS SO AT
AS WAS MENTIONED THERE ARE SOME
NEW FOR EXAMPLE YOU ON. YOUR
PROPOSES AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL. REALLY AND THERE'S
SOME UNCERTAINTY BACK IN. THOSE
NEW OFFICES SO WRITING LIMITED
FUNDING FOR THOSE. HERE IN THIS
ACTIVITY LEVEL LEGISLATURE BACK
IN A FEW YEARS ASSESS WHETHER
THEY'VE BEEN EFFECTIVE OR
WHETHER. THEY SHOULD CONTINUE.
VERY GOOD AND BRING ISSUE BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE HAS SATURDAY
NEAR NIELSEN CHAIR HAPPEN. MY
COLLEAGUES. THIS IS A- SIMILAR
ISSUE THE OVER TALKING ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF POLICY. JUST AS
WITH POLICY THE LEGISLATURE'S
SEATED STARTING THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO HAS DONE SO OVER MANY
YEARS. OF SEATING POLICY OF
RAISING FEES. AN AFFECT TAXES
ON DIFFERENT ENTITIES LICENSEES
ETCETERA. WERE BY EITHER THE
FEE FOR THE TAX IF YOU WILL
CALL IT THAT WOULD BE IMPOSED
BY THE DEPARTMENT. VIA UP ON A
MEDICAL ONE INDEX TO SOME
PARTICULAR FACTOR. BUT JUST BY
VI<c.cyan>. BY THEIR OWN VOLITION</c>
RAISING THE FEES AND OR THE
APPLICATION OF THE UNIVERSE
THOSE FEES WERE IMPOSED ON.
THAT IS A VERY COMMON PRACTICE
NOW AND AS WE APPROACH APPROACH
THIS PARTICULAR AREA I THINK WE
NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT
ASPECT TOO THANK MANAGER. IMAGE.
WELL LET ME LET ME JUST SAY
THAT. BUT I MEAN APPRECIATE THE.
THE INTEREST IN PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC DURING THIS DIFFICULT
PANDEMIC I MEAN I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT. THE PROTECTION
OF THE PUBLIC IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S WHEN THE.
THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF THE SITUATION
COME OUT BEYOND- START PRAYING
ON ON INDIVIDUALS BUT- MY A GUT
REACTION QUITE FRANKLY IS THAT
THE WAY TO DO. A REORGANIZATION
OF THE DEPARTMENT IS TO DO IT
THROUGH THE REORGANIZATION
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE. EITHER
THROUGH LEGISLATION OR THROUGH
THE RE ORGANIZATION PROCESS
THAT. OUR THAT REQUIRES YOU TO
PUT IT IN WRITING AND TAKE IT
THROUGH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION- THAT WAY EVERYBODY
GETS A CHANCE TO SEE WHAT ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT WHO'S GOING TO
BE AFFECTED. WHAT WHAT ARE THE-
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
THIS IS FAIRLY EXTENSIVE- IT'S-
IT IS ABOUT WALKING INTO AN
AREA THAT HAS- SOME ISSUES THAT
I THINK MANY OF US WANT TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
EXACTLY HOW IT WOULD WORK- I
ALSO. I HAVE- IT RECEIVE SOME
CONCERN IN REGARDS TO. THE
LANGUAGE AND IT THIS IS ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY. IN DOING A
BILL- DURING THE REORGANIZATION
PROCESS IS REAL IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU SEE IT IN WRITING AND YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TO RESPOND BUT-
IN PARTICULAR SB TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE THAT WAS PASSED A- THE-
LAST TWO YEARS AGO- IN IT'S THE
TRUTH IN FINANCING WHICH HAS
PROTECTIONS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND THE TRAILER
BILL- CHANGES SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE AND- AND IT
FUNDAMENTALLY HANGES THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
BECAUSE IT IT CHECK IT USES NEW
DEFINITIONS AND- AND IT IT THAT.
THE IT THE BILL AS IT WAS
PASSED ALLOWS ROLL MAKING
SIMILAR TO THE DODD FRANK- AB
FEDERAL LEGISLATION SO- SO PART
OF THE CHALLENGES MAKING SURE
THAT. THAT WHATEVER LANGUAGE
THAT IS ADOPTED REALLY FITS IN
WITH THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED IN
THE PAST SO HAVING SAID THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT.
IT IS RECOMMENDED TO BE WHOLE
HELD OPEN I THINK THERE'S MORE
DISCUSSION ON THIS IT MAY BE
THAT. THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S A
WAY TO BE ABLE TO GET TO YES
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION-
APPRECIATE THE CAN CAN
APPRECIATE AND THAT ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE WE'RE CBO. IS GOING TO GO
ON THIS BUT- I REALLY FEEL
STRONGLY THAT- THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO A
REORGANIZATION AS A BUDGET
ITEM- UNLESS IT'S FAIRLY FAIRLY
MODEST IN. AND SMALL. AS WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
ASK QUESTIONS SO THAT WILL
REMAIN OPEN AND I'M SURE WILL
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK SOME MORE ABOUT THAT- AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. FOR COMING IN AND GIVING
US- THE WISDOM OF DOING THIS.
THIS CHANGE AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
AND ITS ISSUE TWO HUNDRED AND
ONE WHICH IS THE USED CAR
DEALER SALES TAX AND PRIVATE
PARTY VEHICLE SALES VALUATION.
WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
HUNDRED CHAMBERLAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO ISSUE
TO ALL ONE CONTAINS TWO MAY
REVISED GOALS. BOTH OF WHICH
ARE AIMED AT MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
EXISTING TAX GAP FROM THE SALES
OF USING. THE FIRST PROPOSAL OF
WOULD REQUIRE USE USE VEHICLE
DEALERS TREATMENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
APPLICABLE SALES TAX MEASURE BY
THE SALES PRICE. ALL ALONG WITH
ALONG SAME TIME FOR YOU- SUBMIT
THE REGISTRATION FEE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
THIS REQUIREMENT WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE ON JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO YOU USE
MOTOR VEHICLES ARE REQUIRED TO
REGISTER CURRENTLY ARE REQUIRED
TO REGISTER VEHICLES WITH A
PARTNER MOTOR VEHICLES. AND PAY
THE REGISTRATION FEE WHEN TO
USE CARS SOLD. SEPARATELY THE
USED VEHICLE DEALERS ARE
REQUIRED REPORT. SALEM AND
REMIT SALES TAX CALIFORNIA TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
WHEN THE WHEN THE TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
RECEIVES DATA. OTHER THEY
RECEIVE DATA FROM THE DMV ON
VEHICLE REGISTRATIONS QUARTERLY
THEY'VE USE THAT DATA TO
ESTIMATE THE VALUE VEHICLES
SOLD BASED ON THE DMV'S
REGISTRATION FEE SCHEDULES. CTF
REYES ANALYSIS TO SHOW THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT. GET OUT
OF BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF SALES
TAX PAID ON USED CAR SALES AND
THE AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE
EXPECTED TO BE PAID BASED ON
THE DMV'S REGISTRATION DATA.
THIS TAX CAP CONSIST BOTH OF
SALES BY DEALERS WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACTIVE SOLDIERS FROM THAT.
AND INTENTIONAL AND REPORTING
OF THE SALES VALUE OF THE
VEHICLES. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
THE PROPOSAL IS REQUIRED USE
MOTOR VEHICLE THE DEALERS
TREATMENT THE POLITICAL SALES
TAX ALONG WITH REGISTRATION
FEES TO THE DMV WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS FROM THE DATE OF SALE. IT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE ENVY.
OUR TO WITHHOLD REGISTRATION OF
VEHICLES PURCHASED FROM USED OF
VEHICLE. IN OUR PAYS TO THE DMV
SALES TAX- AS MEASURED BY THE
SALES PRICE. THIS PROPOSAL IS
ESTIMATED TO BRING AND- TWELVE
pABOUT TWENTY FOUR MILLION PER
YEAR THEREAFTER. SO THE SECOND
PROPOSAL. YOU WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THERE ARE THAT THERE BE A-
WHEN THERE IS A PRIVATE SALE OF
A OF A VEHICLE VALUE OF THE
VEHICLE CAN'T BE BELOW CERTAIN
LEVEL TO ORDER CURRENT LAW. ON
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
CONTRACTS WITH THE DMV TO
COLLECT USED TAX FOR THE
VEHICLE PURCHASERS ON PRIVATE
PRIVATE PARTY SALES. EAGLE
PURCHASERS ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
THIS TAX TO THE DMV WHEN THEY
REGISTER THE VEHICLE. USE TAX
PAID IS BASED ON THE SELF
REPORTED SALES PRICE OF THE
VEHICLE. AN AMOUNT THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE CD GFA TO
VERIFY. ANALYSIS BY THE CD TFA
SUGGEST THAT THE SELF REPORT.
AND THEN READ UNDER REPORTED
ALLOWING THE PURCHASER TO AVOID
TAX AND FEE LIABILITY ON THE
PURCHASE. DMV DATA INDICATES A
PRIVATE PARTY VEHICLE SALES
SALES PRICES ARE ABOUT 33%
LOWER ON AVERAGE IN SOME MORE
CARS SOLD THROUGH A DEALER.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL WHEN THERE
IS A PRIVATE PARTY SALE OF THE
VEHICLE THE VALUE OF THE
VEHICLE WOULD BE SET AT THE
GREATER OF THE STATED VEHICLE
SALES PRICE SO THE SELF
REPORTED SALES PRICE FOR EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF THE VEHICLES
PRESUMPTIVE VALUE. THE
PRESUMPTIVE VALUE IS DEFINED AS
HAS HE EITHER THE KELLEY BLUE
BOOK VALUE OR SOME OTHER
SIMILAR MOTOR VEHICLE GUIDE AS
AS PRESCRIBED BY THE DMV. IF
THE ACTUAL VALUE OF THE
VEHICLES LOWER THAN THE 80% OF
THRESHOLD THEN THE PURCHASER
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
THE DMV WITH A CERTIFIED
APPRAISAL OF VALUE IN THE CAR
THE LOWER VALUE WITHIN TWENTY
DAYS OF THE DATE. THIS PROPOSAL
IS ESTIMATED TO BRING IN THIRTY
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
SIXTY ONE MILLION THEREAFTER.
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS. HI
I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ALSO MENTION THAT SHE
DID YOU HAVE A STAFF IS ALSO
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO.
WELCOME. I'M SURE BROWN YOU ARE
WITH THE LA- WE'RE CONCERNED
HAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON PRIVATE PARTY SALES
WOULD PLACE ON REASONABLE
BURDENS ON MANY COMPLAINED
TAXPAYERS BY REQUIRING THEM
EITHER OVER PAY USE TAX SORT OF
ENCOURAGE THE HASSLE AND
EXPENSE OF ATTAINING A
CERTIFIED APPRAISAL AND
SUBMITTING IT TO. THE AND THE
THIS WOULD OCCUR BECAUSE THE
PROPOSAL DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
ACCOUNT FOR VARIATION AND
LEGITIMATE USED CAR SALE
PRICES. YES PROVIDED MY
STANDARD VEHICLE GUIDES LIKE
THE KELLEY BLUE BOOK AND
CRUCIALLY ON INFORMATION
NINETEEN BE DOES NOT COLLECT.
SUCH AS THE CONDITION OF THE
VEHICLE AND EVEN IF THE ANTI
COLLECTED MORE DETAIL
INFORMATION ABOUT VEHICLES WE
SAYING. THAT MANY LEGITIMATE
SALES PRICE IS STILL LIKELY
WOULD FALL. RUSSELL PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. BECAUSE OF
THESE CONCERNS AND GIVEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S WANTED TIME TO
DEVELOP AN ALTERNATIVE TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS BEFORE
BUDGET MUST BE ADOPTED. WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE MISTER
THE PORTION OF THE
MINISTRATIONS FOR POLLS ARE
RELATED TO OUR SALES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS. CENTER NIELSEN ONLY
THAT THIS MAKES MY POINT THAT
WAS FORMALLY EMPHASIZED HERE
THIS IS ANOTHER QUANTUM LEAP.
WELL THIS IS AN ITEM THAT IS-
THERE IS SLATED FOR A HOLD OPEN
AND I WHILE I APPRECIATE THE
THIS REALLY HAS TWO SECTIONS
ONE WHICH IS A USED CAR DEALER
SALES TAX. AND THEN THE OTHER
PART WHICH IS A PRIVATE PARTY
VEHICLE SALES- I SAID I SUPPORT
THE USED CAR DEALER SALES TAX
PORTION OF THE- OF THE PROPOSAL
I JUST HAVE A REAL I HAVE
HEARTBURN OVER THE PRIVATE.
PARTY VEHICLE SALES BECAUSE IT
MAKE SOME ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
PRIVATE PARTY SALES- A SALE OF
A- USED CAR FROM ONE PERSON TO
THE NEXT AND QUITE FRANKLY- THE
INDIVIDUALS ATTENDED DO THESE
KINDS OF SALES ARE PEOPLE WHO
CAN AFFORD TO GO INTO A NEW
DEALERSHIP AND BUY A CAR. AND
SO IT IT IT- GETS ITS LOWER
CLASS LOWER INCOME AND MET-
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES THAT ARE
ARE- ARE SELLING CARS AND TO.
UP REQUIRE THAT- DO IT TO SET
UP THE PROCESS TO TRY TO GET
THEM TO PAY THE HIGHER. THE
HIGHER. TAX JUST SEEMS TO ME TO
BE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND SO- I
DON'T I DON'T FEEL REAL
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT BUT- I
THINK IT HIT THE POOR PEOPLE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BUT- BUT THE
OTHER PART I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH. THIS ISN'T- A
HOLD OPEN ITEM AND SO I'M WILL
SIT BACK FROM BUT BUT I DO HAVE
THAT INVITES ME TO ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THAT CARE
YES- YOU CONVINCE ME. I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU AND I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT. I'M NOT THOUGHT OF IT
THAT WAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE.
SENATOR RUSSELL SO WE'LL SEE IT
BACK TO WILL IT MEAN SOME
GEYSER- ANOTHER- AT AT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
OH TWO WHICH IS THE VAPING TAX
AND WILL TURN THE MATTER OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL THE WHITE
PART OF FINANCE- IN NOVEMBER
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX WHICH RAISE THE TAX ON
CIGARETTE AND TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
AND ALSO CATEGORIZE THE
CIGARETTES. THE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FOR THE FIRST TIME. I
BUT AS A RESULT THESE VAPE
PRODUCTS ARE CURRENTLY TAXED AT
59% OF THE WHOLESALE PRICE. TO
ADDRESS THE SURGEON USE A
DATING PRODUCTS BY YOU. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ESTABLISH A WEEK
BASED TAX ON NICOTINE. ON THE
CIGARETTE BABY PRODUCTS THAT
ARE BETTER RATE OF ONE DOLLAR
FOR TWENTY MILLIGRAMS OF
NICOTINE AND THIS IS A NEW TAX
IN ADDITION TO THE EXISTING
TAX. THIS NEW TAX WILL TAXI
SERVICE MORE SIMILAR RATE
IMPOSSIBLE CIGARETTES BASED ON
NICOTINE DELIVERY. E.
CIGARETTES DELIVER NICOTINE
USERS MUCH MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
INEXPENSIVELY THE COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES AND THEREFORE THE
EXISTING TAXES NOT PROPORTIONAL
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH ARE. ALL
REVENUES REYES PURSUING THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD GO INTO A NEWLY
ESTABLISHED SPECIAL FINE AND IT
WOULD BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATION ENFORCEMENT AND
THIS. FOR GROWTH AND MEDICAL
COSTS. I AT WILL ALSO NOW BE
SUBJECT NOW THIS THIS CIGARETTE
STAMPING. WHICH IS FIXING ON
PRODUCTS GENDER THAT THE TAXES
EIGHT. TAXES DISTRIBUTOR LEVEL
AND THEN PASSED ON TO THE
CONSUMER IN THE FINAL RETAIL
PRICE STANCE WILL BE AFFIXED
BASED ON THAT TEARS OF TWENTY
MILLIGRAMS OF NICOTINE CONTENT
CONTAINED WITHIN THE CAR. BY
THIS NEW TAX ID SAY THAT TO
RAISE THIRTY THREE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND A FIFTY
MILLION. THE FOLLOWING YEAR-
GIVEN THAT THIS IS A NEW TAXES-
THE ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE MRKET
IS ALSO IN THE STATE OF MAJOR
FLOCKS. OF THESE REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERABLE ANSWER. AND I
THINK WITH MY REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE LA. BROWN
YOU BRING YOU ARE AGAIN FROM
THE ALLEY- BACK IN FEBRUARY
OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO TAX THE
CIGARETTES. SEVERAL FINDINGS TO
STAR OUR REVIEW OF THE
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE SUGGESTED
THAT. PROPOSED TAX LIKELY WOULD
REDUCE BOTH USE AND ALL THE
CIGARETTE USE SUBSTANTIALLY.
AND ALTHOUGH THE TAX LIKELY
WOULD INCREASE ADULTS CIGARETTE
SMOKING- IF LEGISLATURE DOES
WISH TO ENACT NEW TAX ON
CIGARETTES THE PROPOSED
NICOTINE BASED TAX STRUCTURE.
IS REASONABLE WITH THAT SAID
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
PROPOSE A COMPELLING ARGUMENT
FOR THE RATE THAT FOR. YOU THE
SELECTION OF AN APPROPRIATE.
TAX RATE INVOLVES A NUMBER OF
CONSIDERATIONS. COVER DETAIL
BUT THEY JUST FOR IN YOUR IN
AND FOR THE DISCUSSED IN OUR
FROM YOUR WORK- REGARDLESS OF
WHAT RATE IS SELECTED ASSURE
THE LEGISLATURE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE TAX WE RECOMMEND.
INDEXING THE TAX RATE TO
INFLATION AND REVISITING THE
RATE. FREQUENTLY WE ALSO
RECOMMEND. CRISIS FLEXIBILITY-
IDEALLY THIS WOULD MEAN
DEPOSITING THE REVENUE. IN THE
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD OF
CREATING A NEW SPECIAL. FINALLY
AS OUR COMMENTS SUGGEST HE
CIGARETTE TAXATION INVOLVES
SEVERAL COMPLEX POLICY
DECISIONS I'M FOR THE MORE THE
PROJECTED REVENUES NOT LARGE
ENOUGH TO MAKE A MAJOR
DIFFERENCE IN THE OVERALL
STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET.
BECAUSE OF THIS WE SUGGEST
FELIZ LEISURE CONSIDER
DEFERRING THIS PROPOSAL TO A
LATER DATE WHEN IT HAS MORE
TIME TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER ALL
SEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRINGING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. I DO I DO HAVE A OF A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN- THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE ITEMS THAT IS A
HOLDOVER OPEN ITEM BUT I HAVE
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT- NICOTINE IS
NICOTINE AND SO I THINK IT IT-
THAT THE MORE THAT WE CAN-
REDUCE THE USE AND PART OF THE
WAY YOU DO THAT IS BY
IMPLEMENTING A TAX ON IT WE
HAVE A TAX ON CIGARETTES I
THINK WE SHOULD DO IT. FOR THIS
AS WELL HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IT IS A ACTUALLY IT
WHETHER IT'S IN THE BUDGET OR
NOT THERE'D STILL BE A
CONTROVERSY IT'S- IT'S OVER THE
DETAILS AND I'VE TALKED WITH
THE NUMBER OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND I THINK THERE'S A SWEET
SPOT TO GET THERE BUT THE- THE
THAT. THE WHOLE DISCUSSION
ABOUT POINT OF SALE VERSUS THE
DISTRIBUTOR AND THEN THIS THE
SPECIAL FIND. I HAS GIVE ME
SOME HEARTBURN I THINK IT
SHOULD GO IN THE REVENUE SHOULD
GO INTO THE GENERAL FUND AND WE
SUPPORT. YOUTH HEALTH FUN
ACTIVITIES IF YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THAT IS A PRIORITY- BUT WE ALSO
WE ALSO FIND FIRST FIVE THROUGH
OUR CIGARETTE TAX AND SO IF
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT INTO A
SPECIAL FUND PART OF THE MONEY
SHOULD GO IN THE FIRST FIVE
BECAUSE THAT'S- THAT'S SEEN
DECLINING REVENUES BECAUSE OF
THE- OF THE SHIFT. TO OTHER
SUBSTANTIVE SUBSTANCES BUT I DO
THINK THERE IS. THERE THERE IS-
EIGHTY AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
SOME CONSISTENCY WITH THE
CIGARETTE TAX. AND TO DO IT IN
A WAY THAT THAT IS NOT- A HUGE
BURDEN ON- EITHER. THE
DISTRIBUTORS OR THAT THE RETAIL
OUTLETS- A LOT OF THESE ARE
SOLD AT THE- MOMENT POP STORES
AND SO TO MAKE THEM RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME OF THIS DOESN'T SEEM
TO MAKE A LOT OF SENSE SO. THIS
IS A HOLD OPEN I WOULD ITEM IF
THERE'S NO OTHER A COMMENT-
WITH WITH THAT- I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THERE IS INTERESTED
INTEREST IN SITTING DOWN AND-
AMONG THE INDUSTRY SITTING DOWN
AND WORKING OUT THE DETAILS AND
I'D LIKE TO. I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
DISCUSSION- MOVE ON TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WHICH IS
ISSUE NUMBER TWO OH THREE NET
OPERATING LOSSES SUSPENSION AND
BUSINESS TAX CREDIT LIMITATION
BUT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT UP
FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IF
THEY'RE AVAILABLE. WELCOME HI
HI INDUSTRY JAMES SPARKMAN
FINANCE. SO FOR ISSUE TWO OR
THREE THERE'S STILL MORE. CALLS
AGAIN THIS IN THEIR SUPER BOWLS
IN THIS ISSUE. PART OF THE
BALANCED APPROACH TO CLOSING
THE BUDGET GAP. NO WAS CAUSED
BY THE CUP IN NINETEEN
RECESSION MAY REVISED BUDGET
PROPOSES TO. TEMPER TEMPORARILY
RAISE TAXES ON LARGER
BUSINESSES- AND TO DO IT
THROUGH A TWO MEANS SO THE
FIRST APPROACH IS TO SUSPEND
THE USE OF NET OPERATING
LOSSES- OUT FOR BUSINESSES WITH
INCOME IN EXCESS OF A MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE FOR THE YEAR
TWENTY. AND ONE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE SUSPENSION
APPLIES TO BOTH THE APPROACH WE
CAN TAX TAXPAYERS INCORPORATION
TAX PAYERS AND IT IS ESTIMATED
TO RAISE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN OF THE BUDGET YEAR
ONE POINT THREE BILLION IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY. THIS IS. CORPORATE NET
OPERATING LOSSES FOR TAX
PURPOSES IF THEIR ALLOWABLE
DEDUCTIONS AND LOSSES EXCEED
THEIR TAXABLE INCOME. TWO
HUNDRED CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
TAXPAYERS ARE ALLOWED TO USE NO
OPERATING LOSSES FROM PRIOR
YEARS ALSO YOU ALL SET UP TO A
100% OF CURRENT YEAR INCOME.
ACTORS ARE ALLOWED TO CARRY
FORWARD NOT OPERATING LOSSES
FOR UP TO TWENTY YEARS IN THE
YEAR THAT THE LOSSES INCURRED.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT ALLOW
ANIMAL THAT IT CURRENTLY DOES
NOT ALLOW ANIMALS TO BE CARRIED
BACK TOSS IT IN CAN PRIOR YEARS.
THE AMOUNT OF NET OPERATING
LOSSES USE AND THE NUMBER OF
TAXPAYERS. LOSSES CAN VARY FROM
YEAR TO YEAR BUT FROM TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE NUMBER OF
CORPORATIONS CLAIMING THAT-
WELLS ARE NOT OPERATING LOSSES
HAS AVERAGED OVER A HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND PER YEAR
AND THE AMOUNT. OF ANIMALS
CLAIMED HAS AVERAGED OVER
TWENTY NINE BILLION. ARE
SIGNIFICANT ANIMALS CLAIMS ON
THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX SIDE AS
WELL. SINCE THE SUSPENSION OF
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS LIMITED
TO TAXPAYERS WITH INCOME OVER
ONE MILLION IT IS EXPECTED THAT
THE MAJORITY. WILL STILL BE
ALLOWED THE FULL EXTENT OF
THEIR CURRENT LAW NOT ALREADY
LOST YOU DIRECTIONS BUT THE
AMOUNT OF DEDUCTIONS CLAIMED IS
EXPECTED TO DROP SIGNIFICANTLY.
TAXPAYERS WHO HAVE OF WHO DO
HAVE THE RENTAL SUSPENDED WILL
BE ALLOWED TO CARRY FORWARD
THEIR ANIMALS FOR AN ADDITIONAL
THREE YEARS BEYOND THE TWENTY
YEAR CARRY OVER LIMIT ALLOWED
UNDER CURRENT LAW. IT IS
EXPECTED THAT MUCH OF THE
SUSPENDED NOT OPERATING LOSSES
WILL EVENTUALLY BE YEARS. THE
SECOND PROPOSAL- WOULD
TEMPERATURE TEMPORARILY LIMIT
THE USE OF BUSINESS INSTEAD OF
TAX CREDITS SO THAT THEY WOULD
ALL SAID NO MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION IN TAX LIABILITY.
242-020-2120 TWENTY TWO. THIS
IS PENSION APPLIES TO BOTH
PERSONAL INCOME TAX CORPORATION
TAXPAYERS IN THE NEST AND IS
ESTIMATED TO RAISE. TWO BILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND NINE HUNDRED
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS BUSINESSES REDUCE
THEIR CORPORATE TAX LIABILITY
BY OVER TWO POINT NINE BILLION
THROUGH THE USE OF CREDITS WITH
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION COMING
FROM THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT.
BUSINESS THIS IS CHRIS USE ON
THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX SIDE
ARE MUCH SMALLER BUT STILL
SIGNIFICANT. THE PROVISION OF
THIS PROVISION WOULD LIMIT
CREDIT USAGE TO FIVE MILLION
PER YEAR. STRUCTURED AS A
DOLLAR LIMIT HOWEVER IT WOULD
PROVIDE A DEFINITE PROTECTION
TO SMALL FOR TO SMALLER FIRMS
FOR WHOM FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN CREDIT. IS GENERALLY CAN BE
MORE THAN SUFFICIENT. IN
ADDITION LIMITATION ALL EFFECTS
BUSINESS INSTEAD OF INSTEAD OF
CRITICISM DOESN'T AFFECT THE-
PERSONAL GESTURE CRITICS SAY HE
ID SO THAT'S- FINALLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT ANY CREDIT AFFECTED
BY THIS PROVISION HAS A LIMITED
CARRY OVER PERIOD- THIS TRAILER
BILL WOULD GRAB THAT THE KERRY
OVER. FOR THAT CREDIT BE
EXTENDED FOR THE NUMBER OF
YEARS THAT THE CREDIT LIMIT IT.
AS SUCH AS IT IS EXPECTED TO BE
UP THAT MUCH OF THE CREDITS
LIMITED UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
WILL EVENTUALLY BE USED AND SO
JUST SAID IN SOME I WOULD SAY
THIS IS A- PROPOSAL THAT RAISES
A LOT OF MONEY. BUT BECAUSE WE
REALLY SEE THAT THIS RECESSION
IS HITTING SMALLER BUSINESSES
CHARTER THAN. LARGE BUSINESSES
IN GENERAL WE. WANT TO. WE LIVE
UP TO FIGHT A AND EXEMPTS. FROM
THESE LIMITS. OF COURSE BIZ AND
THESE BILLS TO THAT. SO NOT
INCLUDES MY COMMENTS AND HAVE
TO TAKE COMMENTS AND I ALSO
WANT TO MENTION THAT- OF.
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS STUFF
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AS WELL. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COULD YOU TELL US
WHAT THE LIMIT I AM I MAY HAVE
MISSED THIS WHAT'S THE LIMIT
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. HOW HAVE
YOU DEFINE SMALL BUSINESSES.
YEAH SO FOR WITH THE END OF
WORLD PROPOSAL. IF YOUR INCOME
IS UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS YOU
WILL NOT BE AFFECTED. BY THE-
BY BY THAT AT ALL SUSPENSION
FOR THE- FOR THE CREDIT
LIMITATION THERE'S NO
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS
IT'S JUST THAT YOUR YOUR
EVERYONE IS ALLOWED TO USE UP
TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
CREDITS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO. YES SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH TO INCLUDE
REVENUE SOLUTIONS IN ITS
PACKAGE OF ACTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET SHORTFALL WE THINK
THAT THE PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD
THESE PROPOSALS BEFORE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE REASONABLE
STARTING POINT YOUR
DELIBERATIONS OF THE STATE HAS
TAKEN SOME MORE I. AFTER
SESSIONS- AND ARE GENERALLY
CONSIDERED IS LESS BURDENSOME
BECAUSE THEY'RE LARGELY
ACCELERATE THE TIMING AND TAX
PAYMENTS. ARE WITHOUT GREATLY
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF TAXES.
A OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
THAT BEING SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL DOES
HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS FIRST THE
REVENUE THERE WOULD BE REYES
FROM THESE ACTIONS ARE SUBJECT
TO SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY SO
BUILDING A BUDGET THE RELY ON A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF REVENUE FROM
THESE ACTIONS WOULD BE SOMEWHAT
RISKY. FUNDING THIS CONCERN
BASED ON OUR INITIAL REVIEW. WE
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES OF THE AMOUNT REVENUE
RAISED TO BE TOO HIGH. ANOTHER
POTENTIAL IMITATION OF THE
PROPOSAL IS THAT IT WOULD
ATTEMPT TO- LIMIT KNOLL
SUSPENSIONS MEDIUM AND LARGE
BUSINESSES BASED ON INCOME
THRESHOLD BUT IT'S MY CALLING
FROM THE FINANCES DESCRIBE
USING AN INCOME THRESHOLD. I
WOULD BE THE PERFECT WAY OF
DISTINGUISHING SMALLER
BUSINESSES FROM LARGER ONES.
AND WE ALSO HAVE SOME CONCERN
THAT THIS APPROACH COULD LEAD
TO SIMILAR BUSINESSES ARE BEING
TREATED DIFFERENTLY UNDER THE
PROPOSAL. ALTERNATIVE HE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
CAPPING THE AMOUNT OF MOLD
ADOPTIONS IT CAN BE USED IN A
WAY THAT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES. ON TAX
RATES. VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NUMBER GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS IS A COLD OPEN
AND- AT THE I THINK THE KEY
HERE IS THAT THERE ARE SOME
ALTERNATIVES IF THE- DID THAT
MAY WORK. BETTER BUT- AT THIS
POINT THIS IS A HOLD OPEN SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO IT ISSUE NUMBER TWO
OH FOUR WHICH IS THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX. AND WILL TURN
THE ISSUE OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY SO-
SO THIS PROPOSAL IN THIS DAY
AND THIS THIS WAS RECALLS THAT
WE PROPOSED IN JANUARY- BUT
GIVEN THE ROUTE THE RECESSION
IT SEEMS- OF. EXTRA URGENCY FOR
DOING THIS TO PROVIDE BENEFITS
RIGHT SOME HELP TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. SO THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE STARTING OF FOR
TAXABLE YEARS BEGINNING ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AN EXEMPTION FROM
THE EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR ANNUAL
FRANCHISE TAX. BOB FOR LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES LIMITED
PARTNERSHIPS AND LIMITED
LIABILITY PARTNERSHIPS UNDER
CURRENT LAW. THE STATE IMPOSES
AN ANNUAL MIP MINIMAL FRENCH I
SECTION EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
ON EVERY CORPORATION AND STATE
FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE. BUT IT
DOES PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FROM
THAT FROM THAT TAX FOR
CORPORATIONS IN THEIR FIRST TAX
YEAR CORPORATIONS MUST EITHER
PAY THE EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR
ANNUAL MINIMUM TAX OR- OR TAX
ON THEIR NET INCOME WHICHEVER
IS HIGHER BUT THEY ARE AT IN
THEIR FIRST YEAR THEY WERE
EXEMPTED FROM THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS. EXISTING ALSO IMPOSES
IN ANY INTEREST TAX OF EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON LIMITED
LIABILITY. COMPANIES OF LIMITED
PARTNERSHIPS AND LIMITED
LIABILITY PARTNERSHIPS BUT THEY
BUT THOSE TYPES OF BUSINESSES
DO NOT HAVE ANY FIRST YEAR
EXEMPTION. AND SO WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS TO EXTEND THE
FIRST YEAR EXEMPTION THAT EXIST
FOR CORPORATIONS FOR BUSINESSES
THAT STRUCTURE AS CORPORATION.
TO SIMILAR BUSINESSES IN THEIR
FIRST YEAR IF THEY ARE
STRUCTURED AS LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES LIMITED PARTNERSHIPS
AND LIMITED LIABILITY
PARTNERSHIPS- COM WE THINK
THAT'S EQUITABLE AND AS I SAID
AND IT DID PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS- RIGHT NOW TO SEE. ON
SMALL THIS IS WHO WE NEED AND
THE COST OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
ESTIMATED AT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THEREAFTER. THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HELLO. THANK YOU KNOW BY MARCH
OUR OFFICE RELEASED REPORT
ANALYZING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE EXISTING
FIRST YEAR EXEMPTION TO NON
CORPORATE BUSINESSES ARE NOW
ALSO STUFF BECAUSE THE NUMBER
OF CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE EXEMPTION AS
WELL AS THE EXISTING EXEMPTION.
ON THESE CONCERNS ARE LAID OUT
WELL ON YOUR AGENDA SO I WON'T
GO OVER THEM IN DETAIL- OVERALL
WE FOUND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I WOULD BE REALLY
TARGETED AWAY THE CHEATING AND
STATED GOAL WHICH IS TO PROMOTE
SMALL BUSINESS- BECAUSE OF THIS
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE-
POSTAL. THIS IS THE ITEM IS A
HOLD OPENER THERE ANY COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF WILL LEAVE THIS
ITEM OPEN. FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER TWO OH FIVE
WHICH IS THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE. OBVIOUSLY AN ISSUE
THAT IS ON THE MINDS OF A LOT
OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR HELP. I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
FITZPATRICK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IN APRIL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WAS TRANSFERRED USING
CONTROL SECTION THIRTY SIX TO
THE SMALL BUSINESS FINANCE
CENTER. PROGRAM FOR USE IN THE
AREA- PROVIDING LOAN GUARANTEES
TO ENTITIES THAT WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL DISASTER
LOAN GUARANTEES OUR LOANS. THAT
INCLUDES ENTITIES OF LOW INCOME
AND ON DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
STATUS. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ADD
ANOTHER FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO THAT OVERALL FUNDING AND
EXPAND THE USE OF THE ORIGINAL
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BROADER LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAMS
BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT MANY
ENTITIES WELL ELIGIBLE FOR LOAN
FEDERAL LOAN DISASTER RELIEF
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE'RE UNABLE TO AT LEAST TO
DATE ACCESS A GOOD NUMBER OF
THOSE. FUNDS IF YOU HAVE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE AYE
BANKER AVAILABLE TODAY AND-
THAT WILL TAKE SOME QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE LA. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THE SITE AND WE
WOULD JUST REITERATE- THE STAFF
COMMENTS IN YOUR AGENDA THAT IN
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR. LEGISLATURE TO
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON HOW OF THE FIRST
FIFTY NOT AND HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR. EXCELLENT
QUESTION EXCELLENT QUESTION
EVERY BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
MATTERS HERE I COULD HAVE THAT
QUESTION ANSWERED ABSOLUTELY.
IT DA M. THE QUESTION IS- TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER YOU
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON HOW
THE- FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE PRE THIS BOB. THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY GRANTED HAVE THAT
THAT WENT TO AND INFORMATION ON
HOW THAT DISTRIBUTION WENT. IT
APPARENTLY THE- BANK STUFF FOR
NOT ON THIS CALL I KNOW THAT
ISSUE WAS DISCUSSED WITH STAFF-
RECENTLY A MAJORITY OF THE
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN PROVIDED
TO ENTITIES AND I REMEMBER FROM
THE CONVERSATION- IN SOME
INSTANCES A FUNCTION OF. SO
MANY. PROGRAMS IN SO MANY
MOVING PARTS ARE TAKING
RESOURCES AWAY FROM- PROVIDING
FULL INTENTION TO ANY
PARTICULAR PROGRAM AT THIS
POINT AS WELL AS THE FACT THAT
SOME OF THESE ENTITIES STRUGGLE
WITH PROVIDING THE
DOCUMENTATION NECESSARY. FOR
THE ENTITIES THAT DO- FINALLY
MAKE THE FINAL DECISION ON
PROVIDING THE LOANS- AND HAVE
HAD SOME CHALLENGES FROM THAT
RESPECT BUT THAT IT WAS THE
EXPECTATION OF THE PART ON THE
PART OF THE AYE BANK. THAT AS
TIME GOES BY THAT. THE FULL
AMOUNT WILL BE RELEASED AND IT
WASN'T. EXPECTED THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY PROVIDED TO
OUR BETA BAILABLE FOR THE
ENTITIES IN THE- ORIGINAL-
CHANCE TRANSFER- RATHER IT WAS
A FUNCTION OF REALIZING THAT
EVEN ENTITIES THAT WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR. FEDERAL DISASTER
RELIEF HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS IT. SINCE DRAWS A YES
CENTER FARMS JUST AS A FOLLOW
UP I'M I'M NOT SURE QUITE
UNDERSTAND THEN. SO FIFTY
MILLION WAS WAS ALLOCATED- AND
I YOU'RE ASKING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION. SO
HOW DO WE JUDGE EIGHT ANY VALUE
WAIT THE USE OF ANOTHER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OBVIOUSLY I
THINK IT'S- GENERALLY SPEAKING
GOOD BUT HOW DO WE- HAVE THE
INFORMATION HOW TO WHAT DO WE
GET THE INFORMATION AS TO HOW.
EFFECTIVE IT WAS AND WHAT KIND
OF BUSINESSES- ACTUALLY GOT THE
FUNDING HOW MANY BUSINESSES
REALLY WERE ABLE TO- BENEFIT-
ESPECIALLY IN THIS TIME. AND
I'M SORRY- BUT THEY ABSENT
SURVIVING IN SOME TECHNICAL
SUPPORT ON THOSE QUESTIONS WILL
CERTAINLY GET BACK TO THEM. GET
BACK TO THESE COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER THE ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION IS AGAIN A FUNCTION OF
A NEXT AND UNDERSTANDING
UNFOLDING AND UNDERSTANDING IN
THIS IS A- RAPIDLY CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT THAT EVEN NOT EVEN
ENTITIES WHO WERE ORIGINALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR SLATED TO RECEIVE
FEDERAL DISASTER RELIEF. I HAVE
HAD- STRUGGLES TO ACCESS IT- OR
OR ACCESS YOU ENOUGH OF THE
FUNDING SO IT THE- BROADER-
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS THE
SECOND TRANSFER WAS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THERE'S A
LARGE PROBLEM. WE ANTICIPATED.
TELL ME JUST SIX SIX THAT THE
IS REALLY A CONVERSATION WE
HAVE TO HAVE WITH THE I. BANK
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THE- CHALLENGES THEY FACED
IN. IN IN WORKING ON THE
REGIONAL FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS-
DO WE HAVE A- WE HAVE SOMEBODY
FROM THE I'VE BEEN HERE PERFECT
TIMING. IT'S LIKE MAGIC YOU
JUST APPEARED. JERRY WE CANNOT
HEAR YOU I THINK YOU NEED TO BE.
I NEEDED NO I CAN READ LIPS.
YEAH BUT- YEAH THERE YOU GO
OKAY GREAT JUST TALK LOUDER AND
LOUDER YOU SORRY I WAS I WAS ON
THE ENTIRE TIME HOWEVER I WAS
NEEDED AND- UNABLE TO I DO
MYSELF IT LOOKED LIKE IT HAD TO
BE DONE FROM YOUR AND SO LET ME
JUST GIVE ALL THE CONTACTS ON
THE ORIGINAL FIFTY MILLION AND
THIS ADDITIONAL REQUEST FOR
FIFTY MILLION ON APRIL THIRD
THE I. BANK RECEIVED A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION. FOR
THE DISASTER RELIEF LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM ADD AT THAT
TIME WE ACTIVATE THE PROGRAM
THERE WAS ONE PARTICIPATING
LENDER THAT WAS AVAILABLE WHICH
FUNDS AT THAT TIME AND
IMMEDIATELY THEY WERE SOMEWHAT
OVERWHELMED PUT OUT THE ENTIRE
AMOUNT THAT THEY HAD AVAILABLE
IN THEIR CAPACITY WITHIN A
MATTER OF ABOUT A WEEK AND A
HALF AND AT THAT POINT WE HAD
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH A
NUMBER OF PARTICIPATING
POTENTIAL FOR SPRING LENDERS
AND SINCE THEN WE'VE BROUGHT
FIVE HUNDRED ON. THE PLATFORM
AND WE HAVE. FOR ADDITIONAL
WONDERS THAT TOUGH WE HAD JUST
FOR ON THE- OVER THE NEXT WEEK
OR- AND SO THE- DESIRE OF THE
STATE WAS AT THAT SAME. TIME TO
FINAL THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY THAT WAS IN DIRE NEED
RELEASED INTO THE FEDERAL
DISASTER RELIEF PROGRAMS. AND
SO. HE AND THE US BE IS IDLE
PROGRAMS WERE AVAILABLE WE
WANTED THEM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THOSE PROGRAMS. AND AT THE
SAME TIME THE CDF BUYS THAT WE
HAD SOLICITED TO JOIN OUR CREEK
STATEMENT ROUTE. OCT TARGET THE
LOW WEALTH AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THE REALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WORK
TRYING TO RAISE FUNDS
INITIALLY. ISSUE LOANS THERE
WERE TWO WAVES OF THAT AS
YOU'RE AWARE OF THE SECOND WAVE
STILL HAS AVAILABLE BUT WILL
SOON COME TO EXPIRATION. AND
WITH THAT EXPIRATION WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE TIMING WILL
BE OPPORTUNE. FOR THE SHIFTING
OF THE ACTIVITY. INTO OUR LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM. SO ANOTHER
WAY THE PRIMARY HAS BEEN ON
OTHER PROGRAMS. THE PRIORITY
ONE OF THE STATE WAS TO REALLY
GET GUIDE THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE FEDERAL DISASTER RELIEF
THAT WAS COMING THROUGH THE P.
P. P. AND SQ PROGRAMS AND- THE
PPA HE IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
THIS AFFORDABLE LOAN A VERY LOW
INTEREST RATE. AND ONCE THAT IS
EXHAUSTED WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
AND ARE PREPARED FOR YOU
SIGNIFICANT ACCELERATION OF THE
ACTIVITY INTO OUR GUARANTEE
PROGRAM JUST WANTS. THERE'S A
DRAWS OF IT SO. SO HOW DO HOW
DO YOU MEASURE HOW EFFECTIVE
THE FUNDING WAS THE FIRST
FIFTY- HOW MANY BUSINESSES
WHERE WOULD KIND OF BUSINESSES-
BUT YOU KNOW BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF DECIDING WHETHER
ANOTHER FIFTY BILLION SHOULD
OKAY DID AND FOR WHAT. WHAT DID
YOU LEARN FROM IT. YES WE'VE
LEARNED THAT THERE WAS VERY
SIGNIFICANT THAT MAN. AND THE
SIGNIFIES THAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
JOIN US AS PARTICIPATING
LENDERS. WORK IN A PROCESS OF
FOCUSING ON. A LONG PROCESS AT
THE SAME TIME IS RAISING FUNDS
FOR BOTH HE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
FOR DISASTER RELIEF PROGRAM
HAVING SAID THAT. AS I
MENTIONED THE FIRST WEEK OR TWO
THERE WAS IN EXISTING BINDER ON
OUR PLATFORM THAT HAD ALLOCATED
CAPITAL AND DAY EXHAUSTED THAT
IMMEDIATELY AND THE LAST WEEK
TO TEN DAYS WE BROUGHT ON
ADDITIONAL VENDORS AND SO- AS
OF THIS WEEK. THE VOLUME HAS
PICKED UP AGAIN SIGNIFICANTLY
WE'VE NOW WILL- PUT FORTH
CONDITIONALLY ABOUT THREE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS OF LOANS
AND- COMPOSITION OF THOSE LOANS
IT'S PRETTY AT THIS ACROSS ALL
THE BEER INDUSTRY SEGMENTS. BUT
NOT ONE INDUSTRY SEGMENT THAT
AVAIL THEMSELVES OPPORTUNITY IS
THE SERVICE INDUSTRY FOLLOWED
BY HEALTHCARE SERVICES FOLLOWED
BY AUTOMOTIVE SERVICES BUT IT
REALLY SPANS THE GAMUT RETAIL
CARE SERVICES MANUFACTURING-
CONTRACTORS. AND SO WE'RE BASED
ON THE SMALL SIZE PLEASE WITH
THE CARPET. INDUSTRY SECTOR
THATARE. WELL WHICH UNITIES.
THERE IS A VERY JUST SHE- THAT
ALL OF THE NUMBER ENTERPRISE.
THE FEMALE ALL BUSINESS AS WELL
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME TRACKS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. BUT THIS IS
DEFINITELY SO ANY ISSUE THAT-
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART I'VE
I'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO MANY MANY SMALL BUSINESS.
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT FELT LEFT
OUT OF THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
PACKAGE- ONE BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND HOW BY THE
APPLICATION THEY JUST NEED A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND NUMBER
TWO THAT IT WENT SO QUICKLY THE
MONEY WAS EXHAUSTED IN A VERY
VERY PERIOD OF TIME. SO THERE'S
REAL INTEREST IN THIS BUT I DO
THINK THAT THAT I KNOW I MEAN
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- IN- IN
THE GRANT PROGRAM THAT YOU'VE
BEEN ADMINISTERING AND- IN
PARTICULAR- IMMIGRANTS WHO MAY
NOT SPEAK THE LANGUAGE. I ONE
OF THE. JEREMY BUT THAT
QUESTION IF YOU RUN GRANT
ASSISTANCE. APPLE ASSISTANCE
EIGHTY SIX ACTIVE CENTERS ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN SUPPORTING
BUSINESSES STATE. HI I'M BUT
WE'RE WE'RE HAVE A REALLY TIME
YOU AT THE CLARITY IS NOT WELL
IT IS NOT GOOD AND WE DON'T
HAVE YOU ON. OKAY IT COULD USE
A COULD YOU SAY WHO YOU ARE
AGAIN. HIS MIND AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE. I THINK
I MANAGE THE GRANT. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT. GREAT THANK
YOU YOU MAY NEED TO. IF YOU'RE
USING YOUR PHONES YOU MAY NEED
TO TAKE THOSE OFF AND SPEAK TO
US DIRECTLY BECAUSE IT'S COMING
THROUGH PRETTY GARBLED. OKAY IS
THIS CASE THAT BETTER OKAY
GREAT- SO WITH ALL WITH THE
PROGRAM THERE ARE CURRENTLY
EIGHTY SIX IT IS NOT THERE ALL.
THE AND WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING
ON SUPPORTING ACCESS. OKAY I
THANK. ON THE MATTER. WE HAD TO
LEAN AND- YOU CAN. IN THE FIRST
ROUND SO WE REALLY DOUBLE DOWN
ON TRYING TO GET ACT ONE. BY
COMMUNITY THAT SPOT RIGHT
BUTTONS ARE WERE ABLE TO JUMP
INTO DOING LOANS ARE ONCE MORE
BANKS AND- LENDERS WERE ABLE TO
DO THAT CALIFORNIA'S SAUCE. SO
WE WERE VERY PLEASED WITH THAT
OF COURSE THAT DIRECTLY
AFFECTED- YOU KNOW THE I THANK
CARDINAL SIGNIFIES BUT ALSO
FOCUSED ON GETTING BE. I HAVE
ARE SMALL. I WILL LET AND I
WILL BE AT AT I HAVE
CAPABILITIES IN. THIRTY ONE
LINE. AND DOES OF COURSE YOU
MINISTER MY WHICH IS A
PARTICULAR MANAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE CENTER WE HAVE
ACTIVELY TRYING DOCUMENTS
WEBINARS AND CALL BOTH. OKAY SO
IN ORDER TO REACH MEETING AND
THAT THAT HE INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THE
BEGINNING A MARCH OF IN
ADDITION A- ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO SUPPORT VOTE FOR SO. YOU CAN
BOB I HAVE CALIFORNIA
INTERESTED THAT. WHEN THAT HE
IN ADDITION TO THE CENTER. ALSO
WITH YOU SEE A SIX WRITING AND
I WAS FROM ON WHICH AS WELL AS.
IF YOU SUFFER THE EFFORTS OF
OUR CENTER STUDENTS. ALL. OR A
LOT OF WITH IT MORE THAN ACCESS.
HELLO PAUL BAR AS WELL RECALL
IN A BAR I DON'T. YOU STILL
WANT GO WE WILL ZACHARY IN THE
AND YOU BE ABLE TO SUPPLY I
THANK. WELL THANK WE MISS ABOUT
EVERY. WELL EVERY THIRD OR
FOURTH WORD BY MAYBE I CAN SEE
THIS BE I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S ROLE INTERESTING THIS
AB IT WOULD BE HEALTH IF HAD
AND I DO OF. THE KINDS OF
BUSINESSES AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS THAT
WAS GIVEN TO US. BUT WHERE
WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED- A LOOK
AT SOME OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF.
OF THE- BORROWER- AND OF THE
AMOUNTS AND THEN SOME OF THE-
IT BET BIG OUR REACH THAT
YOU'VE DONE THAT THAT WILL TELL
US A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT. HOW
WE CAN BE HELPFUL IN THE
PROCESS AS WELL BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN- PROMOTING
THIS PARTICULAR GRANT PROGRAM I
BUT I DID THAT FEDERAL PROGRAM
AND I KNOW. THAT MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WERE VERY VERY
DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T GET AN APPLICATION IN IN
TIME OR ELSE THEY JUST COULDN'T
FILL OUT THE APPLICATION AND SO
THE MORE THAT WE CAN GET- SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE OUT THERE
THE BETTER IT'S GOING TO BE
THERE DESPERATE TO GO BACK TO
WORK THEY JUST NEED A LITTLE
BIT. SO WE CAN GET SOME OF THAT
DATA THIS IS A HOLD OVER FOLDER
OVER. A AN ITEMS AND- SO I
APPRECIATE THE- I APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WE WERE LEFT WITH THAT THAT YOU
HADN'T SPEND THE MONEY AND YOU
WANTED MORE SO THAT'S NOT A
GOOD POSITION TO BE IN. BUT WE
DO KNOW THAT THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WHICH IS ISSUED TO- FIVE.
FEDERAL CARES ACT ELECTIONS
FUNDING. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF A
COUPLE MORE ITEMS- WERE WERE
WERE WAITING JUST A SECOND.
WILL WE GET THE SIX CLEAN- A
COUPLE MORE ITEMS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
PART UNDER. PART A THAT WE- WE
PUT OVER AND WE'LL TAKE THOSE
ITEMS. OKAY WILL TAKE UP ISSUE
TWO OH FIVE AND WILL INVITE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
BELIEVE MY COUNTERPART ON THE
SECRETARY OF STATE-
ASSIGNMENTS- WAS ON THE SCREEN
MOMENTARILY I CAN TAKE IT FROM
HERE OR THE- AND HE'S HERE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND HEAR FROM
HER. I'M SORRY I. NO NO.
WORRIES THAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MANY ENSUES
OBSOLETE. STATE THE STATE'S
OFFICE. A STATE IS REQUESTING
SIXTY FIVE POINT FOUR EIGHT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR
FROM THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND.
SPENDING OR REQUEST OF COURSE
IMPLEMENTATION STATEWIDE
MANDATES OF THE HELP HELP
AMERICA VOTE ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND CHIU AS IT RELATES TO
CONSOLIDATED APPROPRIATIONS ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND THE CURES
ACT DUE TO CODE NINETEEN AND
DAMMIT. I'M ON MARCH TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED INTO LAW THE
CORONAVIRUS EIGHT RELEASE AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT YEARS
ACTIVE DROPS LAWYER WITH. THESE
FUNDS EXPIRE ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST 202020% MATCH FUNDS IS
ALSO REQUIRED CALIFORNIA'S
MATCH IS SEVEN POINT YOU
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STORE
MADE WITHIN TWO YEARS RECEIVING
THE FANS. THE MATCHING FUNDS AS
IT RELATES TO THE CURE'S ACT-
IN SPECIFICALLY THE HOW THE
FUNDS. IS I MUST BE IS RELIGION
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO. IN
ADDITION ON DECEMBER. TWENTY
NINETEEN PRESENT SIGNED INTO
LAW THE CONSOLIDATED
APPROPRIATIONS ACT TWENTY
TWENTY. HAD THE SURGERY STATE
IS REQUESTING A PORTION OF
THESE FUNDS AS WELL IN ADDITION
TO THAT CARES ACT FUNDING TO BE
USED FOR THAT. THE COPA
NINETEEN TRANSGENIC. BUT THE
CURES ACTIONS AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY CONSOLIDATED
APPROPRIATION ACT FUNDS ARE
HELP AMERICA VOTE ACT FUNDING
WHICH IS ALLOCATED DISTRIBUTED
AND GUIDED BY THE ELECTION
ASSISTANCE COMMISSION THE AC.
EASY HAS AUTHORIZED FUNDING TO
BE USED FOR COBRA NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND I HAS IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL AREAS OF YOU. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HIGHER LEVELS
OF ABSENTEE VOTING BUT BY NOW
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. INTO
INSURANCE DISABILITY BY ALL
POPULATIONS THE ACQUISITION OF
ADDITIONAL BUILDING EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING HIGH SPEED OR CENTRAL
COUNT TEN LEADERS HARDWARE
SOFTWARE THAT TYPE OF THING.
I'M SECURE BALLOT BOXES
ADDITIONAL WORKERS ELECTION
OFFICE STAFF THAT NEEDS TO BE
DIVERTED IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO
THE PANDEMIC I'M TEMPORARY STOP
THAT TYPE OF THING. THE
GOVERNOR NISSAN ISSUED AS YOU
ARE AWARE OF A AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER CALLING TO THEM NUMBER
SIR TWENTY TWENTY TWO ELECTION
TO BE CONDUCTED AS ALTHOUGH BY
NOW BALLOT ELECTION. THE ORDER
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE
IN PERSON BUILDING UP TREES AND
POINTS TO THE THRESHOLDS
IDENTIFIED IN THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACT. NEEDS OF LEGENDS NOT TO
LEGISLATURE'S NOT TAKING ACTION
ON IN PERSON LOCATIONS FIND IT
MAY THIRTY IF YOU LIKE THE-
ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
SITTING. FOR PERSONS WRESTLES.
WHAT THE IN PERSON.ARE ARE
THAT ARE. A SEPARATE STATE
ESTIMATES THERE WILL BE A-
ACTION BECAUSE SINCE. WITH THE
CONDUCT THEY'LL- NO CHEN
ELECTION FACE BUT- NUMBER APART
FROM WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE. I'M
OF THE REQUESTED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FIFTY MILLION
IS. AL IS LOOKING TO BE
ALLOCATED TO FOR LOCAL SYSTEMS
FOR COUNTIES AS YOU ARE AWARE.
COUNTIES ARE THE ONES THAT DO
ALL THE HEAVY LIFTING
ELECTIONS- AND THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND- AND REALLY NEED
THAT MONEY TO ENSURE THAT THE
ELECTIONS ARE SAFE. AND SECURE.
FIFTEEN MILLION WOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO FOR STATE SUPPORT
AND- THAT WOULD INCLUDE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH STAFF TRAINING
CLEANING ON OUR SIDE PREVENTION
PROCESSES. RECONFIGURATION
ACQUIRING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE.
EQUIPMENT FOR OUR OWN STAFF.
AND IF YOU JUST YOU FORMS A
DATABASE AS WELL AS EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ON THE VOTING
PROCESS CHANGES IN
REQUIREMENTS. USE THE EASY HAS
INDICATED THAT IT WILL BE
FLEXIBLE AND ALLOW SUCH THINGS
AS STAFF TIME TO COUNT TOWARDS
HOW THE STATE'S MAKE THEIR 20%
MATCH. STATES HAVE TWO YEARS TO
MAKE THE MATCH FUNDS AVAILABLE
THEY MUST BE FOR CORONA VIRUS
RELATED EXPENDITURES THERE'S-
INCURRED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE TWENTY TWENTY FEDERAL
ELECTION. THIS YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD OUR PRIMARY AND HAD A
SPECIAL FEDERAL ELECTION JUST
RECENTLY. WE'VE DONE
SUBSTANTIAL PLANNING FOR
NOVEMBER WE ANTICIPATE MEETING
OUR MATCH IN LARGE PART AND
HOPEFULLY ALL THE- TIME IN
LARGE PART TO THOSE COSTS ARE
INCURRED. FOR THE PRIMARY THE
SPECIAL ELECTION IN PLANNING
FOR NOVEMBER. THIS HAS INCLUDED
SUBSTANTIAL TAX STAFF TIME ON
BOTH THE STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL
AND MANY OF YOUR STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN. AN
INTEGRAL PART TO THE PLANNING.
BEGINNING IN MARCH OUR OFFICE
CAN BE IN A WORKING GROUP WITH
OVER A HUNDRED LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
BRAINSTORM COLLABORATE PLAN.
AND HOW WE CAN DELIVER AN
ACCEPTABLE ELECTIONS IN THE
FACE OF CORONAVIRUS IN
NOVEMBER. THESE FUNDS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING STATE
NEXUS SELECTIONS FOR BOTH
VOTERS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YES DEPARTMENT BUT
AS WE JUST LIKE TO NOTE. AND SO
TAKING A LOOK AT THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S THE USUAL
THIRTY DAY WAIT THOSE UNITED
WITH JAIL BC NOTIFICATION IS-
INCLUDED IN THE EVENTUAL BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE IT COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF GETTING THE
MONEY OUT TIMELY- AND WANTED TO
KNOW WE WANTED TO KNOW THAT.
OKAY VERY GOOD. BELIAU. EUROPE.
HELLO NO WE CAN HEAR YOU. I
THOUGHT YOU WERE A. CAN HEAR ME
NOW NOW I CAN HEAR YOU
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY GREAT- NICK SCHROEDER WITH
THE LA- THE STATE HAS A CLEAR
INTEREST. TO HAVE A WELL
ADMINISTERED AND SAFE AND
SECURE ELECTIONS COMING
NOVEMBER AND GIVEN THE REVENUE
LOSSES THAT HAVE BEEN SUSTAINED
BY THE COUNTIES. COUNTIES VERY
LIKELY WILL NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A
PREDOMINANTLY BY MAIL ELECTION
AND THROUGH WE ARE OFFICE
PARTICIPATED IN ALL IN THE
WORKING GROUP'S OTHER SIX
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE ARE
REFERENCED IN THROUGH THOSE
MEETINGS AS WELL AS THROUGH-
INFORMATION STICKERS THEY
PROVIDED INDICATING THAT THE
COUNTIES COSTS COULD INCREASE
BY AS MUCH AS A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE- BASED
ON- ACOSTA SIR TO RUN TO PUT ON
THE BILL BY MAIL ELECTION. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER PROVIDING THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
EITHER THROUGH A LOW INTEREST
LOAN OR THROUGH SOME SORT OF-
MATCHING GRANT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH COMMENTS HERE- YOU
MENTIONED IT- WAS MENTIONED
ABOUT THE NOVEMBER ELECTION. UP
ALL MAIL BALLOT ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER IS GOING TO BE QUITE A
CHANGE FROM WHAT EVERYBODY'S IT
USED TO- AND- WHEN YOU MAKE
CHANGES LIKE THAT IT'S LIKELY
TO. RESULT IN- LESS VOTERS. AND
AS IT IS THIS GOING TO BE THE
CHALLENGE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN TO DO AN ALL WHEEL BY
MAIL- THERE IS A AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THERE'S A
MINIMALLY A THIRD OF THE VOTERS
HAVE NEVER VOTED BY MAIL- BY
MAIL BEFORE SO- WE HAVE GOT. TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN- IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS TO
PROTECT OUR DEMOCRACY AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE KEEP- PROVIDING
THE RESOURCES. ALL WHATEVER IT
TAKES I THINK AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF. UP MORE
FUNDING ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
SHOULD SHOULD BE PUT INTO THIS
WE NEED A LOT OF- EDUCATION. WE
COULD SEE FOR EXAMPLE FROM THE
CENSUS EFFORTS- THAT WE DID NOT
WE HAVE NOT DONE AS AS WELL AS
WE SHOULD ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE STATE SO. I A- IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE VOTERS
HAVE CONFIDENCE. IN THIS NEW
VOTING SYSTEM- THAN WE REALLY
HAVE TO- DO EVERYTHING WE
CANCEL I SUPPORT THIS AND MORE
WHATEVER IT TAKES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE MOST ROBUST
TURNED OUT OF THROUGH MAIL-
THIS NOVEMBER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT AND- THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS- IS TO
PROVE THE FEDERAL FUNDED THIRTY
AND ADOPT PLAY HOCKEY
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET LANGUAGE.
BILL BUDGET BILLING WHICH IT
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE UPON NOTIFICATION TO
THE JB JAIL BC TO TRANSFER
FUNDS. FROM ONE FRIEND TO
ANOTHER AND I DO NOTED THAT-
MAY BE PROBLEMATIC I THINK THE
SENT TO THE EXTENT. THAT THAT
THERE WILL BE MORE DISCUSSION.
ON THIS BUDGET THAT THAT MAYBE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THAT THAT RIGHT BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE THE
MONEY IS AVAILABLE WHEN IT'S
REQUIRED- AND SO I AM JUST
PUTTING PUTTING A NOTE THERE-
WE'RE NOT READY TO VOTE ON THIS
RIGHT NOW BUT- WELL. WE WILL-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH WE'RE MOVING ON TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS CALVET AND THE
IT'S ISSUE TOO TWO HUNDRED AND
SIX THE CLOSURE OF BARSTOW
VETERANS HOME. AND WILL. TURN
THAT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE UNLESS THERE'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
IT'S HERE. WELL THAT IS HERE
JOHN YOU SPACE OR YOU LIKE TO
HURT ME- ALL HAVE A COMMENT
AFTERWARDS BUT IF YOU ALL WOULD
LIKE TO START. SURE YEAH. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETH MISSION SKIING AND I'M
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
VETERANS HOMES FOR JOHN SO
LOOKS JUST LIKE SUSAN LOOKING.
YOU'RE GOING WE CAN HEAR YOU
THAT YOU'RE COMING IN VERY
CLEAR THANK YOU. WHITNEY IS
THOMAS MARTIN DIRECTOR FUTURE
OPERATIONS AND PLANNING FOR THE
VETERANS HOME. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. DUE TO A
COMBINATION OF HIS DARK
CHALLENGES WE HAVEN'T STAFFING
AND FILLING OUR VETERANS HOME
IN BARSTOW IN THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS NOW I'M ON THE STATE.
CALVET IS PROPOSING CLOSING THE
BAR SO LONG IN TWO YEARS. IF
APPROVED WE PROJECT ONCE THE
CLOSURE PROCESS IS COMPLETE IT
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS A YEAR. FOR
MANY YEARS THE BAR SO HOME HAS
BEEN LESS THAN HALF FULL. IT IS
DESIGNED TO BE A FOUR HUNDRED
BED FACILITY AND CURRENTLY HAS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE RESIDENTS. CALVET
STUDY THIS ISSUE AS PART OF OUR
COMPREHENSIVE TWENTY TWENTY
MASTER PLAN WHICH WE RELEASED
ABOUT FIVE MONTHS AGO. AND WE
IDENTIFIED MANY FACTORS THAT
ARE CHALLENGING AND CHARGE SO
PRIMARILY IN STAFF RECRUITMENT
REMOTENESS AND LACK OF. IN
RESPONSE TO THESE FINDINGS IN
GOVERNOR NEW SINCE JANUARY
BUDGET YOU PROPOSE BEGINNING TO
SHIFT OUR OPERATIONS AT THAT
HOME OVER TIME MOVING AWAY FROM
TWO LEVELS OF CARE. THAT HAVE
LITTLE DEMAND AND TOWARD OUR
LEVELS OF CARE THAT WILL
REPRESENT ONGOING DEMAND AMONG
THE- IN THE FUTURE. THIS WOULD
HAVE RESULTED IN A SMALLER
BUDGET CAPACITY OF BANDS AT
BARSTOW AND RESHAPE THE
EMPHASIS OF THAT HOME THIS
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED THROUGH
ATTRITION SO WOULD HAVE TAKEN A
NUMBER OF YEARS. ONE NINETEEN
SAYS HAD SUCH A VAST IMPACT ON
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND THIS
BILL STATUS AND SO QUICKLY. WE
KNEW WE NEEDED TO TAKE A NEW
LOOK AT OUR PLANS FOR THAT
PROPERTY. WE BELIEVE THE BEST
OPTION FOR THE STATE AND OUR
OUR BARSTOW RESIDENTS WOULD BE
TO ACCOMMODATE THEM AT OUR
OTHER SEVEN VETERANS HOMES THAT
WE HAVE. IN THE CAL THIS IS
JUST CLOSE THE BAR SO LONG.
SPECIFICALLY WE BELIEVE NOW IS
THE TIME TO BEGIN THIS PROCESS.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN AND I'M LIKE WE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED
ADMISSIONS INTO OUR VETERANS
HOMES SYSTEM WIDE IN ORDER TO
REDUCE INFECTION RISK IN EACH
LOCATION. AS A RESULT WE HAVE A
VACANCY IS IN OUR OTHER
VETERANS HOMES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO OUR BAR SO RENTS.
THAT MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE IN
ANOTHER TIME IN THERE ARE IN
THERE ARE ANOTHER OPEN ON A
NUMBER OF OTHER LOGISTICAL
FACTORS LIKE THIS THAT POINT
TOWARD STARTING THIS PROCESS
NOW. FURTHER WE STUDIED THIS-
AS PART OF AS WE DEVELOPED OUR
MASTER PLAN AS I MENTIONED AND
THAT INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT.
SIGNIFICANT AND LIKE THE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT PROCESS AND
STAND TOGETHER AND RESEARCH AS
WELL ON THE STOCK. THE CREW
WILL SPEND THE NEXT TWO YEARS
WORKING PERSON BY PERSON AND
FAMILY BY FAMILY. RIGHT OPTIONS
TO OUR RESIDENTS. WE FULLY
EXPECT TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL RESIDENTS IF
THEY WISH IN OUR OTHER SEVEN
HOME NO ONE WILL BE DISCHARGED
THE BAR SO. DUE TO THIS. NEED
AMENITIES JERRY BROWN LOOKING
AND OTHER FACTORS ON AN
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL. WE KNOW THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
RESIDENTS WILL BE SENSITIVE AND
DELICATE. THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN OUR LIVES. AFTER
DECISIONS ARE MADE ABOUT WHERE
THEY WISH TO MOVE WE WILL WORK
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM AND WITH
THEIR FAMILIES TO RE LOCATE
THEM AND THEIR BELONG. FOR THE
STAFF. WE WILL WORK WITH CALLIE
CHART TO IDENTIFY THE OPTIONS
AND AVENUES AVAILABLE TO STATE
EMPLOYEES WHO THANKS THIS SORT
OF CHANGE IN OUR WORKPLACES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
EMPLOYEES WILL SEE THEIR JOBS
CONTINUE AS THEY CURRENTLY ARE
FOR MOST. THROUGH MOST OR ALL
OF THE TO YOUR PROCES. AS LONG
AS WE HAVE RESIDENTS LIVING IN
OUR BARSTOW HOME EVEN A SMALLER
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS. WE WILL
NEED MOSTOF OUR POSITIONS IN
PLACE IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN OUR
PROGRAM WHERE. BELIEVE ME WHEN
I TELL YOU WE DID NOT ARRIVE AT
THIS DECISION EASILY AND WE DO
NOT TAKE IT LIGHTLY. WE KNOW AS
WELL AS ANYONE THE MAGNITUDE
AND IMPACTS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AND WE ARE TAKING GREAT CARE
AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. TO
CLOSE BARSTOW IS TO CHANGE
CALTRANS IDENTITY PERMANENTLY.
BUT WE HAVE RESOLVED EVEN WITH
GIVING OF THIS PROPERTY REST
ASSURED CALIFORNIA'SDEDICATION
TO ITS VETERANS REMAINS TRUE
AND THE STATE INVESTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO YIELD QUALITY CARE
IN HOME LIKE SETTINGS THAT
PROVIDE THESE HONORABLE HEROES
THE SERVICES THEY DESIRE. THANK
YOU THOMAS ANSWERING THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS
WE'D LIKE TO KNOW THE- SO THE
SAVINGS FOR THIS PROPOSALS AND
EXPECTED TO MATERIALIZE UNTIL
YEAR THREE AT LEAST BALK OF
THAT SAVINGS- SO WE WOULD SAY
THAT ANY DELAYS. IN
IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN BUT
CERTAINLY PUSH. ALL THE
MATERIALIZATION OF THAT SAVINGS
BY ANY QUOTE ROUGHLY EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME ADDITIONALLY- AS
THE DEPARTMENT NOTED- AND
IRONICALLY. THE HOLD ON A
MISSION OF THE OTHER HOMES
CREATED AN UNEXPECTED
OPPORTUNITY- AS IT RELATES TO
THIS PROPOSAL AND AS IT MAY BE
THAT THOSE SAVINGS COULD
MATERIALIZE SOONER IN LIGHT OF
THE MANY VACANCIES AT OTHER
OWNS. IT BARSTOW WE'RE TO SORT
OF DRAW DOWN ITS RESIDENT
POPULATION FASTER THAN EXPECTED
AND THE LAST POINT WE WOULD
MAKE IS THAT THIS WOULD BE
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF IT
HAVING BEEN NOT. IDENTIFIED AND
DISCUSSED EXTENSIVELY IN THE
MASTER PLAN CONSISTENT WITH THE
EFFICIENCY TARGETS- THAT THE
ADMISSION ADMINISTRATION HAS
PUT FORTH- COURT APARTMENTS ON
A STATEWIDE BASIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HELLO. THANK YOU
PRESS IT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I WAS
MENTIONED BY THE DEPARTMENT- AS
A PART OF THE MASTER PLAN THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF LIMITATIONS
IDENTIFIED ON WHAT THE BARSTOW
HOME SUCH AS NOT PROVIDING THE
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF CARE
THAT'S A RECOMMENDATION THAT
CAME OUT OF THE MASTER PLAN WAS
TO TAKE AN INCREMENTAL APPROACH
AND ADDRESSING THOSE
LIMITATIONS WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF EXPLORING THE
OPTION OF FUTURE CLOSURE IN
BARSTOW. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL MADE THAT FIRST STEP
BY PROPOSING TO I'M SHIP
CERTAIN CAPACITIES TO HIGHER
LEVELS OF CARE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HIGH LEVELS OF
DEMAND BUT THEN RAMPING DOWN
CAPACITY AND LESS- IT AND LOWER
LEVELS OF CARE HOWEVER AND THIS
PROPOSAL SIGNALS A SHIFT AND
APPROACH AND THAT IT'S A MORE
XCELERATED- ADVANCEMENT TOWARDS
CLOSURE AND WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS MADE PROGRESS
IN. EXPLORING OPTIONS AND
CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
CLOSURE PLAN WE CONCUR WITH THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION THAT-
REJECTING THE MAY REVISION AND
ALLOWING FOR MORE LEGISLATIVE
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADOPT LANGUAGE SO THAT IT CAN
FURTHER EXPLORE SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS. OF THE CLOSURE PLAN
SUCH AS IMPACT ON STAFF- WHAT
ASSISTANCE IT WOULD PROVIDE
STAFF THROUGH THE ON RAMP DOWN
PROCESS BUT THEY ALSO POTENTIAL
OPTIONS FOR ALTERNATIVE USED IN
THE FACILITY- AND THAT THIS
PLAN AS NOTED IN YOUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
A PART OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BY JET. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. GREEN MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. YES SENATOR
NIELSEN ADAMS YOU'RE HAVING
REPRESENTED THE ONLY VETERAN
PHONE FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
THEN FIFTEEN THE EXPANSION SETS
I THINK I'M PRETTY AND THEY'RE
STANDING CONVERSANT INFECTIONS.
TO HOMES AND THE ISSUES
ATTENDED THERE TOO. THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY SENSITIVE AREA.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO RESIDES IN
THEIR- ARE VERY VERY SPECIAL
INDIVIDUALS OBVIOUSLY THEIR
MILITARY HISTORY. THE
RESPECTABILITY DAMAGE THAT CAME
TO THEM WE SORT OF ALL THEM
THAT THAT HOME. THOUGH THAT HAS
BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROJECT
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AND YEAH
BILL. AS WITH ADVANCED THAN IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S BEEN A BOON
TO MANY OTHER AREAS AND I DID
REPRESENT THE SHASTA COUNTY SO
THE I. GOING ON ALL A HOME IT'S
BEEN A PART OF THE YEAR THAT I
REPRESENTED. AND THE DYNAMIC IS
NOT JUST THE INDIVIDUALS HOUSE
THERE IN BUT IT'S OF FAMILIAL
ASPECT OF IT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A
CONSIDERATION WITH ALL SUCH
HEALTH FACILITIES BUT INDEED
THAT IS THE CASE WITH THE
VETERANS HOME. SO I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE- THIS WILL NOT A BE
JUST PUT ON HOLD AND LET TO.
LET'S LOOK AT IT OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME AND CRAFT A PLAN. OF
THE SHORT OF CLOSING THAT WOULD
BE SURPRISING AS FAR AS
BALANCING OUR BUDGET THIS IS
NOT EVEN BUDGET DUST. SO I JUST
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY AS TERMS OF A-
FASHIONING AND OF BEING A AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THIS
PARTICULAR BUDGET SO YEAH BUT
WE WERE LEAVING IT OPEN AND
WILL. WILL CONSIDER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BETTER DRUGS OF ANY
COMMENTS ON THING MAN I AM YOU
KNOW I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT THAT THERE'S NO SAVINGS
TO BE MADE WHEN YOU'RE DOING-THIS KIND OF TRANSITION BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP THE SERVICES
GOING WHETHER THERE'S FIFTY OR
A HUNDRED PEOPLE THERE AND SO-
I JUST I WANNA MAKE SURE THIS
IS DONE IN THE MOST- DELICATE.
AND SENSITIVE WAY BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TRANSFORMING IN
CHANGING PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
MOVING THEM SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING IT IN A WAY THAT-
INVOLVES OF FAMILY AND SO I
THINK THAT THE IDEA OF HAVING A
PLAN IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
SO THE MANAGER IF I MAY. I ALL
I KNOW IS IT VETERANS HOMES
PLACEMENT TO HAVE LONG WAITING
LISTS. TO ASSUME THAT THESE
COULD ALL BE JUST FANNED OUT. I
THINK IS AN UNREASONABLE
EXPECTATION. BUT I THINK THE-
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSAL TO
CLOSE THE BARSTOW HOME AN ADOPT
A PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO A CAR CALVET TO
SUBMIT A CLOSURE PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS A REAL- IS
REALLY GOOD RECOMMENDATION AND
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS-
FIT FOR THE UPCOMING BUDGET-
EACH YEAR- SO I APPRECIATE THE-
TESTIMONY AND THE- STAFF
PROPOSAL TO- TO TAKE SOME TIME-
RECOMMENDATION AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO SEEING A PLAN THAT-
WE CAN LOOK AT AND COMFORTABLE
AT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN IN NOT.
IN OUR HE THAT CONCLUDES PART
AND ISSUE ONE SIXTY NINE THE
DFG H. FACILITIES OPERATIONS
FUNDING AUGMENTATION IS NOW
I'LL HOLD OPEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO. TO THE FIVE A- PART
A AND THERE WERE SOME ITEMS
THAT WE PULLED FROM THE VOTE
ONLY TO DISCUSSION. AND I WANT
TO START WITH ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE- I AM TOLD HERE. THE FACT
THAT THE INTEREST IS IN HOLD
DOING. FIVE AND FIFTEEN
TOGETHER IS THAT RIGHT. VERY
GOOD SO ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES IN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS EMPLOYEES AND
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND SO
WE'LL TAKE THAT. THAT ITEM. AND
THAT WERE DOING A TRIP THAT
TRANSITION HERE VERY QUICKLY SO
WE CAN BEG YOUR INDULGENCE.
MAKE SURE WE GET THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. ON DECK. CLOSE TO GIVE
THEM FIVE THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA. AND. YEAH IT WAS THE FACT
THAT WE AND I WANTED TO START A
FEUD GOING ON YEAH YEAH I THINK
EVERYBODY SEATED SO. YOU CAN.
WHAT WHAT IS OUR FIRST TIME
HALF. FIVE TOGETHER. IN ORDER
FOR DON'T HAVE THAT. THE OTHER
WITH FIFTEEN FIND. THE ONE I
JUST GAVE ME. YEAH OTHERS
THOUGH YEAH SHIA. ALL RIGHT
ITEM FIVE IS THE FIRST THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR ISSUE
RELATED TO ASSEMBLY BILL NUMBER
FIVE. THE THIS IS AN EIGHTY
DEPARTMENT ISSUE. YOUR GENERAL
FUND ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
NINE MILLION. AND THIS IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE RESOURCES TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT DO WE HAVE SOME OF THE
RATIONS FOR THE FINANCE ON THIS.
PLEASE. HI MARK MEADOWS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- BUT MAY
REVISION I CONTINUES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROVIDES UP TO THREE. THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
EACH YEAR OVER THREE YEARS YOU
NEED AND YOU AND I YEAH I ARE
ALSO SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION A YEAR OVER THREE YEARS
TO IMPLEMENT EIGHTY FIVE AS A
REMINDER EIGHTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES A NEW AYE STATUTORY
EMPLOYMENT HOUSE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER A WORKER IS AN EMPLOYEE
OR. INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR.
RESOURCES ARE INCLUDED TE
BUDGET ON ALL OUR RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY IMPLEMENT EIGHTY FIVE
BY ALL BOTH YOU YA TO TRY
EMPLOYEES. A FORM AND CHRISTY
AND MORE HEARINGS AND
INVESTIGATIONS RELATED THROUGH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EIGHTY
FIVE. QUESTION. ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AT THIS POINT
BUT WOULD GO INTO ANY COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS AYE I THINK I'D
REALLY LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CHAIR GETS BACK HERE BEFORE
WE DO IN THE FINAL ON THIS I
GUESS WE'RE NOT VOTING ON IT
THOUGH TODAY ANYWAY BUT IT IS A
MATTER OF THE DISCUSSION SO WE
HAD FINANCED WITH TRAVELER
JAMERSON. OBSERVE THEIR YOUR-
THANK YOU CHAD ALLEN OKAY WITH
ALLEGE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M-
FOR CONTEXT MAYBE. A BIT
HELPFUL SENATOR NIELSEN WITH
RESPECT TO THESE THESE CHIU
PROPOSALS ET DE UM THIS THE
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO ALLOW
STAFF TO RETRAIN TO APPLY THE
NEW TESTS UNDER AB FIVE WHEN
DETERMINING EMPLOYEES STATUS
WHEN THEY'RE REVIEWING.
BUSINESS PAYROLL TAX RECORDS
ON. THAT THE STAFF ARE AS SOON
AS PART OF THIS PROPOSAL TO BE
NEEDED BECAUSE- WAITING TO BE
ADMINISTRATION THEY ANTICIPATE
THAT BUSINESSES WILL APPEAL.
SOME OF THE NEW DECISIONS IF
THE EMPLOYMENT STATUS OF THEIR
WORKERS CHANGES AS A RESULT OF
APPLYING TO TEST AND THOSE
APPEALS RESULT IN IN SOME
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD AT UT SO
THAT'S THE EDT COMPONENT I. T.
I. OR IT'S A IT'S A LARGER
PROPOSAL AND SPECIAL FUNDED ADS
AS MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF. FINANCE NOTED
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
POSITIONS AT THE I. R. OF WOULD
BE WITHIN THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THEY
WERE SPECIFICALLY BE HEARING
OFFICERS ARE TO A JUNIOR KATE
WORKERS COMPENSATION. CLAIMS
FALLING THROUGH THE PROCESS
THERE WOULD ALSO BE SOME OF HIS
POSITIONS WITHIN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE FOR I
WISH CRIME INVESTIGATIONS AND A
FEW POSITIONS ACT CAL OSHA THAT
THE BASIS UNDERLYING THE DIR
PROPOSAL ON A WORKLOAD BASIS IS
SIMPLY BAD AB FIVE WILL WILL
RESULT IN A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
FORMERLY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR. WORKERS BEING RE
CLASSIFIED IN HIGHER ESTEEM
POLICE EMBOSSED THEIR THEIR
DEPARTMENTAL WIDE WORKLOAD
INCREASE I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO
MORE SPECIFIC. ON EITHER THE
PROPOSAL SENATOR. RETURN TO THE
CHIRLA. THREE GET ON. BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. YES
CENTER NIELSEN I JUST WILL
OBSERVE WE NEED TO TAKE A VERY
CLOSE LOOK AT THIS. THIS
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION AND WHAT
IT WILL TAKE TO IMPLEMENT THAT
LEGISLATION THE CONCERN TO ME
IS THAT TO CERTAIN PEOPLE ADMIN
AND CERTAIN POSITIONS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE A VERY DIFFERENT
POSITIONS AND IT'S- GOING TO BE
A- NOT MAY BE. CONFUSING BUT
PERILOUS SO WE HAVE TO GO WITH
CAUTION THAT'S MY RULE. THIRD
DRAWS OF. IT SENATE BILL SO I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
POINT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE. UP A HARD
TRANSITION TO GO TO- FOR
EMPLOYERS FOR OWNERS OF
BUSINESSES FOR OFF FOR THE MEN
AND WOMEN WOMEN THEMSELVES SO
I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE. THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE READY FOR IT- VERSUS
JUST GET GETTING INUNDATED AND-
ALREADY A LOT OF QUESTIONS SO I
THINK. THIS FEELS LIKE WE'RE IN
THE BUDGET BETTER POSITION MORE
PREPARED TO HANDLE THE ISSUES.
WELL THE CONCERN I HAVE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM IS JUST
THAT THE- LANDSCAPE IS
CHANGING- THERE WAS A BILL
HEARD I BELIEVE YESTERDAY THAT-
READ SOME MORE EXEMPTIONS. AND
WHETHER THAT GETS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE NODDED IT'S A IT
THERE IS SOME UNCERTAINTY AND
THERE'S I THINK IT'S GOING TO
TAKE A LITTLE WHILE FOR US TO
GET THROUGH THIS AND SO- I AM I
APPRECIATE THE I APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW THE DIRECTION WE'RE GOING
IN. I SUPPORTED- BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE WE ON.
BEFORE WE START ACTING TO BEEF
UP A DEPARTMENT- WE NEED TO
KNOW WHAT WE'RE BEEFING IT FOR
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
SO- THIS IS A BY A HOLDOVER
ITEM AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION SO THAT WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING. IN AS
WE AS WE MOVE ON THIS IT'S
CREATED A GREAT DEAL OF
UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR IN THE
COMMUNITY AND I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO SAY WE KNOW WHERE WE'RE
GOING AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO WITH IT SO HOLD OPEN I THINK
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE- THAT-
CONCLUDES ITEMS NUMBER FIVE. IT
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IN ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE. NUMBER TWENTY ONE IN
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE WILL
TAKE THOSE TOGETHER. THAT SAID
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AGAIN. VICTIMS OF
WAGE THEFT AND THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FUND LOAN
TO THE GENERAL FUND. SO IT WILL.
DO WE WANT TO START WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO GO HEAD AND-
MARK MEADOWS APARTMENT OF
FINANCE- BUT MAY REVISION
WITHDRAWS- THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSED AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED THE USE OF OLE
GARMENT REGISTRATION YOU REFUSE
TO. WAGES IN THE CAR INDUSTRY
AND WOULD HAVE EXPANDED
ALLOWABLE. USE H. FIND. THEY
ARE TYPES OF WAYS CLAIM HOWEVER
WE ARE WE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW THE TRANSFER OF FUNDS-
YEAH IN THE WAGE FIND THE I. R.
STUDY RESTITUTION FINES
INCLUDING THE GARMENT ACCOUNT-
PRIOR TO THE END OF YOUR
GENERAL FUND SWEET. QUESTIONS
VERY GOOD. HELLO. THANK YOU
TRAVIS ALLEN- AGAIN WITH THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE ONLY THING
I WOULD ADD I'M JUST BRIEFLY IS
THAT LAST YEAR THIS SUB
COMMITTEE APPROVED AS PART OF
THAT THE BUDGET ACTED COMPANY
EXAMPLE MENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE DIRECTED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO PROVIDE A RECORDS
THE LEGISLATURE WITH DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT THE GARMENT
FUND SPECIFICALLY AND ITS
CHALLENGES RECENTLY WITH
SOLVENCY ARE WE'RE STILL
ANTICIPATING THAT REPORT WAS
DUE EARLIER THIS YEAR- WITH
CURRENT CONDITIONS.
UNDERSTANDABLY OPPOSITE WAYS
IT'S TO BE EXPECTED BUT I THINK
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL AS OUR
OFFICE WOULD APPRECIATE
REVIEWING THAT REPORT AND
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION GOING FORWARD-
WHEN REVIEWING THAT. THE FUTURE.
OF THE RESTITUTION FINES OF
THEIR STRUCTURE. BRING THE
MATTER TO THE COMMITTEE. YOUR
HONOR DRAWS SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I REMEMBER
THIS VERY. VERY WELL WHEN THEY
CAME BEFORE US LAST YEAR- ON
THE ISSUE OF THE WAGE THEFT IN
THE WAGE CLAIMS BY THESE-
GARMENT WORKERS. AND SO I I'M
I'M- ARMED. DISAPPOINTED THAT.
OF LAST YEAR'S CASES OF ONLY
NINETEEN OF FORTY SIX CASES
PENDING- IN THE RESTITUTION
FUND HAVE BEEN PAID THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING SO. THIS IS ALL
ALL THE WORLD CASES WERE ALL
THE REQUIRED PAPERWORK IS
SIGNED SO WHAT IS THE ISSUE
HERE HOLDING BACK PAYMENT OF
THESE VICTIMS OF WAGE THEFT ARE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND AS IT IS
THEY WERE ALREADY. IT'S NOT
JUST THIS YEAR THAT'S DELAYED
THEM GETTING THEIR FOR THEIR-
WAGES IT'S A YEAR OR TWO YEARS
OR WHATEVER IT TOOK TO GET TO
THE POINT OF GETTING THEIR
CLAIMS PROCESS SO. CAN SOMEBODY
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME. YES MORE
COMMUNITIES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN RESPOND TO THAT-
THIS IS A REMINDER ON LAST YEAR
WE TRANSFERRED TO NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM BEHIND WHICH FUNDS
THROUGH THE GARMENT ACCOUNT. TO
PAY YOUR WAGE CLAIMS IN
ADDITION. WE NEED THIS YEAR AS
PART OF TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
TRANSFERRED ANOTHER SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION- FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO PAY GARMENT CLAIMS. AND
SO WE HAVE FRIENDS OVER OVER
SIXTEEN MILLION TO PAY-
GOVERNMENT CLAIMS AND- BUT IT
THE OTHER LINE YES YOU IS THAT
THERE IS A HIGH DEMAND BUT-
ENOUGH OUR RESOURCES YOU
ADEQUATE HEY ALTHOUGH I AM CAIT
ALL OF THE ON. WHICH FUNDS.
ALTHOUGH I'M HERE ALL THE WAY
CLAIMS THAT ARE COMING IN AND-
ZERO IT. RESPONDS THROUGHOUT.
POINT ABOUT A SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT LANGUAGE WE JUST WANTED
TO SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE SO
IT'S UNDER WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOUR REFLECT THIS OUR
CURRENTLY WAITING WE WERE
WAITING AT THE TIME TO ADDRESS
THE NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING
CLAIMS I'M CURRENTLY THERE'S
TWO HUNDRED. AND TWENTY SIX
CLAIMS OR FORGETTING WE'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING READY TO
TRANSFER ON ANOTHER EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION HEY THAT
OUTSTANDING CLAIMS THIS YEAR SO
THAT SHOULD ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING. CLAIMS RAINY THIS
YEAR. WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR THE
EXPLANATION. YOU KNOW FOR US- A
CLAIM OF YOU KNOW FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS OR A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW. IS REALLY NOT A WHOLE
LOT- BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW THESE WORKERS WHO.
LIVE WORK WORSE THAN ON THE
EDGE THE ALREADY LIVE IN DEEP
POVERTY AND FOR THEM NOT TO GET
THEIR THEIR WAGES PAID I THINK
IS REALLY OUTRAGEOUS- AND I
THINK IT JUST POINTS TO. THE
PROBLEMS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY AND HERE WE ARE YOU
KNOW. DEALING WITH AND THOSE
WORKERS DEALING WITH THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T GET PAID IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT HAS THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF WAGE THEFT- THERE'S
SOMETHING LIGHT THE- TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS A WEEK. IN WAGE
THEFT FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
WEEK IMAGINE WHAT WE AS A STATE
WOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY YOU KNOW
FOR THOSE FAMILIES AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED AS A RESULT OF BEING POOR.
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
WEEK WOULD GO INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES- SO I FEEL SO
STRONGLY ABOUT THE LIABILITIES
OF THESE EMPLOYERS AND IT MAKES
EMPLOYERS TO DO GOOD. WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE. PUT ME GIVES THEM
PUT THEM AT A BIG DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE THEY THEN ARE. PLAYING
BY THE RULES THEIR PAIN AS THEY
SHOULD THEIR TREATING THEIR
WORKERS GOOD AND THEN YOU HAVE
A WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHERS ALL
SCRUPULOUS ARE ARE REALLY
THERE'S MORE TO IT THAN JUST
THOSE THOSE CLAIMS. THERE'S A
MUCH BIGGER DEEPER PROBLEM THAT
I HOPE WE ADDRESS AS WELL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THOSE ISSUES THAT-
UNDOUBTEDLY IT TO THAT AFFECTS
ALL OF US- BUT THOSE FAMILIES
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE. ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST AND THAT'S-
WE'RE- ALL KINDS OF RAMPS TO
TRY TO FILL IN AND BE IN BEHIND
AND IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE. AT THAT VERY MUCH.
CENTER NIELSEN DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THIS. ALL RIGHT ARM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT COMMON IN
WE PROBABLY SHOULD LOOK AT THAT
A LITTLE BIT A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER INTO WHAT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. BACK THAT CONCLUDES
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AND
THIRTY ONE- IS A THIRTY ONE- IT
ALL I'M SORRY I'M SORRY WE
DIDN'T WE DIDN'T GET TO THIRTY
ONE. I'M SORRY YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE WHICH
IS THE- LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUND LOAN TO THE
GENERAL FUND. AND WILL TURN IT
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I MARK HARMON BY ANTS
ON THE NEIGHBOR VISION INCLUDES
A SPECIAL ON LOAN. SEVEN
MILLION TO THE GENERAL FUND
RESPONSE YOU. I BUDGET
SHORTFALL ON THE LOAN IS COMING
FROM THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ONE OF THE PURPOSE
OF WHICH IS TO FIND PROVIDE A
LOT OF RESEARCH USED. OR SPENT
ON REVENUE SOURCES CIVIL
PENALTIES RELATED TO PARK OR
OTHER PRIVATE. GENERAL LACK I
WOULD MAKING THIS DECISION
SECOND TO CONSIDERATION OF
PROGRAMS HE- ACTUALLY RESPONDS
ON ALONE CAN BE MADE WITHOUT
CAUSING HARM TO THE PROGRAM.
AND WE WILL BE PAYING BACK
ALONG WITH THE PROGRAM NEEDS IT
OR NO LONGER NEEDED BY THE
GENERAL FUND UNLESS OF COURSE
THE PROGRAM I NEED FASTER.
HELLO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT ON ON
THIS PORTION OR PROPOSAL
INTIMIDATION THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD THING ABOUT COULD
COMMITTEE CENTER DRESS OF THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- WELL I WOULD.
I WOULD BEG TO DIFFER I THINK
RIGHT NOW. THIS DEPARTMENT
NEEDS THE MONEY I THINK RIGHT
NOW WE JUST. THE CAME OFF OF A
CONVERSATION OF VICTIMS OF WAGE
THEFT IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
AND IN GENERAL LOW WAGE
WORKERS. LOSING TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS A WEEK I DON'T
SEE HOW WE COULD AT A TIME LIKE
THIS WHEN LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE
SUPER EXPLOITED UP WHEN THEY
NEED THIS KIND OF UP OF
ASSISTANCE. THAT WE WOULD BE
TAKING THAT MONEY FOR SOMETHING
ELSE I DON'T SEE THE RATIONALE
THERE'S NO REPAYMENT PLAN
PRESENTED THERE'S NO INTEREST
BEING CHARGED I DON'T THINK
NOW'S THE TIME TO BE TAKING OF
FUNDING FROM VULNERABLE
WORKERS- I WAS REMINDED THAT
SOME THE LAST TIME IT THE
GENERAL FUND QUOTE UNQUOTE
BORROWED FUNDS. FROM THE STI
DURING THE RECESSION IT TOOK
TEN YEARS TO REPAY- AND THAT'S
JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE AT A TIME
WHEN- YOU KNOW HARD WORKING
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN. GET
THEIR WAGES ARE STOLEN OR OTHER
ISSUES- THAT THEY HAVE TO
LITIGATE SO I REALLY OF WHAT
ASKED SERIOUSLY TO RECONSIDER
THIS LOAN ALLOW THAT DEPARTMENT
TO KEEP ON WITH THEIR- THEIR
FUNDING- AND THAT'S WHERE I
STAND MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT DONNA
THAT COMMENT AND- IT'S PART OF
THE CHALLENGE WITH WITH LOANS
FROM OUT OF A FUND IS IT THEN
THE FUND IS NOT NOT AVAILABLE-
BUT WHAT WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT- SOMEONE'S MADE AN
ANALYSIS OF IT THE FUND HAS
ENOUGH MONEY TO MEET THE NEEDS
FORWARD THAT YEAR THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING BUT I GET YOUR POINT
AND- APPRECIATE YOU RAISING
THAT ISSUE VERY. VERY MUCH AND
THAT CONCLUDES ADAM- ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY ONE- WE HAD THAT
THREE OF THE THREE OF THE ITEMS
THAT- THAT THE RECOMMENDATION
IS CHANGE ONE OF THEM IS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AND I FRANKLY WANTED
THAT ONE PULLED SO THAT I COULD
JUST MAKE A COMMENT- IN REGARDS
TO A BEING OPEN AND THAT'S
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE-
PAID FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER BILL-
IF WE COULD TAKE THAT WENT UP
RIGHT NOW I. JUST HAVE A VERY
BRIEF COMMENT. IT'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IN MY MIND OF DOING
POLICY WORK IN A- IN A BUDGET.
BUDGET DOWN TRAILER BILL BUT-
IS THERE SOMEONE WHO COULD
SPEAK SPEAK ON THIS ONE FROM
THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI
YES I'M WORKING ON IS AGAIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON A NEW
LOOK SAD AND LONELY THERE NOW.
THERE I HAVE MY PRINCIPLE ON
THE SIDE. SO BUT NEIGHBORHOODS
INQUIRIES ALMOST ONE NOT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR ON
SMALL BUSINESSES. STATION YEAH
EXPANSION. I CAN COME A
COMPONENT OF THE- THE
CALIFORNIA BOUNTY RIGHT ACT IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE'RE DOING UP
OUR EXTENSIONS TO THE FAMILY
EACH PROGRAM. ON THIS WE ALSO
INCLUDE A PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE FULL TWELVE
WEEKS OF JOB PROTECTED YOU TO
ALL WORKERS FOR CARRYING BABY
BONDING FOR AND FOR PREGNANCY
REGARDLESS REGARDLESS EMPLOYER
SIDE SO THAT'S THE REAL YEAH
EXPANSION ON AND- THIS
EXPANSIVE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACT TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FAMILIAL
RELATIONSHIPS CURRENTLY
COVERED. BY THE PAID FAMILY.
LEAVE ANY SOLUTIONS. SO GRANT
FRENCH. NOTHING PARTNERS AND
PARENTS OUT IN LOS IN ALLOWS
PARENTS WHO WORK WITH THE SAME
EMPLOYER TO RECEIVE ALL WEEKS
OF PROTECTED BE REMOVED
LANGUAGE STOP WHAT HAVE ALLOWED
ME TO DENY THE A LOT SALLY
EMPLOYEE I MEAN IT'S A QUESTION
THANK VERY MUCH HELLO. HELLO
THIS. COMMON ON ON THIS
PROPOSED CHANGE TO THE CHOPPER
TECH TO LEAVE TO ALIGN IT WITH
WITH PAID FAMILY LEAVE- I'M
SORRY YOUR POINT ABOUT THIS
POTENTIALLY BEING A QUESTION
FOR THE POLICY COMMITTEE
PROCESS IS A VALID ONE. THERE
ARE LARGE POLICY QUESTIONS AND-
IT COULD BE BEST HEARD IN THAT
VENUE- THOUGH I WOULD ADD THAT
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE EXPANSION
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
LAST YEAR FROM SIX WEEKS TO
EIGHT WEEKS WAS TAKEN AS PART
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS OF THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT STEP
THAT WAS TAKEN LAST YEAR. SHE
THAT THAT VERY MUCH ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT. I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT I SUPPORT FAMILY LIVE I
THINK IT'S- A TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT. OF. AT BENEFIT TO
HAVE AND- IN THE IN THE
EXPANSION TO INCLUDE OTHER
OTHER THAN THE PARENTS AS WELL
IT IT. BEING GRANDPARENTS
EXEDRA AND I THINK THAT'S ALL
REALLY GOOD WHAT WHAT IT FOCUS
ON QUITE FRANKLY IS. THAT THIS
IT COULD EXPANSION INCLUDES
EMPLOYERS OF ANY SIZE AND- I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYER HAS NO DISCRETION TO
DENY OR TO ASK THE EMPLOYEE TO
MODIFY THE LEAVE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE EMPLOYER'S BUSINESS
OPERATIONS- AND IT COMES ON TOP
OF THE TWO WEEKS PROVIDED BY
THE CARES ACT AND THE EXISTING
TWELVE WEEKS OF FMLA. AND SO AN
EMPLOYEE MOM. CAN GET CAN BE
OUT FOR HALF A YEAR AND FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS I RAN A SMALL
LAW PRACTICE. FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS WE ONLY HAD TWO OR THREE
PEOPLE ON AND WHENEVER SOMEONE
WAS OUT WE HAD TO OBSERVE THE
WORK DAY WITH THE WORKLOAD AND
AT THE END OF THE DAY-
EMPLOYERS REALLY WANT TO RETAIN
THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND DO
EVERYTHING TO ACCOMMODATE THEM
BUT YOU GOT TO KEEP THE
POSITION OPEN AND- SO- YOU GOT
TO KEEP THE POSITION OPEN AND
IT'S GOT TO BE THE SAME
POSITION THAT YOU OFFER AND SO
IF THE BUSINESS CHANGES LIKE.
UNDER THE CARE ACT- AB YOU
COULD BE IN VIOLATION OF THE
LAW SO I JUST WORRY I WORRY
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PARTICULARLY AT
THIS. AT THIS PARTICULAR POINT
IN TIME AND- SO I YOU KNOW I
WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE BUT THIS
IS REALLY A TOUGH A TOUGH NEW
ADDITION TO WHAT. WE'RE ASKING
SMALL BUSINESSES TO DO WHEN
WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA LOSE A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF OUR
BUSINESSES SO. I JUST WANT TO.
GO ON THE RECORD SAYING THAT
I'M I'M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT IT
AND I KNOW I'VE HEARD FROM MY
BUSINESS MY SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AS WELL. THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED AS WELL. SO THAT
CONCLUDES THAT ITEM. AND THAT
CONCLUDES ALL THE ITEMS THAT
WERE WERE GOING TO HEAR FOR
TODAY- OUR NEXT TASK YES JUST A
QUESTION. IS NOT ON THE AGENDA
BUT I WAS GOING TO RAISE IT
UNDER THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
IN THE EITC. A ISSUE I YES DO
YOU HAVE AN ITEM AND ITEM
NUMBER. WELL IT WAS UNDER-
SEVEN SEVEN THREE OF THE UNDER
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. WHEN
WE TOOK IT UP A LITTLE WHILE
AGO. I THINK YOU MENTIONED WE
WOULD DO IT AT THE END OF. FOR
THE. WITHIN A SPECIFIC ITEM BUT
IT'S UNDER THAT DEPARTMENT THAT
I WANTED TO RAISE AN ISSUE WITH
THE COMMUNISTS HEY YES SO IT'S
FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND- I JUST. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THE BUDGET YOU KNOW DOES A GOOD
THING AS A AND TWENTY NINETEEN
DO GOOD THING OF EXPANDING THE-
YEAH I. T. C. FOR- FAMILIES AND
REACHING- A MILLION MORE.
HOUSEHOLDS AND RAISING THEN YOU
KNOW THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS
RECEIVING THE CREDIT SO OUR OUR
TO VERY GOOD THING THOUSAND
DOLLARS CREDIT ALL MY PROBLEM
AND I WANTED TO RAISE IT HERE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET. IS
EXPANDING THE EITC TIGHTENED
TAX FILERS. DATE ARM THOSE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN ARE
CONTRIBUTING THEIR FILING THEIR
TAXES THERE- PERFORMING ALL ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT WORK- AND WE
ARE. REALLY IGNORING THAT AS A
PART OF THIS ECONOMY WHEN IT
COMES TO HAVING THE SAME ACCESS
TO THE SAME PROGRAMS AS
EVERYBODY ELSE- THIS IS A AN
ISSUE THAT WAS BROUGHT UP AS A
MULTI CAUCUS PRIORITY THE
LATINO ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER. LGBT Q. BLACK CAUCUS
AND JEWISH CAUCUS ALL- PUT THIS
AS A PRIORITY ISSUE WHICH IS A
HARD THING TO DO- AND I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO EXTEND OUR
ACCESS TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
TAXPAYING WORKERS IN THE STATE.
SIXTY THOUSAND INCOME ELIGIBLE
I TEN HOLDERS AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THIS CHANGE IN POLICY-
THERE'S BEEN NO RATIONAL BASIS
TO CONTINUE TO EXCLUDE TAX
PAYING RESIDENTS FROM THIS
PROGRAM WHO CAN PROVIDE AND I
TEN NUMBER SHOWING THAT THEY
PAY TAXES. AND IN LIEU OF A
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER SO I
WANT TO RAISE IT TO OF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THEY'RE NOT
THE ONES WHO MAKE THE DECISION
BUT THIS IS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME ESPECIALLY WELL
WHEN OF THOSE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
PROBABLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS AND I SAFETY NET SO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
INDULGING ME ABSOLUTELY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS HERE TODAY. SO
NOW IS THE TIME WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO. MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD. AGAIN WE WILL
TAKE COMMENT REGARDING ANY THE
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
INCLUDING THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
COMMENTS IT WILL BE HELPFUL IF
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THE ISSUE FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT YOU ARE
PROVIDING COMMENT ON. DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND-NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS.
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH PERSON PROVIDING COMMENT
WENT WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF ONE MINUTE. NOW LET'S
BEGIN- ME SEE HERE. CHECKING TO
MAKE SURE I DON'T. CONTEMPT AND
THEM SIR. WE NEED TO GIVE THE
MODERATOR INSTRUCTIONS TO THE
NEW COLORS KNOW HOW TO GET ON
THE LINE. AND PLEASE JOIN IN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU'D LIKE
TO UNDER THE QUEUE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL
THEN PROVIDE YOU A NUMBER AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT
NUMBER AGAIN TO JOIN THE QUEUE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA START WITH TIME
WITH YOU- MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA START WITH PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM. AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO THE PEOPLE ON THE LINE. SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE WITNESS
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE ITEM THAT
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE COMMON AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A- I ISSUE
TO- THREE AND PART C. OF YOUR
AGENDA PAGE FORTY SIX THE AND A
WELL SUSPENSION. AND CREDIT
LIMITATION THIS IS CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF. COMP TIA
THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. OUR
CONCERNS ARE TWO FOLD FIRST YES
THE PRESIDENT'S BEEN SET- AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTED
THAT TWICE BEFORE THE NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED HOWEVER AND- IN
BOTH OF THOSE PRIOR INSTANCES
NUMBER ONE WE DID FOR TWO
YEARS. THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR
THREE WE'D LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER
TO INSTEAD. SECONDLY WHEN THE
NO WELLS CAME BACK AFTER THE
SUSPENSION. AFTER THE FIRST
TIME WE INCREASE THE AMOUNT
FROM 60% TO A HUNDRED. AND THEN
AFTER THE SECOND TIME WE
ALLOWED YOU'RE VERY BACKING
CONFORMITY TO FEDERAL LAW. LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET DEAL ELIMINATED
THAT TO YOUR KERRY BACK WE'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME. BENEFICIAL
TREATMENT OF THE AND A WELL
DEDUCTION WHEN IT WOULD COME
BACK HOPEFULLY AFTER TWO YEARS
NOT THREE. AND THEN SIMILARLY
ON THE CREDIT LIMITATION OUR
CONCERN ALSO IS IT'S THREE
YEARS THAT COULD. PRIMARILY IN
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT THE R.
ANDY KERR CREDIT IS AVAILABLE
PRIMARILY TO HIGH TECH AND
BIOTECH COMPANIES. AND MOST OF
THE YOU THE CREDIT IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO EMPLOYEE WAGES.
AND SO WE THINK IT REALLY
IMPACTS COMPANIES THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ADVERSELY IMPACTED
AND WHILE. THE DEPARTMENT DOES
ARGUE THAT IT'S A TIME VALUE OF
MONEY ISSUE THAT IS THOSE TWO
THINGS. TOGETHER OR TWO BILLION
DOLLARS EACH WHICH MEANS
BUSINESSES WILL BE PAYING AND
IT. FOR BILLION DOLLARS THOSE
TWO SCHOOL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
TENS OF OUR DINNER ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PETROLEUM
COMMUNITY SOURCES ASIAN AS PART
C. ITEM TO THE BAY TAX. WE ARE
YOUR MINORITY OWNED MOM POP
SHOPS. AND WE OPPOSE ANY TAX
FOR VAPE ABOVE THAT OF
COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTES. WE FEEL
IT IS WITHOUT PARITY IT WILL
DROP SALES TO UNDERGROUND AND
THE STRIVE NOT ONLY OUR SALES
THE SALES OF CALIFORNIA LOTTERY
TICKETS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT
WISH TO SPEAK SEEING NONE-
SERGEANTS COULD YOU LET CAN YOU
LET ME KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ST THERE ARE NONE. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAIT WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
AGAIN WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ITEMS.
THEY COULD PLEASE IDENTIFY THE
ITEM THEY ARE COMMENTING ON SO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES IN THE ITEM
THERE COMMENTING ON AND I'LL
ASK YOU TO PLEASE- LIMIT
YOURSELF TO ONE MINUTE. I YES-
THEY WANT WE'RE MOVING OFF A
LISTENER THAT ARE PART OF
UNFUNDED OPERATING LOSSES THIS
POINT ARE WE WERE GOING ON WELL
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING ANY ITEM
WELL LET ME JUST. SINCE THIS IS
MORE FORTUITOUS TIMING I'M
GONNA WE- ASK THAT WE- BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THE NET OPERATING
LOSS IT MAY LOOK LIKE BIG MONEY.
DARKHAN IS IN A VERY FRAGILE
STATE RIGHT NOW. AND I AM
PLEASED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S.
WORKING WITH US TO OPEN UP A
LITTLE BIT THAT'S VERY
NECESSARY. BUT THESE BUSINESSES
ARE IN VERY PRECARIOUS
POSITIONS THAT ANY SIGNAL
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE THEIR
LIVES MORE MISERABLE I THINK
IT'S VERY WRONG RIGHT NOW. AND
WOULD BE VERY HARMFUL TO OUR
RECOVERY SO THAT JUST AN
OBSERVATION FOR THE RECORD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. SO WE'RE READY TO TAKE-
IT WITNESSES VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ITEMS PLEASE IDENTIFY THE I TO
ME YOU'RE YOU'RE COMMENTING ON
AND GIVE US YOUR NAME.
ABSOLUTELY AND JUST SO YOU'RE
AWARE WE HAVE NINETY EIGHT IN
THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW- FIRST TO
GO TO NUMBER TWENTY SIX. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION THE ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S- BUT
YOU'RE ALSO TOOK AND DROPPED IT
THAT IT TO ALL WORKERS UNDER
SEPARATE REGARDLESS OF
EMPLOYERS FIVE HOURS WORK OR A
TEN YEAR DEGREE WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION PROGRESS THE
COALS- AND RELATED ISSUES
NUMBER FIVE IN BETWEEN WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO. IMPORT EIGHTY FIVE
TO THE ALLOCATION OF SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION THE I. R.
THIRTEEN POINT FOUR BILLION TWO
EDT AND AGAIN SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION COMPATIBLES
RELEASED TO ISSUE SEVEN- BUT
SUPPORT DID A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO THE ISSUE-
AMBER ISSUE TWENTY ONE WE
SUPPORT HE- JANUARY PROPOSAL TO
IN JANUARY PROPOSAL TO- TRAINS
THE- CLAIM. THE TRACTOR FUNDS
FROM BE ON WAGES TO THE
RESTITUTION FINE A PROPOSED
THAT THE ORIGINAL HOUSE WILL BE
A COME I'M PRETTY SURE THIRTY
ONE WE ACTUALLY HOLD THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL YALLA KEEP.
HUNDRED THAT. THE LABOR AGENCY
FROM LABOR. LABOR AND WORKFORCE
TO PLANS OF THE JOINT FUND. OUR
COLLECT FROM NOT AND ARE.
REQUIRED BE USED FOR A LABOR
IMPORTS. TO ENFORCE WORK
PROTECT. EVER OUR HOUSTON AND
THIS CRUCIAL THAT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE BY REMAIN
LABOR EIGHT THE AND CONTINUE TO
BE YOU FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE AND LET WE'VE THE- BE.
INCOME WILL PLAY IN THE POLLS
THAT WAS IN BY CALL IN SUPPORT
ABOUT THIRTY HUNDRED
LEGISLATORS I AND ALSO SUPPORT.
PLANS EXPAND COUNTY I. T. C.
TIED TO ORDERS. WE SUBMITTED
HIS NO COMMENTS WRITTEN AND
THOSE ARE THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH SO I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY IT AND WE HAVE NINETY
EIGHT PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE WE CAN GET
THROUGH EVERYONE AND WE'VE GOT.
A LIMóN I MEAN THIS IS
BUILDING IN THIS. SPACE SO IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ONE MINUTE THE
NEXT. SPEAKER PLEASE. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER TWENTY. TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO. IT EVENING
THIS IS DOOR WAS DIRECTOR OF
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA POLICE IN FIGHTING
FOR VOTING RIGHTS AND WORKING
TO EDUCATE EMPOWER VOTERS FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS THIS IS ACTUALLY
OUR CENTENNIAL YEAR. WE STRIVE
TO EXPAND REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BALLOT BOX AS YOU ALL KNOW IF
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER. EVEN
THOUGH IT IS GOING TO CHANGE
THE STOCK ALL REGISTERED VOTERS
ARE GOING TO GET A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT BUT IF THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS HAVE NOTED
IT'S REALLY VITALLY IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN ROBUST IN PERSON
OPTIONS. FOR MANY VOTERS WHO
NEED SENSIBILITY AND ASSISTANCE
CENTERS IT SHOWS HERE THAT
WOULD IN PERSON VITAL. WILL
MAKE A WOMAN VOTERS IS GOING TO
BE THERE ON THE FRONT LINES
ALONG WITH MANY OF OUR
COALITION PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
CLEAN LANGUAGE MESSAGING TO
OFFER TOOLS THE VOTERS NEED TO
VOTE OF CONFIDENCE ULTIMATELY.
ABLE CALIFORNIANS TO VOTE FOR
THE CANDIDATE SHOULD THEY LEAVE
ARE GONNA HELP US CLIMB OUT
FROM UNDER THE. STAND BUT TO DO
THE ENORMOUS EDUCATION CAN IT'S
GONNA BE ENOUGH TO. WE TO GET
FUNDING SO. WE ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAND WITH US COUNTY.
LAW AND WITH THE MONEY CAN YOU.
OR LARGE. YOUR HELP WHEN SHE
THAT THE SUPPORT THAT YOU'RE
NOT IS. NOT VERY. THANK YOU
VERY FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. BACK
PLEASE. NEXT NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU THE CLOCK RUNNING.
HI MY NAME IS YVONNE WORKS AND
I KNOW MY CLOCK IS RUNNING BUT
THE CLOCK IS ALSO RUNNING OUT
ON A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE OUT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STREETS
TODAY OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND AND
MORE TO CAROL AND THIS IS TO-
ASK 420% SET ASIDE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND ITS TIES TO
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL WE CAN
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WHEN WE
PRIORITIZE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. THE
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOHN
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA FIELD INCONVENIENT
COLLIDE BEGIN TO THE VAPING TAX
PROPOSAL IN PART B. BY THE FDA
REPRESENT OVER HALF THE TWELVE
THOUSAND YOU GOT THE TO THE
CONVENIENCE STORE IN THE STATE.
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENTLY
PROPOSED- NEW VAPING TACKED ON-
THE TWO PRODUCTS ARE MEMBERS OF
FATE LET'S GET CHALLENGES
DURING THE PANDEMIC NOT ONLY IN
THE CENTRAL BUSINESS PROVIDING
CRITICAL FOOD AND FUEL TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. BUT ALSO AT THE
MALL FAMILY IN MINORITY ON
BUSINESSES- BEING REQUIRED TO.
COMPLY WITH NECESSARY YET OWNER
AT NEW PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENTS WE'RE CONCERNED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
YOU FURTHER TACK THEIR
CUSTOMERS IN BUSINESSES DURING
DIFFICULT TIMES. FOR THE MORE
WE BELIEVE IT IS BAD PUBLIC
POLICY TO TACK TACK BEEPER
PRODUCT HIGHER THAN COMBAT WILL
FIGURE IT DRIVING ADULT. BUT
HEALTHY PRODUCT FOR THOSE
REASONS. WE JUST GOT THE YOU'LL
RECONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON ALTERNATIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOUR PLEASE. A NEXT TO A GOOD
AND ONE OH FIVE ONE OF YOUR-
HERE THIS IS A EVERITT CREDIT
OF GOLDEN STATE OPERA. A
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO ENDING
POVERTY AND I'M REFERENCE BEING
ITEM THIRTY PART SEE I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF ITUNES HOLDERS IN
THE CALLIE I TT AND THE COOPER
INCLUDING TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STATE BUDGET. FORTY
ITC EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
EFFORT AND PRE TAX PREPARATION.
TODAY I HEARD YOUR DEDICATION
TO BUY MEANING TIME FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BY MAINTAINING THE
I TT R. REACH FINDING THAT THEY
WILL BE ENSURING THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS CAN ACCESS THAT
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS BY
KNOWING ABOUT AND CLEANING
THEIR CREDIT. EVERY YEAR
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT CLAIM ONE
POINT FIVE TO TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL EITC
DOLLARS. BUT IN THE FOUR YEARS
THAT THERE HAS BEEN FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD REDUCE THAT BY
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION.
AND THAT MONEY GETS SPENT IN
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY AND GENERATE
MILLION BEEN TAX SALES TAX
REVENUE. FUNDING IS AN
INVESTMENT ARE WORKING FAMILIES
AND THE RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT IT'S SIGNIFICANT NOT
ONLY FOR INDIVIDUALS ECONOMIC
SECURITY. FOR A LOCAL ECONOMIC
STIMULUS. AND A LOT MORE I WON
ENCOURAGE INCLUSION OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EDUCATION
IN OUR REGION THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU WERE DOING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. A NEXT YEAR THE
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS BETTY HUNG WITH THE UCLA
LABOR CENTER. ISSUE SEVEN OF
HEARTS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SHEET INITIATIVE CAN SURE THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
INCLUDED IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY EACH EVEN IF
IT IS A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION OF THE NAY REVISED.
THAT WILL PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WITH MICRO GRANTS
AND CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY EFFECTIVE
TRAINING START OR RESTART
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE HIGH ROAD
BUSINESSES AND WORKER
COOPERATIVE SH WOULD HELP TO
CREATE QUALITY JOBS AND PROMOTE
DEMOCRACY IN THE WORKPLACE FROM
KERN DURING THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. WITH DOCTORS
KEEP YOUR HOME IN BOTH. EVEN
THE SUGAR IS SPECIALLY CRITICAL
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT EVEN
NATIONALLY WE ALSO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO INCLUDE A COMPILERS.
AND HOW. HE YOUR SUPPORT PERSON
MEMBER. PROPOSED FOR WEEKLY IN
REPLACEMENT FUNDS FOR A DOCU
WORKER. WHO ARE ACTUALLY EXTRA
FROM. INSURANCE ACCORDING
WEARING FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE IT'S TIME TO
MOVE ON TO THE NORTH SPEAKER
PLEASE. I'M SORRY HE DIDN'T TO
CUT YOU OFF BUT WE DO NEED TO
GET THROUGH- I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET AS MANY PEOPLE
SPEAKING AS POSSIBLE. SIX OTHER
PLACES WE GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TELL TRITON REPRESENTING NEXT
GEN AND CONSUMER TURNING THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
TWO HUNDRED THE DDO LOCAL. WE
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
FORESIGHT YOU CREATING INCREASE
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
OF THE TV UP. THE ORGANIZATION
IS MODELED AFTER THE CFPB A
PROGRAM THAT WORKED BEFORE IT
WAS STARTED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING
UNEMPLOYMENT AND MANY ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY AND BENEFITS.
THIS CREEK DESPERATION AND PUT%
PEOPLE AT RISK OF SHARP DEBT
COLLECTORS AND DANGEROUS WILD.
THE BEAUTY OF THE PUZZLE IS
THAT WITHOUT TAPPING GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS YOU CAN THROW A
LIFE POINTS YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
IT WILL PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ALREADY BEING
HAMMERED BY FALL OUT FROM THE
PANDEMIC. WE CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
NEXT YEAR CURLY WE URGE
ADOPTION OF THE TV OFF A LITTLE
NOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT BAKER. THE NEXT TO
GO TO NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME IN HERE YOU FIND THE RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU ADRIN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE THAT
IS ON FIFTEEN NOTHING NETWORK
OF WOMEN FARMWORKERS LEADERS
AND WE OFFER OUR IN SUPPORT. OF
THE WE- WELL I'M- NOT YEAH. I'M
NOT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT
RIGHT. ALRIGHT WE'LL GET. RIGHT
RIGHT. RIGHT WELL YOU. BUT FROM
I STRUGGLING THANK. RIGHT RIGHT
BUT NOT THERE WEREN'T VERY ALL
THAT BAD IN FACT BUT IN A I.
DON'T. OKAY OR YOU. THANK YOU
IS THE MONEY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I REALLY APPRECIATE HEARING
THOSE WERE. THE NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. NEXT THE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN
LOWER CALIFORNIA CORRECT THE
PLAN AND COMPANY BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ON ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN I MEAN I'M ABOUT PROJECT
LOT OF ALL IT WILL NOT COMMENT
ON. AND A COMPANY HOMELESS
CHILDREN THANK YOU CAN YOU KNOW
EVEN ON THE STREET AND
DEMOCRATS AND A SHARP BELIEVED
TO HAVE A NUMBER OF. YEARS
EXPECTING HOME OF THAT ARE.
RIGHT COMMENTS THE COUNTRY
SUGGESTION ON HOW TO
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE IT LATER
SCHECTER DRY. BUT HOW MUCH ONE
STREET TODAY WHICH OF THE- THAT
AFFECTS ONE BUT CON HAVING
FIFTY THOUSAND MUCH AND COULD
NOT PERMANENT HOME. BOBBI UNDER.
THAT AND I'M A CO. I'M GOING
HAVE BIGGER IS THAT THE- AND
EDUCATE PRODUCT BAD. LIKE THE
LAST RECESSION WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY HOW ON YOUNG
PEOPLE. HAVE NINETY EIGHT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH TWO TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE AVERAGE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE. EARLIER TRANSLATION IN MY
DAY THAT ACTUALLY FOR YOU THE
COLOR. FOR SUFFERING AND WE
THEIR JOB THE URGENT AT. THE
WHITE THE REASON FOR YOU BY
MARKING OUT WE PERCENT OF.
EXPANDING MUCH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY AND YOU REYES
REALLY GOOD WHICH THAT YOU CAN
SUBMIT YOUR TEST. IN WRITING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO THE- UP BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR AND THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE IN TOTAL AND I
WILL MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
GETS COPY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BAKER IT WAS EXACTLY ONE
MINUTE. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE A
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND I'M
SPEAKING ON ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
CARS YES WELL WE SUPPORT A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR COALITION
PROPOSAL ON HOMELESSNESS THAT
BUILT ON THE GOVERNOR'S NAME
REVISED. BY USING FEDERAL
STIMULUS AN EXISTING STATE
FUNDING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ALSO BUILD ON PROGRESS OUR
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE MADE TO ENSURE SAFETY OF
OUR HOMELESS POPULATIONS. AND
ASSISTING ALL FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PROJECT ROOM KEY RESIDENTS
AVOID RETURNED TO THE STREET.
WE PROPOSED SELLING GAPS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
OFFER RENTAL SYSTEMS IN THE
PRIVATE MARKET TO LEARN FROM
PAYMENTS. TO FUND CAPITAL TO
CONVERT ANY POTENTIAL FIGHT TO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND TO PAY
FOR OPERATING AND SERVICES AND
CARE COORDINATION NEEDS OF
TENANTS. IT ALSO CALLS FOR A
MATCH FROM LOCAL ALLOCATION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS TO COORDINATE
WORK HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. FINALLY WE APPRECIATE
AND SUPPORT THE PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION THE STATE LOW INCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. NEXT YEAR TO NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTER WE GOT HIT WITH A
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER WE THOUGHT WHAT'S THE
COLLISION OF A WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS CLUB AND
ACTED MICHAEL BUT NINETEEN IN
THE JOHN BUDGET. LAST WEEK A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE SHARED HOW
SHE- HELPED. HER GET HER TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN. MUCH OF PROP.
SHE'S BEEN FRAMED QUITE A FOR
HER BAY ABOUT BIG. SCHERING
WITH MADE UP THE MORNING RAP.
THAT'S ENERGY THERE THE MORE
SHE CAN PRESS PLUMMETED GLOBE
THREE AND A HALF SURVIVE ON.
FOR YOUR UNIQUE. HIGHER DOCKING
THAT. FROM UP FOR ALL. WE ALSO
A COLD. WHEN THE MAY REVISED
NUMBER COLLECTED UNDER THE
PRIVATE GENERAL DOC UP TO ABOUT
GOING TO THE GENERAL. WELL
THOUGH FUNDS REMAIN IN THE
BUDGET FOR. IN QUITE OR DO YOU
I'LL BE BUT B. EIGHT OR NOT THE
REALITY. OF THEIR GAP IN ABOUT.
WE ALSO SUPPORT INCLUDE OF THE
I BY IN THE EARNED INCOME TAX.
AND INCLUSION OF. THE STATE
BUDGET. THANK YOU THEY YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT BAKER PLEASE. BUT
NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBERS TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CLICK HERE WE
CAN HEAR YOU. START START TO
GET TO MY MANY SECTORS SO DO I
I'M WITH THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- MYSELF FOR
THE DOCTOR YOU SHOULD BEEN AND
ALSO MAKES THAT IS FOUND TO
HIGHLIGHT CENTER TWO BOXES
POINT HOW MUCH HE PUBLIC PUBLIC
STANDING AND FOR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
IN THESE TIMES SO I WON THEIR-
SUPPORT THE CD. MISSION WHICH
WILL HELP WITH THE RECOVERY.
DOCUMENTED IN THE MIDDLE. YOU
MAY WANT TO DEVELOP DON'T
BUSINESS. IS THAT WHAT COOPS
ALSO BE ONE OF THE HIGHER THE
IMPORTANCE OF A COMIC. PROGRAM
THAT I ASK. HAS PROPOSED AND
YOU WILL HELP ME A OF OUR
COMMUNITIES LITERACY FIND
TRYING TO JUST WHETHER TO GO TO
WORK IN WE'RE ASKING. OR FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PROVIDE US WITH A
PEACEFUL. FURTHER THE FINAL. I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WITH THIS PLEASE. NEXT WE WILL
GO TO NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AIR TRAVELER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
RICHARD CORDRAY THE FIRST
DIRECTOR THE FEDERAL CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU
SPEAKING ON PART SEE ISSUE TWO
HUNDRED THE DB O.
REORGANIZATION. RESPECTFULLY
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY FROM
WORKING FOR THE LAST ECONOMIC
CRISIS I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
DPO TO STRENGTHEN THE STATE
FINANCIAL OVERSIGHT. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WITHOUT USING GENERAL FUND THE
PROTECTION THEY DESPERATELY
NEED TO PREVENT PREDATORS AND
SWINDLING THEM WHEN THEY CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT. TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE THE CALIFORNIA FAILED
TO ACT IMMEDIATELY WE KNOW MORE
PEOPLE WILL LOSE THEIR HOMES
AND LIFE SAVINGS THEIR CREDIT
AND ACCESS TO CAPITAL WILL BE
DESTROYED MANY WILL NEVER EVER
RECOVER. AND DAMAGE HE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO RESORT TO SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS WILL HAVE NO OTHER
CHOICE PUTTING FURTHER PRESSURE
ON CALIFORNIA'S BUDGETARY
RESOURCES. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RIGHT NOW MANY SOPHISTICATED
BUSINESSES ARE LOOKING TO GET
RICH BY MAKING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS POOR PLEASE DON'T
LET WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE.
HAPPEN AGAIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT NEXT THE
WITNESS. NEXT SO WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT HI MY NAME IS RUBY
A CASTER AND I'M FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO DO TO COVER
NINETEEN I'M NO LONGER ABLE TO
WORK AT THE TOP PROGRAM
COORDINATOR IN THE OFFICE OR
REMOTELY. THEREFORE I'VE BEEN
DATING ECONOMIC DIFFICULTY AS
THE JOB WITH HELPING ME SAVE UP
FOR MY MASTERS PROGRAM THIS
FALL. UNFORTUNATELY THE KIND
THAT MAKE AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
MIGHT BE THE REASON I'M NOT
ABLE TO CONTINUE MY EDUCATION
AS INTENDED. HOWEVER I WAS
APPROVED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT AND I
GIVE ME HIGH HOPE. IN THAT I
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE SAVING
UP FOR GRAD SCHOOL. FOR
GRADUATE SCHOOL. WITH THAT
BEING SAID IF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM HAS HELPED ME IN A
POSITIVE WAY. THEN IT'S EXTREME
IMPORTANT AND- OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN MY POSITION WHO
ARE NOT RECEIVING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE DUE TO THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
HEARTBREAKING STRUGGLE THAT ARE
GREATER THAN MINE. I'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO RECEIVE
GOVERNMENTAL SUPPORT AND THEY
SHOULD TO. JUST LIKE YOU AT
THAT EVENT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS PAY TAXES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY. HE
THEN THE VISUAL HAVE BILLS TO
PAY AND FAMILIES TO FEED.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS I
IMMENSELY IN NEED OF AID JUST
AS US CITIZENS ARE. HIRED YOU
CENTER CABALLERO TO SUPPORT THE
WAGE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CENTER
HERNANDEZ A MEMBER OF. THE
BLACK WHEN I AM THE MYSTIC
MURKY- BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY FORM OF BASIC INCOME SHORT
ON THE COMMENT THE CALIFORNIA.
HIS MOTHER SAID. EXCLUDES ONE
INTENTIONAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
FROM MY BASIC SUPPORT NETWORK
MASON ON THE IMMIGRANT CHECK
THE STATUS. IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WILL DURING A CRISIS OF
THIS MAGNITUDE. THAT IS WHY WE
ARE DEMANDING IN THE JUNE
BUDGET TO INCLUDE A WIKI
REPLACEMENT INCOME PROGRAM. ONE
ANGLER. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE GO TO NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR GO AHEAD. HI FOR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. DO YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
CAN YOU MY NAME IS LIVES EASIER
GARCIA. I'M MEMBER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION MORE CAREFULLY THE
FACT BEAVER I NINE DOMESTIC
WORKERS DIVIDE DECLINING ANY
BASIC INCOME FOR ONE DOCUMENT
IMMIGRANT IN CALIFORNIA LIKE TO
MEET. THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE IF
THE ORDER ONE OF THE TEN
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA WELL WHAT
WE HAVE A CHANGE OR BASIC
SUPPORT. WE SHOULD NOT HAVE.
IMMIGRATION IS. THIS IS NOT A
WOKE BILLION DIFFERENT THEY
MADE FOURTEENTH OF MARK. WE
DEMANDED. TO ADAM WEEKLY FOR
ALL THESE WORKERS WE SHOULD
LOSE THEIR JOB. OR CALL THE
NINETEEN BETTER PROTECT LOW
NUMBER COMMUNITIES REGARDLESS-
IMMIGRATION IS TAXES I'M
PROVIDED. RELIEF FOR BOTH. FOR
READILY THIRTY BECAUSE THE OUR
DAILY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO
TO NUMBER FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY HI MY NAME IS AND MY
BODY FAT IN INDIA I AM A MEMBER
OF MILE MATH AND HELLO MY
COUNTY. I WORD OF CAN'T DEEPER.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ANY
FRIEND. WITH FOUND THEY AFFECT
AFFECTED WITH THE COMPLETE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE COULD MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER MODERATOR. YES
SOME OF THE NUMBER SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FORTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. WE
MAY GET THEM BACK LATER WE'LL
JUST KEEP MOVING ON I. I'M SO
SORRY AFTERNOON AT MY NAME IS
GETTING IT ALL AND I AM WITH
THE PRODUCT LEGAL SERVICES- I
USE TRONG WE SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FIND FRIEND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN- THAT FOR THAT TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE JUNE BY JACK-
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE PROPOSAL IN
THE MAIL REVISED ALLOWING THE
FUNDS COLLECTED. I NEED ARE AT
THAT PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACT IN TWO AND FOUR TO THE
GENERAL FUND. ACTUALLY REQUIRE
THOSE PLANS REMAIN IN THE
BUDGET TO SERVE AT THE
ENFORCEMENT PRIORITIES THE L.
W. D. EIGHT AND NOT BE
REALLOCATED TO SELL EITHER GAPS
IN THE BUDGET AS PROPOSED IN
THE REVISED. IT IMPERATIVE THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED BY THANK YOU
TO THE COURT WORKERS RIGHT
COMPUTERS ARE THE SERVICE
PREVENT. PARTICULARLY UNDER
THAT AND THAT MAKE THE
DISPLACED WORKER AND ANYTHING
FOR THE REST OF AND EIGHT AND
EXPLICATED WORKING CONDITIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING
NEXT PLEASE. MEXICO NUMBER
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ALEX GARCIA I'M WITH
THE CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE
UNITED GROWTH WITHIN NORMAL
ECONOMY OR BECAUSE BUT
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF A WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT
BUMPER AND I COMMEND WORKERS
WEAPON IMPACTED MICHAEL THE
NINETEEN IN THE GYM BUDGET
WE'VE SEEN THE DESPERATION AND
FRUSTRATION OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TRYING TO ACCESS THE
DRIVE FUND. AND WE KNOW ONLY A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE FAMILIES
WILL GET THROUGH BEFORE THE
MONEY RUNS OUT. AND EVEN THE
PEOPLE THAT DO GET IT. THE
RELEASE OF WILL PROVIDE WILL BE
VERY MINIMAL. RIGHT BUT THAT
DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY FORM OF
INCOME SUPPORT FOR NOT MANY
CALIFORNIANS AND WE SEE THIS AS
AN ACCEPTABLE WE URGE YOU. TO
INCLUDE OUR PARENTS. OR AUNTS
OR UNCLES AND GRANDPARENTS IN
THE STATE BUDGET THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. MEXICO THE NUMBER ONE
OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS CAROL SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
AT PUBLIC COUNCIL THE NATION'S
LARGEST PREPARING A LITTLE
FURTHER I'M CALLING SUPPORTIVE
ISSUE TWO HUNDRED TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT. BASED IN
LOS ANGELES WE SERVE LOW INCOME
CLIENTS ACROSS A RANGE OF AREAS
INCLUDING HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION AND CONSUMER RIGHTS
SH WITH REGARD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION IF WE
HAVE HOPE THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT
DURING THE LAST FINANCIAL
CRISIS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS MIGHT KNOW OF LOS
I HATE TO FORECLOSURE. GIVEN
THE SHOP THE CONTRACT WHICH
RELATED MORTGAGE FINANCING
ISSUES WE ALREADY SAME CRITICAL
WE ESTABLISH. A RIGHT YEAH YEAH
I NOW. IN ADDITION A TO COME ON
THE- EIGHT RELATED THE NATIONAL
BECAUSE- TWELVE OKAY LEGAL
SERVICES A GREAT CHEF ABOUT
COURT ORDERED BY ITEM. I WENT
TO MONITOR YOU CAN SEE RIGHT
JAMES. BUDGET BICYCLE MULTI.
MORE SOURCES THAT HOME COULD
SAID TO THE COUNCIL. TO KEEP
OUR CLIENTS IN THE HARD. THANK.
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SIX
WITH PLEASE. AND SO YOU KNOW WE
ARE DOWN TO EIGHTY IN Q. A NAME
NUMBER EIGHTY NINE- YOU MADE ME
FEEL SO GOOD. MAKE SPEAKER
PLEASE. NUMBER EIGHTY NINE AND-
HI MY NAME IS ALAN AND I'M ABLE
TO AND I'M- HERE WITH CLIENTS
AND BECAUSE BLANKS NINE DOUBLE
CONNELLY- AND I JUST WANTED TO
SAY- THIS WEEK WE SAW THE
STAGGERING NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITY DURING THE GROUND
THAT MAKE THAT ISN'T BEING MET
AT THE DISASTER RELIEF FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND OPEN AND WE ASK
YOU SAW WEBSITE AND PHONE LINES
ACROSS THE STATE CLASH AND
FAMILIES WHO HAVE DOLLARS AT
WORK OR IN SEEKING OUT FOR
WEEKS ON END RUSHED A CHANCE AT
THE FIRST TOP BILL WITH. A
BREAK OF THE VIRUS BEFORE RAN
OUT MEETING I'M PRESIDENT
EMPLOYMENT CRISIS WITH A FELLOW
BY KIND DOLLAR GRANT IS LIKE
PUTTING A BAND AID ON OPEN
CHEST WOUND OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY THERE'S SO MUCH
BETTER AND THAT'S WHY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
POLLUTION OF A WEEKLY PARTIAL
INCOME REPLACEMENT PLAN FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY CALLED THE
NINETEENTH AND ADJOURNMENTS
THANK. YOUNG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT
YEAR THE NUMBER FIFTH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BEACH
AND ARE THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES- SPEAKING ON
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN FROM PART B.
OF THE AGENDA WE ARE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INCLUSION OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
OF CARE DOC FUNDING PLEASE
STATE ALLOCATION TO TACKLE THE
INTERSECTION OF HOMELESSNESS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. HOWEVER WE WANT TO ECHO
THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS FROM
EARLIER IN THE HEARING THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE METHOD
OF DISTRIBUTION. FRANKLY WE
DON'T THINK IT EQUITABLE THAT
FOR THE VASTMAJORITY OF OUR
SMALL AND MID SIZEDCITY THAT
THEY SHOT THE GO THROUGH THEIR
COUNTIES. WOULD MUCH RATHER
PREFER A DIRECT STATE
ALLOCATION OF THOSE RESOURCES.
HOWEVER IF YOU DO DECIDE THAT
SOME TYPE OF COUNTY
DISTRIBUTION MODEL IF NECESSARY
WE WOULD REALLY OUT THAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE ACT WOULD BE
INVOLVED IN THAT FORMULA. AND
NOT ALLOW THE COUNTIES TO THE
CHARGE ANY ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
TO REDUCE WHAT IS A CRUCIAL
ALLOCATION. FOR OUR STATE CITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. EXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT
YEAR THE NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MEMBERS WHO THEN MARTIN DELLA
CONSUMER REPORTS- KEEPING A
BRIEF- TO BUILD UPON THE
COMMENTS OF MY ALLIES REGARDING
ISSUE TWO HUNDRED PART HE-
VERY- WE'RE VERY PLEASED- YOU
KNOW DID TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
ABOUT THAT I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION IS
CRUCIAL TO PASS NOW I WANT TO.
AMPLIFY WITH MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID ABOUT THE NEED TO BE
PROACTIVE PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
HURTING- WITHIN THE FIRST WAVE
OF PEOPLE FALLING UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS I ALSO HEAR EVERY DAY
FROM PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY'RE A
MONTH OR TWO AWAY. FROM FALLING
INTO FINANCIAL RUIN AS A RESULT
OF THE CRISIS- HEARING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT ACCESS WILL
BE FROM WONDER SERVICERS BY
DEALING WITH DEBT COLLECTORS
DON'T BELIEVE PROVIDERS AND
OTHER QUESTIONABLE OFFERS OF
FINANCIAL HELP- SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS ISN'T IMPAIR TO BE
DOING NOW- UNDERSTAND
OPPRESSION WHAT IS THAT ARE
UNDER A GIVEN THE- CONTENT
CRIME ONE BUT WE REALLY URGE.
YOU DON'T TAKE A LOOK AT THE
VERY THIRTY TO SPECIFICALLY- IS
WOULD NEED FOR BOARD BETTER
SUPERVISION OVER THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES INDUSTRY PARTICULARLY-
GIVEN THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
GENERAL FUND. THE PROPOSAL SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND. AGAIN WE'RE
JUST ON THE PORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TO. PERFECT
TIME. NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. NEXT
IS NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN THE
U. AT. HELLO TERRY MEMBERS-
COMMENTED ON PARK FEET ISSUE
TWO HUNDRED THIS IS KATELYN
AGAIN SHOWS. WITH CORBIN AND
KAISER CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NAY COULD LAW YOUR CALL IN THE
PORT OF THE EXPAND OF YOU DO
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAYBE BY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS BAKER PLEASE.
MEXICO TO NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ABRAHAM MELENDEZ
REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE UNITED QUESTIONABLE
ECONOMY. RESEARCH FROM UC
MERCED SHOW THAT NEARLY ONE IN
FOUR PANDEMIC CROP LOSSES IN
CALIFORNIA IT NON CITIZEN
IMMIGRANTS AS IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE MOST
IMPACT IN THE STREET MANY OF A
UNDOCUMENTED AND MAKE SENATE
FAMILIES WERE TALKING TO HAVE
SURVIVED WITH LITTLE TO NO
INCOME. SINCE MARCH AND THOSE
SEEKING AT ALL WE STAND WITH
THE TECHNICAL FOR ALL COALITION
A GROUP OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AND COLIN LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE A WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND FOR DOCUMENT
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY COVER NINETEEN ON THE JIM
BUDGET THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
THANKS BIGGER PLEASE. NEXT WE
ARE THE NUMBER ONE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS RON I'M
PARTICIPATING WITH WHERE HARD
WORK AND RESEARCH CENTER WE
ALSO ALL BOTH THE PROPOSAL IN
THE MAIL EVERYBODY LONG TO
COLLECT UNDER THE PRIVATE UP
ONLY DID NOT ACT OF THAT ALL
TWO THOUSAND FOUR TO THE
GENERAL FUND. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST BY BOTH FONG REMAIN IN
THE BUDGET TO SERVE THEM
PARTNERS PRIORITY ALL THAT ALL
DOG WOULD BE ALL. OVER THE OVER
YOUR THE A- AND NOT BE READ
OKAY TO. ALL THEIR GOD IN THE
BIBLE. AFTER BOTH IN THE MAY
WITH. HE DIDN'T. THAT BOND
ALLOCATE BYE JUSTICE FAR WORK
AND RIGHT CONTINUOUS DOES THAT
LEAVE IT FOR BOTH. PARTICULARLY
ON THAT DID FROM THAT MAKE
WOULD HAVE PLAYED OR GET OUT
EVEN FOR THE RENT AND THE
THOUGHT THAT THE- WORKING
CONDITIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
TESTIMONY SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXT
IS NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE I'M IS YOUR TWO OH
FIVE REGARDING ELECTION. THANK
YOU SENATOR OUT OF FEAR MARKING
THE DIET CALIFORNIA BALLOT JUST
OUTLINED THE LINE ORGANIZATIONS
LET YOU KNOW BROWN OBJECT IT
SHOULD URBAN SUBURBAN RURAL AND
CORPORATE CHAIR DURING THE BEEN
DEVASTATING IMPACTED BY
COLLECTING AND AFTERSHOCKS
BECAUSE OF POLLUTING INDUSTRY
GRAYSON REGULATORY NEGLIGENT.
ALONG THANK YOU REFORM BILL BY
MAIL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
FUNDING TO CREATE YOUR.
SHORTAGE COULD BE MILLION.
INCREDIBLE YEAH THANK MORE. OUT
PROGRAM AND- MORE WHERE THEY
NEEDED HIGH DOWN THE FOR LOW.
IN THAT OVER HYPED BY YOU FOR.
INSURANCE DENTAL YOU ME CURRENT
IN PERSON VOTING OF ALONG. THE
WAY. IF ALL BY MAIL NATION OUT
OF CUTS TO PERSON GOING REST
RAISING POTENTIAL LARGE MY
VOTER ARE GETTING. WOULD YOU
HEALTH RISK IN ORDER TO HOW
PUBLIC CRISIS AND STATE THE
MEMBERS CLASS THAT MY SCHOOL
FUNDED CURRENT IN PERSON BUT
RATIOS REQUIRED LAW. IN THE
CIVIL RIGHT CANNOT BE. I ASK
YOU A LONG MANY OTHER OR-
ACTUALLY I. YOU SEE ON TV THANK
YOU ARE NOT YOUR HELP CALL.
ALLOCATE CHARGES THE MARRIED.
NOW ABOUT I TOLD YOU IN HER TO
RADIO. PUBLIC WATER REGION.
PROGRAM FROM TO TRUCK WE HAVE.
ANTI BY LATE. EACH RATE INCOME
LEVEL YOUR- NEXT PLEASE.
NATURAL NUMBER FIVE THE UNITED.
HI MY NAME SPARKY ABRAHAM I'M
AN OLDER JUSTICE TURKEY WITH
THAT SAID LIKE LEGAL SERVICES
LOS ANGELES GOING TO SUPPORT
PART SHE ISSUE TWO HUNDRED THE
ENHANCED DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
I'VE LOST INCOME AND RESOURCES
AS A RESULT AND THEN CALL READY
AND THEY'RE INCREASINGLY
VULNERABLE TO PART TWENTY
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
CALIFORNIANS CAN'T WAIT TO-
CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT FOR
PROTECTION IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
WE NEED OUT OF THE DEAL AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE WITH THE POWER TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
NEIGHBORS LOSING THEIR HOMES
AND THE LIFE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK BAKER
PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROSE MARIE BOTH BAY AND BUT
OFFICE PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES
LOCAL UNION TWENTY NINE I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE STATE
AND THEY SHOULD HAVE INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISED BUDGET. I'M
ALSO CALLING THE POOR KID WELL-
BUT DON'T GET MEMBER KALRA
UNDOCUMENTED WORKER INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK MATT ON THE ROCK
LOOK FOR HER COMMENTS AYE AYE
IN MULTIPLE COLORS BUT PART OF
THE- OUT. YEAH THE- IDEA
HOLDERS. CONDUCT WORKERS MORE
THAN. BE INTO TAXES THANK.
EVERY YEAR AND WE SHOULD NOT
OVERLOOK THEIR CRUCIAL
CONTRIBUTION. TO OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. NEXT GO TO NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WITH A ONE SIXTY SEVEN. YOU'RE
ON YOUR LINE. THANK YOU THE
ONLY NOTHING MORE FROM
PARTNERSHIP WORKING FAMILIES
ARE REPRESENT TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATE INCLUDING LANE IN LOS
ANGELES THE TWELVE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE
TELECOM BALLY CENTRAL COACH
INLAND EMPIRE ORANGE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO. THE MAIN REVISED
COMMITTEE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND- WHICH MEANS THE
CALIFORNIA. THAT THAT INCOME
REPLACEMENT IS A NON NEGOTIABLE
PIECE OF HOW WE PROTECT
FAMILIES AND BE THE CULPRIT PER
COUNTRY. BUT ALSO WE DON'T
PROVIDE INCOME REPLACEMENT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS IT WILL BE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT INCOME
REPLACEMENT IN THAT NEED SHOULD
WILL BE BECAUSE WE ARE CHOOSING
CLEAN FROM FAMILY BEHIND. BASED
ONLY ON THERE'S THAT THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY TO EXPLAIN AND
JUSTIFY THAT EXCLUSION AND THAT
KIND OF EXCLUSION IS NOT WHAT
WE- NOT WHO WE ARE CALIFORNIANS.
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
LETTER THAT WE NEVER KALRA AND
THIRTEEN OTHER LEGISLATORS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR. SO
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THE BRIDE
WEEKLY PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT IN THE JUNE BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE I'M GONNA HAVE
TO- START ASKING YOU TO GO
QUICKER BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE
OUT HERE IN ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES WE HAVE VOTING TO DO
SO- IF I COULD- MODERATOR CAN
YOU TELL ME HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
IN THE QUEUE. YEAH AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE SEVENTY ONE IN THE
QUEUE. SEVENTY ONE WELL THAT
THAT KIND OF BREAKS IT DOWN TO
THIRTY SECONDS EACH SO I IF I
IF I COULD PLEASE ASK YOUR
INDULGENCE AND GET TO THE
ISSUES WE UNDERSTAND THE IF YOU
COULD JUST SAY WHAT IT IS THAT
YOU SUPPORT- DON'T DON'T LIKE
THAT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL WE
DON'T NEED THE EDITORIALIZING
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND HOW STRONGLY YOU
FEEL ABOUT FEEL ABOUT IT SO
NEXT. NEXT BAKER PLEASE. THEN
WILL BE NUMBER SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
DENISE VELASCO WITH THE
MAINTENANCE COOPERATION TRUST
FUND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FUND TREND OCU
MINUTE WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY COLBERT NINETEEN
AND THE JOHN BUDGET. IT IS
NECESSARY TO HELP PEOPLE LIKE
ROSARIO FOR MORTGAGE COUNTY
THAT WAS LET GO FROM HER
CLEANING JOB AND IS NOW
HOMELESS PREGNANT AND DOES NOT
KNOW WHERE HER NEXT MEAL WILL
COME FROM. WE CANNOT LEAVE
PEOPLE LIKE BESIDE YOUR BEHIND
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF ITUNES FILERS AND THAT
CALLIE I TO YOU SEE ON THE
INCLUSION OF THE SEAT
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
THAT WAS GOOD NEXT ORDER NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SHANNON HOW THAT'S FROM THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE ROCKS WITH
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF OUR
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS STATEWIDE IN COLLEGE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE. THE GOVERNOR COULD
LEAVE TRAILER BILL. THE CORE
COMPONENT OF REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM I'LL TO TWENTY QUICKLY
TO ADDRESS- MENTION ABOUT. AND
THE TRACKING WITH YOUR POLICY
COMMITTEES RATHER THAN IN THE
BUDGET. AND MAKE CLEAR THAT
THERE IS A BILL AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN AUTHORED BY FOR THE
RIVERS COVERING COULD BALLOT
THAT ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF THE
COUNTY SIDE. I DON'T LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE TO A FIVE AND
THEN THE CALIFORNIA MONTHLY THE
COUNTRY TO ENSURE THAT THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION IS ACCEPTABLE
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS SHREDDING
EVERY COMPANY BUT OUR BALLOT IS
ONLY ONE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
MAINTAINING ADEQUATE IN PRINT
OPTIONS IS ALSO VITALLY
IMPORTANT AS HAS BEEN NOTED THE
MAYBE LIKE DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND IT
IS CRITICAL THAT THE FUNDING IS
ADDED SURE PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF OTHERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
WILL BE NUMBER ONE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ARE MORE MERRILL TO
TELL LEAGUE BUT COUNTRY BUT- MY
COMMENT WILL BE AN ISSUE KILL
FIVE WHICH ON HE TO BEAT YOUR
PART OF THE AGENDA WE SUPPORT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
REQUEST FOR SIXTY FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION A FEDERAL FUNDED
STORY BUT THE NEED IS ACTUALLY
MUCH GREATER FOR FUNDING FOR
VOTER EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
FOR THE CRUCIAL THAT AMBER
GENERAL ELECTION SHE- HI THERE
ARE NOW. AND VOTERS MUST
UNDRSTAND ALL OF THEIR OPTIONS
WHY ADDITIONAL FUNDING AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
WHETHER THAT IS FROM THE
FEDERAL OR THE STATE AND OUR
STATE FUNDING THAT THE NEED FOR
STATEWIDE AND LOCAL BUT OUR
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH-
ACTUALLY I WANT TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF IN PERSON BY A
LOCATION. FOR ECHO EQUITABLE
VOTER ACCESS. WHAT WE CAN. ARE
NEVER AND TO INCLUDING. BY MAIL
BUT ALSO AT NINE. IMPORTANT
LOCATION ACOSTA TO AVOID. LAW
LONG. AND CRY. ONE THE CROWD WE
BE CONTRIBUTING THE HEALTH
THANK VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TO CUSTOMER NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
NUMBER ONES EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK THE CARRERA
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SPEAKING UP PARKING ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN I AM AYE ACOSTA
REPORTS COMMENTS IN THE
CORPORATION OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TWENTY NINETEEN COULD COUNT
REVEAL THAT MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE
WERE EXPERIENCIG HOMELESSNESS.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE THE HIGH
PRIORITY OF ANY HOMELESSNESS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE- PROPOSED A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR FUND WHICH IS
ONE TIME FEDERAL TO STATE
RESOURCES. THAT TO CREATE
PERMANENT AT THE STATE LEVEL
PASSED UP THROUGH TO EXIT ALL
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ROOM PROJECT
AND HE RESIDENTS- WE PROVIDED
THAT- RECOMMENDATION AND
WRITING AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
BE NUMBER THIRTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LUCY A MATIC FOR THE SENATE OR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING I'M
COMMENTING ON THE PORT FOR
PARKS THE ISSUE TWO HUNDRED
EXPANDING THE D. B. O. INTO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
GREAT RELIEF MEASURE TO BOTH
STABILIZE PEOPLE'S LIVES DURING
THE CRISIS AND THAT PEOPLE UP
TO TRACK YOUR ACTOR EXPLORED
LOOKING DEFINITIONS WILL
CAPTURE THE KINDS OF ABUSE OF
LENDERS NOW OFFERING PAY LIKE
CREDIT APPETITE PRODUCT.
CURRENTLY TO ESCAPE OVERSIGHT
BECAUSE THE INSTANCE OF THE DAY
OWE HIM BY. FINANCIAL CO
DEFINITE. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IT DID PROGRAM THAT- EXPANSION
WILL SET UP- CALIFORNIANS TO
TRY TO LONG TERM BECAUSE WILL
PROVIDE A COMMISSIONER WITH THE
ABILITY TO LEVERAGE ITS NEW
FOUND IMPORTANT CAPACITY.
BENEFIT OF CONSUMERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE DAY THE
OVERHEATING ARE SUGGESTIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIA ONE
COMMENT REALLY BRIEFLY ON TWO
ISSUES THE FIRST IS TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR HER THAT YOUR
NATION DISTRICT FUNDING WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HELP REBUILD PARADISE AND
SECOND WE HAVE REALLY SERIOUS
CONCERNS AND OPPOSE THE EIGHT
CD AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
CLEAN UP TRAILER BILL. ISSUE
THIRTY THIS ISSUE IS FAR FROM
CLEAN UP AND IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM EXPANSION WE HAVE
REALLY SERIOUS CONCERNS THE
BILL COULD LEAD TO INCONSISTENT
LAND USES AN INCREASE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED ALL LOW
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED AND LOCAL
INPUT AND HINDER OUR ABILITY TO
REDUCE THE M. T. AS THE STATE'S
REQUIRING SO STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
HUGE. HOLE IN MY. EIGHTY SEVEN.
TAYLOR BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS NOT
APPOINTED UNDER THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF A
WEEKLY INCOME REPLACEMENT FUND
FOR DOCUMENT WORKERS AND
INCLUDING THE AYE TO FIVE YEARS
IN THE CAL THE AGENCY. AS WELL
NOT A PART OF MAINTAINING THE
INITIATIVE IN THE STATE BUDGET
WE ARE YOU KNOW SHOULD NOT
OVERLOOK THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. YOU SO MUCH I WAS. IF
COULD FOLLOW THAT WE COULD GET
ALMOST EVERYBODY IN NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS AND WE
THE TREE WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
ISSUE FOURTEEN PART HE WE ASK
THAT YOU MENTIONED ALLOCATION
OF THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER LANGUAGE PREFERENCE
RELATED UPDATE ELECTION
MATERIAL. THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET AREN'T YOU
MAKE MONEY INCREASING
INCREASING VOTING LOCATION
POSSIBLE. AGAIN LA HAD PRODUCT
OVER THREE THOUSAND DRY
APPLICATIONS. IN THE LAST FORTY
EIGHT. THE COURT ESTABLISHING
I'M ROBUST INCOME PLACEMENT
PROGRAM FOURTH SOMEONE KALRA.
WITH SEVERAL INCLUDING GARAGE.
ISSUE THIRTY ONE PART AB
SUPPORT THE PRODUCT LINE UNDER
LWD A CO WORKER PROTECTIONS
SUCH AS THAT IF YOU FOURTEEN
THIRTY RIGHT. WE SUPPORT I CAN
FILERS IN CAL YEAH IF YOU ARE A
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT AS WELL
AS THE NATION THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT BAKER PLEASE. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO OH FOUR
THE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
PAMELA AND I'M WITH LEGAL AID
AT WORK. ARE YOU WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WATCH WORK AND THE
RESULT OF THIS CRISIS ARE NOW
ELIGIBLE BUT FOR BETWEEN SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY AND ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY DOLLARS PER WEEK
IN UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT BALLET
REPORT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS PAID
OUT TWELVE BILLION IN YOU I
BENEFITS WITH THE START OF THE
CRISIS. HOWEVER ONE GROUP HAD
CAN ENTIRELY EXCLUDED AND THAT
IS UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO
MAKE UP ONE TENTH OF OUR
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
BEEN EQUITY NOT BE ADDRESS IN
AGAIN BUDGET AND NOT WHY WE'RE
SUPPORTING BEING. HAVE A WEEKLY
INCOME REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
FRIEND DOCUMENTED WORKERS WOULD
BECOME AN EMPLOYEE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THANK SENATOR
DROPPED OVER HER SUPPORT AND
HELP REIMAGINE DISTILLING OUR-
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER US. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BUT WE CAN HEAR YOU. THE
NUMBER THEIR NAME IN HERE RIGHT.
AMANDA LETTER YEAH YEAH YEAH.
HELLO ARE. VERY PROUD OF MIND
PLANNING WERE NOT FOR MONEY THE
DEATH OF BACKING BUT ARE NOT
GOING TO ME ON A IN THE THAT.
IT'S A NICE THAT BAD IT HOUR
NOT A IDEA FROM LOTUS IN
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE NOT READ
THAT BY ALIVE BY FAT THAT IN
THAT WITH ME THE- NO. THEY NEED
LEVEL AND THERE WERE NOT.
THERE'S THAT THAT MINE. BUT I
SAID GRANDMA BE CANDLE AND
THAT'S YES THIS THE MORNING.
LEGITIMATE WITH US YES PURSUE
TO PRESENT THIS YEAR I WHAT I.
THE NEXT THIS PLEASE NEXT WILL
BE TWO ELEVEN PLEASE AHEAD.
SEVEN CHAIR. RUBBER WHO WROTE
CONSUMER FEDERATION TELL THANK
YOU FOR TAKING PHONE TWO THE
MONEY AND SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED TO AND HOW
THE PART BECAUSE THIS I SHE TO
HUNDRED. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK THE
TRIAL STOP STATE CONCERN. OVER
WHAT THE RELIGION OF PPL RATHER
INSURERS THE GPO CAN DO ITS JOB
AND OVERSEEING FINANCIAL
SERVICES BEYOND THE CURRENT
AUTHORITY BUT TO BE ANOTHER
STATE AGENCIES. IN BAD TIMES
FINANCIAL SCAMMERS COME OUT OF
WHAT. WE NEED ENFORCEMENT AGAIN
PRESCRIPTIVE FINANCIAL
OPERATIONS CURRENTLY BEYOND THE
BILL'S CUT THE AUTHORITY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT OF THE
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD ALL. OF. HELLO WHEN I
SEVEN AND IS THIS NUMBER AT THE
END OF IT IT MAY NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN WILL BE AND IS ALWAYS IN
A RUNNY BUT YOU'RE NOT YOUR
GIRLFRIEND HE CALLED A MORON.
HELLO ARE A LOT BUT I MEAN IF
SOMEONE BEGIN BILL A IT WAS
LIKE WE YEP I AMONG YEP YOU'RE
GONNA BE I LOOK AT THE LOCAL
MADE AND A LOT. YEAH YEAH GOT A
BOOK. WHAT IT. MY GLASSES HE
SAID BY THE NEXT BAKER PLEASE
OKAY. IS THE NEXT SECOND XV
NUMBER TWO NINE PLEASE YEAH.
THANK MAY FEEL ILL CAL IS ONE
BE SUPPORT THE ADOPTION OF THE
FAMILY LEAVE PROPOSAL TO THE
THAT ALLOWED FORTY COULD OF
WORKER TO BE BY FOR LEAVE THAT
THEY PAY FOR IT SUPPORT ISSUE
INSTEAD THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FUNDING AND WE ALIGN SENATOR
OUTLOOK. ON CALLIE I. T. C.
EXPENSE DAHLE IMMIGRANT TAX
FILERS AN ASH KALRA PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ON GOING WAGE
REPLACEMENT IS ARE CRITICAL TO
OUR STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
EFFORTS THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT WAS GREAT. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. FOR THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHOULD BE WHEN
OFFENDED ME NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
FINAL SO YOU MANY MORE CRITICAL
NEED AT THAT EVEN IF YOU THINK
THAT I HAD LIED A LOT. IN THE
COURSE OF WITHOUT ANY SATELLITE
CLEANING GOING UP FOR MONEY
SELECT THE BY THE- LOOK LOOK WE
TITLES. BUT IT'S ALL YOU CAN
LOOK AT HERE. MAKING A YOUNG
GIRL THAT I'M NOT LONDON
LOOKING NOT ALMOST ANGLES
ALLUDING. BUT I'D GIVE ALL THAT
MOST THERE ARE BE GETTING.
WHICH GAS YES. YES YES. NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO BE
TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO. GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS IS NEED TO ON
WHAT THE USE LABORS AND OF ITEM
NUMBER PART A IS THE KEY TO IT
SHOULD HAVE ALSO WANTING TO.
THE AND I'M INCLUDING IDENTIFY
IS WITHIN POWER A PIECE AS AS
THE CREATION OF A REPLACE AND
FIND DOCUMENT IS A WELL I
FILLING UP A TO I NUMBER THE
ONE THANK YOU. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU MUCH. NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
NEXT BE NUMBER FOUR FIVE PLEASE
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHAN FELDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE PAPER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING INDUSTRY- WE ARE
OPPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S
CIGARETTE TAX POLICY ISSUE
NUMBER TWO OH TWO. OH FORTY NO
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO A TAX BUT
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS TAX
WHICH WOULD JACQUI CIGARETTES A
HIGHER RATE THAN COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES. WHICH AS THE LA OF
HIS NOTED WILL LIKELY DRIVE THE
CONSUMPTION OF COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES ADDITIONALLY TAXED
MAKING CONTENT AS THEY HAVE
PROPOSED DOES NOT BEEN PROVEN
TO IMPACT YOUTH PURCHASING
BEHAVIOR GIVEN THE FACT THAT
ALMOST 80% UNDER USERS OF THE
PRODUCT. PURCHASED THEM LEGALLY
AND ALREADY PAY MARKED UP
PRICES. WE SHOULD HAVE TAX.
VOTERS INTO AND- PROPERTY SIX
WHICH WE ARE PLEASE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR TEST. NEXT WEEK
PLEASE. ACTUALLY NUMBER TWO
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER.
PLEASE ARE THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MARGARET GOLD AND ALL THE
DIRECTOR FOR THE FIRST FIVE
INITIATION REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY EIGHT FIRST FIVE COUNTY
COMMISSION I'M HERE TO SHARE
CONCERNED EVERY ISSUE TO A TWO
PART THE NICOTINE DATE INTACT.
WE AGREE THE CONCEPT OF TACKING
A PRODUCT WHICH YOU WERE
WORRIED ABOUT YOU BABY HAPPEN
AND WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
FLAVORS BAND HOWEVER WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRECEDENTS THAT LOOK THAT
PROVIDE KATHLEEN EXISTING
TOBACCO TAXES. WE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT
SURPRISING XCELERATED REVENUE
DECLINED OUR BUNDLE DECLINED BY
50% VOTERS FIRST IMPROVE POP
CAN ONLY THINK THAT SHARE HER
KNOWLEDGE AND AFTER THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK THIS CAN IMPLY
THE EXISTING TAX STRUCTURE TO
THE NEW INVESTMENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. BUT NEXT TO A THE
NUMBER. SO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE PLEASE.
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN I
GEHRY WITH LEGAL AID AT WHERE I
NONPROFIT ADVOCATE THE RIGHTS
OF LOW WAGE WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING TODAY
AND TRANSPORTED ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THE GOVERNOR'S PAID FAMILY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
URGENT IS ABOUT THAT PROPOSE.
FORTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS NOT
COVERED BY A TOP PROTECTION
LAWS BECAUSE THEIR EMPLOYERS TO
SMALL TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE
FAMILY FELT AND THEIR INCOME
WELL THE PROBLEM BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BUT OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS WE'VE HEARD FROM
THOUSANDS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
ACROSS THEIR CLINICS AND HELP
LINE. ONE THING IT BECOME CLEAR
THE CONTINUATION OF THAT THE
NETWORK OF OFFICE THEM IS
UNCONSCIONABLE NOW THE TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO ACT TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
WELL BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND THEN I CAN BE ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
THE NEXT BE NUMBER NINE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS A SORRY SORRY
WITH THE COUNTY BE EVER HELTER
JUSTIFICATION ON PART B. I. AND
POINT SEVEN YEARS FRANKLY
REQUEST INCLUSION OF BOARDING
CARE HOMES OF AN ELIGIBLE
PROPERTY AND THE GOVERNOR IS
COMPOSED. OF ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION KORUNA BUYERS RELIEF
FUND FOR PARTICLE TOLD THE
MOTELS FOR CONTINUATION OF
PROJECT RANKING- BOARDING CARE
HOMES OPERATE STRUCTURED
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT DURING
FRAGILE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
OTHERWISE BE HOMELESS OR
INSTITUTIONALIZED. PEOPLE
COMMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE REQUESTING A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION EXPENDITURE DEADLINE
DUE TO CALL THE NINETEEN
HUNDREDS OR NO PLACE LIKE HOME
TECHNICAL. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE.
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER NINETY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO SELECT A
HOWARD AND I'M NOT POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH TO BE MORE ACTION
ON BEHALF OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME TO. STATE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION OF THE
DDO ISSUE TWO HUNDRED A PART OF
THE AGENDA. ESPECIALLY FROM
THERE IS NO IMPACT TO THE
GENERAL FUND- I URGE YOU NOT TO
PUT THE DDO PROPOSAL OFF UNTIL
A BETTER TIME. THE CALL THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE ITS ROLE AS
A NATIONAL LEADER IN YOUR
PROTECTION. THE ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO WORST AND NOW IS
THE TIME. TO IMPLEMENT
AMBITIOUS FISCAL AND REGULATORY
PROTECTION POLICIES SO PLEASE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED MEDIA
EXPANSION OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT WE NUMBER TWO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO ALL
I SEEM TO HERNANDEZ HERE I AND
STRONGLY ONCE OPPOSE PARKS SEE
TO- TO THE SO CALLED BABY TAX
IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING VOTING
FOR THIS I WANT TO RESPECTFULLY
CONSIDER IT SINGLE PAYER
HEALTHCARE COUNTRIES INCLUDING
THE U. K. AND CANADA AND THE
ROYAL COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS ALL
SUPPORT PEIPING AS A LESS RISKY
ALTERNATIVE CIGARETTES WHICH
KILLED ONE AND TWO OF ITS
USERS. IN FACT THE SINGLE PAYER
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS HAVE FOUND
IN PUBLISHED STUDIES VAPOR IS
AT LEAST 90% REDUCTION IN HARM
TO CONSUMERS AND THEREFORE
CATCHING PEIPING AT TWO TIME
THIRTY CIGARETTES IT'S ACTUALLY
EXTREMELY HARMFUL AND WILL
DRIVE CONSUMER MISPERCEPTIONS
AND PEOPLE TO A PRODUCT THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY KILL THEM AB
PROBLEMS YOU NOT HAPPY. GEN
THEY HAVE A MARKET LAWLER
NUMBER CARPAL. ALL PLEASE DO
NOT VOTE FOR SOMETHING X. TO
KEEP OF ALL TO WILL. I'M SORRY
BY IT WILL YOUR POINT IS WELL
AND WE NEED TO MOVE ON NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. RENTS ARE WHERE
WE ARE STILL AT FIFTY IN Q.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRIAN HICKOX- I AM
CALLING- REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
TWO TO ASKING YOU TO OPPOSE THE
NEWSPAPER TAXES AS PROP FIFTY
SIX IS ALREADY LEVY. OF TAXES
TO- HE CIGARETTES BASED ON NOT
A CIGARETTE TAXES AND THE NEW
TAX WOULD MORE THAN DOUBLE. THE
TAX RATE OUR COUNTER POUND
FORCING PEOPLE BACK TO ANALOG
CIGARETTES AND A- FASTER. MORE
PAINFUL DEATH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. A NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS AMAAN TERRAKOM WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATE FOR YOU
THIS IS ABOUT ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN IN PART BE. REQUESTING A
MINIMUM OF 10% FUNDING THAT
ASIDE FOR YOU THEY COME WITH
THE BUDGET WE SURVEYED KEEP
FUNDED DO PROVIDERS AND SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. INDICATED THEY
PROVIDED HOUSING TO YOUTH WHO
WERE MADE HOMELESS YOU CALL THE
NINETEEN BUT THE FOCUS BEING ON
PROJECT RING HE FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED.
YOU WILL NOT BE THIRD WITHOUT A
SATISFIED IN LA COUNTY JUST ONE
POINT 8% OF PROJECT GROUP HE
RECIPIENTS ARE YOU. FOR THIS
REASON WE ASK YOU TO INCLUDE A
YOU'D BETTER PRIDE IN A HOME
BUDGET. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER EIGHT ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ELIZABETH
DOLLARS TRACKING ATTORNEY OF
THE CONSUMER LAWYER PUBLIC'S
LOSS FROM TURN ORANGE COUNTY IN
ORDER PART HE ISSUE TWO
HUNDRED. DLP I WOULD MAKE AN
IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
NOW WHEN WE ARE FREAKING THE
GREATEST FINANCIAL CRISIS AND
ARE LIKE KERN WITH A CLIENT WHO
BEFORE COMING TO US. THOUSANDS
OF WE DID GARNISH FOR DEFAULT
JUDGMENT SHE DID NOT KNOW ABOUT
EVENTUALLY IT STOPPED YEARS
LATER THE DEBT COLLECTOR CAME
BACK IT THAT YOU STILL OWE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AFTER
FINDING US. AFTER THE DEBT
COLLECTOR YOU TO PROVIDE US AN
ACCOUNTING WE KEEP TOGETHER
INFORMATION AND FOUND THAT SHE
ALREADY PAID MORE THAN WHAT.
THE GOLD WE CAN FROM THE DEBT
COLLECTOR THE RESPONSE WITH
YOUR LONG WHERE RIGHT WE WILL
KEEP COLLECTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. NECK WILL BE
GOING TO NUMBER TWO TWENTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU GO ON
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YES
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BARMAN
DRAWN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN CAR WASH CAMPAIGN ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE VICTIM TO
PREACH THAT. YOU WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE LANGUAGE OF
PUBLICLY JANUARY TRAILER BILL
AND OPPOSITION TELLING WHICH
COUPLES MAY REDUCTION. IN THE
MAY REVISION WILL CREATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS AT A TIME
WHEN WORKERS NEED MORE NOT LESS
PROTECTION AND HELP COLLECTING
THE RIGHT THERE ARE. WE JUST OF
THOSE REASONS WE ASK THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE JANUARY TRAILER
BILL BE COMPLEMENTARY AND NOT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE MAY
REVISION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE GOING TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
CALENDAR TRUCK CAR ON THE PAUL
BUSINESSMAN LOCALLY INTERNAL MY
COUNTY ALSO REPRESENTING
GRUDGING HUNDREDS OF THE-
EIGHTEEN YEAR WE OPPOSE THE
NEW. DATA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO
A NUMBER TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MANY THIRTY STAND I'M
LOOK BLACK A WILD MAN AND ONE
AT THAT ARE SUPPORT OR THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE ISSUE LINE AND
THEN ALSO. ABOUT TOO LOW BY. WE
NEED BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE PUBLIC EDUCATION. IN
ORDER TO ALERT VOTERS ABOUT
THEIR MAIL IN BALLOT HOW TO
FILL IT OUT I'D LOVE HOW TO
TURN IT IN. IN ADDITION WE KNOW
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ON HOW PEOPLE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. A NEW
VOTER. KNOW HOW TO. TALK ABOUT.
IN THAN BONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ABOUT I KNOW I HATE TO DO
THIS BUT WE GOT A MORE MINUTES
THEN THE LINE GOES TODAY.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL ALL THAT THE
TO AS LONG AS A LET US USE IT
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE I GET AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE IF YOU
COULD STATE YOUR NAME AND WHAT
YOU SUPPORT AND WHAT YOU DON'T
THAN WHAT WE'RE WRITING IT DOWN
AND- IF WE MISS YOU PLEASE YOU
CAN SEND IN YOUR YOUR-
TESTIMONY IN WRITING IF YOU'D
LIKE. BUT IF I COULD PLEASE ASK
YOUR INDULGENCE SO THAT WE CAN
GET AS MANY PEOPLE TO SPEAK
DURING THE NEXT EIGHT MINUTES.
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT WE
NUMBER TWO NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANIELLE JONES AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR SMOKE
FREE ALTERNATIVES ASSOCIATION
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED TAX ON NICOTINE PAPER
PRODUCTS THANK YOU EXCELLENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT BAKER.
ACTUALLY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MANAGER
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE UNITED
NUMBER ONE THE SURFER EXPANSION
ALL WORKERS INCREDIBLY UNFAIR
TO FORCE WORKERS TO PAY FOR
PROGRAMS THAT THEY CAN'T ACCESS
AND WORKERS YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CARE FOR LOVED UNDER THEIR
OWN SICKNESS WHEN TRAGEDY RIGHT
SO WE VERY MUCH URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS BAKER. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS GEORGIA HALL AND I'M WITH
AMERICAN PETROLEUM AND
CONVENIENCE STORE ASSOCIATION
AND I OPPOSE ANY PUT IT TAXES
ON BAY BEING PRODUCT HIGHER
THAN THE COMBUSTIBLE ADDRESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EXCELLENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE NEW
DIRECTOR OF THE GARMENT WORKER
CENTER WITH RESPECT TO ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE- WE- ANYONE WE AND-
QUITE THE JANUARY PROPOSAL IS
ACTUALLY ON THE TRANSFER
UNCLEAN WAGES TO THE GARMENT
WORKER CAR WASH WORKER AND
FARMWORKERS RESTITUTION FUND
WITH RESPECT TO GARMENT WORKERS
WITH HOW WIDESPREAD WAIT THAT
IS IN THE INDUSTRY WILL HAVE
AND ALL THAT AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
WITHOUT ONGOING APPROPRIATION
WE ALSO OPPOSE. THE TRANSFER-
OR THE LOAN OF FUNDS FROM
PROJECT TO THE GENERAL FUND AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE INCOME REPLACEMENT
FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND
INCLUSION OF I CAN COLLEGE IN
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WEEK NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
NEXT BE NUMBER TWO FOR NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAD LEARNED
AND DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
SPEAKING TO ISSUE TWO HUNDRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMERS NEED AN ENHANCED
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
AGENCY THEY NEED THAT AGENCY ON
THE BEAT. AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NOT
ENOUGH- ALL ENTER WITH CHIRLA
AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
COMPLICATED CENTRAL VALLEY-
LIKE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH
KALRA PARTIAL INCOME
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND
INCLUDED IN THE TRUMP BUDGET.
I'M ALSO FOR THE KELLY I TO
KEEP BASHING FOR AYE CHEN
FILERS ON THE GOVERNOR'S TOTAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. NEXT WE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. YOU CAN MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER TWO FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI EVERYONE MY
NAME IS PHOTO BODY GAS AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CLEAN CAR WASH CAMPAIGN AND
WHERE I'M SUPPORT OF ITEMS
SEVEN. FIVE FOR THE INCLUSION
OF THE FINANCIAL IN THE STATE
BUDGET WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM TWENTY ONE. I DON'T
REGINALD JANUARY PROPOSAL TO
MAKE THE MILITARY CONFLICT ON
CLEAN WE TOOK TO THE
RESTITUTION FUND. WE ARE ALL
GOING FOR QUARTERBACKS CARLA ON
THE TIME TO PROVIDE A SAFETY
NET FOR ALL AGES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT BAKER PLEASE. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
PHONE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
CENTER TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT I
THINK WE CAN ABOUT WITH ME. ONE
DOCUMENT THEIR WORKERS IN THE
GUN BUT GET WORLD CLASS YOU'RE
GOING CONCERN OF I HOLD. IN THE
COLLEGE I YEAH YEAH. CREDIT AS
WELL AS BEING INITIATIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE NUMBER TWO SO
SIX GO AHEAD. THANK ACT REALLY
DETAILS ON MONDAY WITH THE UCLA
LABOR CENTER CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE SHOULD SEVEN THE
FIENDISH. ALSO SUPPORTER OF THE
INCLUSION OF AYE COMPRISES THE
CAL E. I. T. C. R. AS WELL AS A
PROPOSAL FOR A WEEKLY INTERNET
GRAYSON FIND FRIEND I CAN THEIR
WORKERS AND LASTLY- WE OPPOSE
ISSUE THIRTY ONE WHEN I HAD A
FRIEND WHO CAME TO BE USED FOR
LABOR LONG QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER. NEXT WE NUMBER TWO
TWO. NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
BUT NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS JESSICA
CENTER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN FRONT SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL GO TO
EXPAND OPPORTUNITY LEAD TO ALL
CALIFORNIA WORKING FAMILIES.
AND ALSO URGED INCLUSION OF ALL
IMMIGRANT TAX FILERS IN THE CAL
YET YOU SEE IN THE STATE
BUDGET. CRITICAL TO THINK THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
ALSO WILL HELP AND IN A QUALITY
FRAME ABOUT WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS KATIE WATERFRONT
PUT THAT CALIFORNIA WORKING
FAMILIES COALITION I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER DEL
I'M JOB THE JACKET HE LEADS
WHICH IS ISSUE ONE WE ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE INCLUSION
OF THE WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT FINE FRIEND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY FROM THE NINETEEN
IN A JUNE BUDGET THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER THREE OH TWO TWO
PLAYER HAD. HI THIS IS EVELYN
SHOOT FROM AND CHILD POVERTY
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF INCLUDING TAX
FILERS WITH I CAN NUMBERS IN
CAL YET YOU SEE AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THE SEAT INITIATIVE
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS
PROPOSAL FOR A WEEKLY INCOME
REPLACEMENT AND- UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBERS THREE OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING ALEX CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
FIRST BY CALIFORNIA AND JUNK
THE PART OF ITEM ONE THE
GOVERNOR COULD FAMILY PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
DOLLARS CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE
I THINK WE HAVE TIME FOR ONE
MORE. AND THEN THEN THE NEXT
WILL BE. THE HEAD EIGHT GEN. GO
AHEAD. DOT THREE AWAY EUROPEN.
HELLO VETERAN CARNEGIE
CALIFORNIA PENETRATE HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
PARK EIGHT EIGHT FOUNDING
LEAVE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE MORE.
YOU KNOW ME- THEN WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MAP RIGHT
HERE ON THE AFTER THE TEAMSTERS
IN PARADISE YOU'RE ENGAGING
DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE DID JOB STAFF
RECOMMENDATION REGARDING PART
SHE ISSUE ONE NINETY FIVE-
WHICH IS ABOUT THE BUDGET
REPAIRED AS YOUR GAUGING
DISTRICT. STANDINGS PARAMOUNT
FOR THE SURVIVAL OF PARADISE
AND OUR WORKERS EMPLOYED AT P.
ID THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO IT'S NOW SIX THIRTY AND MY
APOLOGIES TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE ON THE LINE AND THEY CAN
GET A CHANCE TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON. IF YOU'RE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE EMAIL CALL OR
WRITE THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE CAN MAKE WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE. THAT YOUR
TESTIMONY IS PART OF THE RECORD
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO THAT
THE FULL COMMITTEE OF THE
BUDGET GETS THE INFORMATION AS
WELL- I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED AND LISTENED.
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH AND UP AND I DO
APOLOGIZE IT THIS IS PART OF.
THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS
EXPEDITED IN THE CODE RED
NINETEEN PROCESS THAT WE'RE
USING IS THAT WERE YEAH WE HAVE
A LIMITED TIME AND- AND ENTERED
TO TAKE TESTIMONY IN PARTICULAR
WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING ON ON
THESE ITEMS RIGHT NOW BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AYE. I REALLY WANT TO.
I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE INPUT ON
THIS IS NOT EASY WORK TO DO AND
WE'RE DOING IT IN AN- AN
EXPEDITED REALLY EXPEDITED WAY
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE
SEND YOUR TESTIMONY TO S.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE FANCY. YOU
CAN SEND IT IN AN EMAIL AND-
EASY TO DO YOU CAN DO IT IN A-
YEAH EMAIL IS THE BEST WAY. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO NOW WE'RE
RIGHT WE'RE READY TO BEGIN THE
VOTING- AND WE WANT TO START
WITH- PART A OF THE AGENDA NOW
ON OUT. TAKE A REAL QUICK BREAK.
MISSION AND.
BEG YOUR
INDULGENCE AS WE GET. OURSELVES
ORGANIZED HERE.
TO THE LOAN.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE READY WE'RE
READY TO BEGIN- ARE VOTING ON
PART A OF THE AGENDA NOW AND I
HAVE HAD A REQUEST ON ITEM
THIRTY ONE ON THE- PART A
AGENDA- AS THE- SENATOR DR SO
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON ON THIRTY ONE A AND. IT'S
THE IT- IT SAYS IT'S THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND IT REGARD IT'S
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL. FOR A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR LOAN FROM THE LABOR AND
WORK FOR THE FOREST DEVELOPMENT
FUND. TO THE GENERAL FUND YES
BUT- MADAM CHAIR IF WE COULD
HOLD THAT OVER- FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND FOR THE
CONSIDERATION I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. AND SO THE
MOTION AT THIS TIME WOULD BE TO
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. AND I DON'T
I DON'T HAVE ANY- CONCERNED
WITH DOING THAT AT THIS POINT-
SO THAT IS THE MOTION. YEAH.
YEP IS OUT CENTER NIELSEN. THAT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THAT'S GOOD
OUT ALL EXCEPT HER MOTION-
WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE
ON THE- AT EIGHT AGENDA. THE
ROLE. CABALLERO I SEN I DRESS
UP I GREAT THANK YOU THANK THAT
NOW WILL TAKE UP VOTE ON A CHEN
FOR PART. AND WE HAVE PULLED
OFF NUMBER ONE FIVE IN FIFTEEN
THESE ARE HOLD WILL OPEN ITEMS
AND- AND WE'RE GONNA SPLIT THE
VOTE ON THE VOTE ON THE AGENDA
WE WILL FIRST BE VOTING ON
ISSUES. TWO THROUGH FOUR. EIGHT
THROUGH TEN. THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX THREE
TWENTY EIGHT. THIRTY ONE.
332-373-9240 ONE. ABOUT THIRTY
ONE ARE WE DID NEVER MIND
THIRTY ONE. IS THERE A M<c.cyan> ON</c>
THIS WORK ON THESE ITEMS WILL.
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DRAW SO THE MOST
EMOTION IS TO PROVE áP PROVE
TE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF AREA HI NIELSEN. TORONTO
RIGHT. MEDICARE I'M GONNA HAVE
TO SPUR OFF. CHECK BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S WAY THE BUY SPLIT.
ALL OKAY OKAY GOT IT. OKAY NEXT
WILL BE ON ISSUE SEVEN. ELEVEN
TWELVE ELEVEN INTO SIXTEEN INTO.
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY AND THIRTY TWO. IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE ITEMS.
FOR MORE. THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR GARAGE SO THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE IT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
REMEMBER TO SPEAK AND HEAR MIKE
SENATOR CABALLERO BY SENATOR
OUT AS THEIR NIELSEN HI. YOU WE-
NOW. OR OCCUPATIONAL. AT WILL
CALL WILL CALL THE SIX CALLED
YOU YUP ENTER NOW NO SENATOR
RAZA I. THE MOTION CARRIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
WILL BE VOTING ON ISSUES SIX
AND TWENTY ONE. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE ITEMS
SOME OF THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DR SO. THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HAVE AREA
BY YELTSIN I. DURACELL HI.
MOTION PASSES FINALLY WE WILL
TAKE VOTES ON THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS BEGINNING WITH ITEM FORTY
TWO IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE
ITEMS. YOU'RE AT FORTY I HAVE.
SOME OF THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DRAWS A- THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAVE AREA I.
NIELSEN I TRUST THEM HI. MOTION
PASSES WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FORTY THREE. I HAVE A
NOTE. OKAY IT IS FOR WOMEN OF.
WALKER FOR IF YOU'RE A THREE
THREE B. AND I TO OTHER POLICE
IT SAYS KEEP. OKAY SO THAT CAN.
AT THE A. OKAY AND WILL MOVE TO
PART BE. WE WILL BEGIN THE
VOTING ON PART B. H. NOW. FIRST
WE WILL TAKE UP THE ONLY A J.
FOR PAR B. WE HAVE WITHDRAWN TO
FOUR FROM THE AGENDA. ONLY C. A
NOT HAVE THE- OKAY. OUR KIDS
THAT. IN THE. FOURTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. YES BY TWO THROUGH
FOUR SEVEN THROUGH EIGHT TWELVE
FOURTEEN THROUGH TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY SIX. IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THESE ITEMS. THANK YOU THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION SEVEN MOVE
BY SENATOR DRESSER. THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RARE. HI
YOUR FRIEND I TRUST THEM YES.
MOTION PASSES NEXT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON ISSUES NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER FIVE. NUMBER SIX NUMBER
TEN. ELEVEN THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
THREE. IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE
ITEMS. SO MOVED THANK YOU THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DR SO. THE
MOTION IS TO PRODUCE IS TO
APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PLEASE
REMEMBER TO BEGIN HERE MIKE
CARREIRO BY NIELSEN NO. TRUST
THEM HI. MOTION PASSES. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS ISSUES TWENTY
SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY ARE TO
HOLD THESE ITEMS OPEN SO WE
WON'T TAKE A VOTE ON THESE
ISSUES AT THE AT THIS TIME.
THIS CONCLUDES PART B. SEE WE
WILL BEGIN VOTING ON THE PART
C. AGENDA NOW. FIRST WE WILL BE
POLLING ISSUE ONE SEVENTY AND
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN. WHICH
ONE OF THENEXT WE WILL TAKE UP
THE VOTE ONLY AGENDA FOR PART
SEE. WELL THE- SHE WAS SHE GOT
VERY PULLED OUT THIRTY ONE
RIGHT OR WAS THAT ANY. I
THOUGHT WE HAD WE HAD THIRTY
ONE OUT WITH ONLY A- SORRY OKAY.
SORRY RIGHT HERE IN. PARTY WE
RIGHT WAS IT A. OKAY LAUGH.
OKAY THE FAMILY GATHERED ON
FRIDAY- OVER THE GROUP. SO. ALL
RIGHTY WE GOT IT STRAIGHT NOW
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE VOTING ON. THIS IS
AGENDA FOR PART PART SEE. WE
WILL FIRST BE VOTING ON ISSUES
ONE THROUGH FOUR. SIX SEVEN.
NINE THREE SIXTEEN. NINETEEN TO
TWENTY THREE. TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY NINE. THIRTY ONE TO
THIRTY THREE. THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY FIVE. FORTY SEVEN.
572-606-9712 SEVENTY THREE.
782-808-3280. FOUR NINETY TWO.
NINETY SIX NINETY EIGHT AND
NINETY NINE. ONE OH FOUR ONE OH
EIGHT TO ONE TEN. ONE SEVENTEEN
TO ONE TWENTY ONE. ONE THIRTY.
1-351-382-1403. 451-408-2150
ONE. ONE FIFTY SIX ONE FIFTY
EIGHT TO ONE FIFTY NINE. ONE
SEVENTY ONE. ONE SEVENTY FOUR
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT ONE SEVENTY
NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE TO ONE
EIGHTY THR. ONE EIGHTY
SIX TO ONE NINETY FOUR. BOB.
THE BRAVE NEW WORLD TOUR IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THESE ITEMS.
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DR SO THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE REMEMBER TO SPEAK AND
HEAR MIKE'S CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN HI RUSSEL I. THE MOTION
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WE WILL BE VOTING ON ISSUES.
NUMBER FIVE EIGHT. THIRTY.
FORTY SIX. FORTY NINE TO FIFTY
TWO. 542-566-1260 EIGHT.
SEVENTY SEVENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY
SEVEN. EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE TO EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY NINETY ONE NINETY THREE
NIN
TWO. ONE OH THREE ONE OH FIVE
TO ONE OH SEVEN. ONE ELEVEN. TO
ONE THIRTEEN. ONE TWENTY TWO.
TO ONE TWENTY FIVE. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN TO ONE TWENTY NINE.
322-134-1361 THIRTY SEVEN. ONE
FORTY SIX ONE FORTY SEVEN.
532-154-1621 SEVENTY. ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY THREE
AND. ONE SEVENTY FIVE TO ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STE ONE NINETY
FOUR IS THAT INCLUDED IN THAT
LIST ONE NINETY FOUR. THE THING
OKAY. YEAH OKAY NO IT'S NOT ON
MY LIST. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THESE ITEMS. SO THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DR SO THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE REMEMBER
TO SPEAK AND HEAR MAKES
CABALLERO BY YOU'LL SEND NO
RUSSELL NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION PASSES. NEXT WE
WILL BE VOTING ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR. FIFTY THREE NINETY
FOUR ONE ON ONE. ONE FOURTEEN
THROUGH SIX. AND ONE NINETY
FIVE. AT THE STATE. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THESE ITEMS
SO MOVE THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR ALSO SHE'S ON A ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
BY. YOU'LL SEND ABSTAINING.
DRESSER BY. MOTION PASSES.
FINALLY WE WILL TAKE A- VOTE ON
THE DISCUSSION ITEM. BEGINNING
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE NINETY SIX.
OKAY MANY NEED A LITTLE NOTE
WHAT'S WHICH ARE THE ITEMS.
OKAY. THE LAN PARTY SIERRA.
HOLD ON. THAT. OKAY. RELATED ON.
YEAH YEAH. SO DOWN. AND WE'RE
CENTER. WHY ARE WE THE PEOPLE.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE ISSUE
TOOL FIVE. IS THERE A MOTION.
ON THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS ITEM. WILL MOVE TO APPROVE
THANK YOU- THE MOTION THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR DERIVE SO- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CABALLERO I FEEL SEND STAINING.
DRESS THOUGH YES HI. THE MOTION
PASSES AND- THE LAST ITEM IS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS ITEM NUMBER
TWO OH SIX THE CLOSURE BARSTOW
BETTER AND HOME IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. SO MOLD. THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DURAZO THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF AREA HI NIELSEN NO.
DRESS THE HI. GOING BACK TO THE
VOTE ON THAT I MISS READ THE
MOTION MADAM CHAIR I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY IT'S LATE- AT IT SO-
MADAM SECRETARY. I'M SORRY.
OKAY BUT TO THE WE WILL STRIKE
THE ROLE AND REDO THE ROLL CALL.
HAVE AREA HI NIELSEN I DRESSED
SO FINE. MOTION PASSES. IN THE
FOR RICHARD OVER OPEN. THE
THING IS A PRODUCTION. CLOSE IT
IS THE SAME THING THIS PARADISE
IN EFFECT. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
YOUR FUNDING AND THEN THAT
WOULD SIGNAL THANK YOU TO ALL
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE INCLUDE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR THE
SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
STATE. ADMINISTRATION AND SO WE
ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH TIME.